Kekona
from those days that are gone
Twitchy Modes
from long ago
made you feel
you're not alone
Kappa Pog Champ
Keep a forehead
Bible Thumb
Twitchy Modes
I remember
!
You're not alone, Kappa Pong Champ, Keep a forehead, Bible Thumb, Witchy Maltz.
Still hear his bark in the morning hour, he calls me, his doggy malt reminds me of a time far away.
Looking at a chat I get a feeling that I miss emotes from yesterday, yesterday.
Twitch emotes from long ago made you feel you're not alone.
Pong is Pongchamp
Cap is Cap-Pong
Bible Thumb
Twitchy Moles
Pepperns
Bible Thumb
Twitchy Moles
So, da bin ich.
Ich muss noch mal kurz wohin
Und ich muss noch mal
Mein Microsoft fertig futtern
Ich war echt verwirrt
Warte mal
Erst mal Headset entknoten
Heute Morgen habe ich auf die Uhr geguckt und habe gesagt, boah, schon 8.42 Uhr, jetzt muss der aber echt mal aufstehen.
Dann habe ich erst gecheckt, eben gerade, dass hier heute Nacht Zeitumstellung war.
Ja, das ist kein richtiges Crossword, das ist so ein Fake-Crossword, so ein Ding vom Lidl.
Das ist was so heißt, aber eigentlich was ganz anderes ist.
Oh, eine Pillenmuschel, die habe ich auch vergessen.
Ich glaube, das können wir wieder zumachen.
Ich war afk.
Und wie war es bei euch die Woche?
Falls ihr irgendwelche Videos habt
Für Youtube
Wo ihr sagt, die müssen wir unbedingt zusammen gucken
Könnt ihr mal Bescheid sagen
Ich hab heute gar nicht großartig rumgeguckt
Vor dem Stream
Was wir uns angucken können
Ah
Ah, VM
Ne, nicht VM starten
Die will immer noch die VM starten laufen
Aber falsch.
Muss ja gar nicht die VM starten.
Muss ja den Mini-PC starten.
Und ich immer noch nicht weiß,
warum mein Dev-Container drauf nicht richtig funktioniert.
Achte das verdammte Spiel.
Moin.
Ich habe noch etwas vergessen.
Ich muss die Maus-Sharing-Software starten.
So.
Exzellent.
Logitech.
Dreimal noch starten.
Der sich aus irgendwelchen Gründen, warum auch immer, nicht von alleine startet.
Muss man nicht verstehen.
Ist aber so.
Ja, ja.
So, jetzt müsste es eigentlich gehen mit dem Umschalten.
Ja, wusst.
Exzellent.
Wobbly Windows.
Das Beste.
Zack, Firefox
Was, was will Firefox
Geh weg
Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment, was ist das
Warum ist da oben ein VPN Knopf
Was passiert wenn ich da drauf klicke
Try Firefox
Bild in VPN
Äh
Was ist das
Das ist neu, das kenne ich noch nicht
Getting started
aber muss ich man muss sein innen dass das funktioniert okay okay dann würde ich sagen
kann man das nicht einfach remote toolbar und tschüss weg terminal full screen und jetzt hier
erstmal date arch by the way er ist immer hier 2,5 giga updates jetzt gibt es
gratis vpm wie ist das so bandbreiten technisch hat das thema schon mal
ausprobiert dass firefox vp
dann kann man damit zum beispiel irgendwelche streams oder so gucken
was ich gerne machen würde ab und zu ist zum beispiel übertragung von
irgendwelchen fahrradrennen und es ist ja unglaublich schwer generell
ratsport zu folgen wenn man nicht irgendwie ich weiß nicht mal wo es dann
gescheit es gibt paid abo hat aber in den jeweiligen ländern wo die renne
ausgetragen werden gibt es meistens kostenlose streams geht das kann das
dass firefox vpn ist das dafür schnell genug das herausgefunden was mit der
nvm los war
es scheint aber ich habe eine vermutung das scheint irgendwie an zfs zu liegen
Vielleicht hat sich da irgendwelche Default-Parameter geändert oder kamen neue Sachen dabei seit
dem letzten ZFS-Update.
Vielleicht liegt es daran.
Naja, nachdem ich das NAS noch nicht in Betrieb habe, habe ich auch noch Paperless nicht in
Betrieb.
Bist du noch in den Regen gekommen?
Bisschen ja, aber nicht wirklich schlimm.
Ich glaube, ich weiß nicht, ob du den gleich...
Es gibt so einen Channel, der
auf YouTube
der filmt quasi nur
bergab
und fährt teilweise auch sehr risiko
behaftet, ja.
So mit an irgendwelchen parkenden
Autos vorbei und
das ist auch was, wo ich mir denken würde,
ne, das müsst ihr jetzt nicht
unbedingt sein.
Ne, ich folge so ab und zu ganz gerne
so größeren Radsport-Events, aber
es ist halt schwierig, sich Streams anzugucken,
weil
die meistens nur auf die Länder beschränkt
sind, in denen das stattfindet oder
irgendwelche anderen Länder, die das übertragen
und da musst du aber in dem Land sein mit
deiner IP, dass du dir das angucken kannst.
Deswegen wäre so ein Firefox-VPN
vielleicht gar nicht verkehrt, wenn das halt
die Bandbreite, weiß ich nicht, ob das die Bandbreite
für irgendwelche Streams hat.
Soll ich mal kurz meine Pillen noch nehmen?
So, jetzt haben wir Updates gemacht, gucken wir mal ob es hier noch Updates gibt, gucken
wir mal ob es bei JetBrains noch Updates gibt.
Aha, hier gibt es Updates.
Chatterino wurde geupdatet, JetBrains Toolbox.
dann dann mal mit chat brinks toolbox noch mal aus machen erst mal ein update davon
und dann gucken wir chat brinks updates chatarino starten wir auch dann müssen wir wahrscheinlich
noch mal gut gab es ein kölner update eigentlich mega kein kölner wird sich das richtig kein
kölner update wenn es kein kölner update gab dann müssen wir auch nicht riemen das läuft
Yes.
Wenn ich das richtig gelesen habe,
haben die Bandbreite einmal nur 25 Gigs,
sind kostenlos.
Oh.
Ja gut.
Mit 25 Gigs kommt man.
Also ich lasse die Sachen auch gerne
nebenher laufen.
Und so eine Etappe von
irgendeinem, oder auch wenn es
ein Tagesrennen ist,
geht ja schon mal so
5 Stunden
und dann sind die
25 Gig aber ganz schnell weg
was kostet das denn
Firefox VPN
das müssen wir uns gerade mal angucken
so wollen wir hier noch Updates
pro Monat
ein bisschen wenig
ah guck mal hier jede Menge Updates
25 wird Upgedated auf
Außer Rider
Rider bekommt nochmal
25.3.4
Okay, wie war denn? Update
Mal gucken, wie schnell es jetzt
Auf der Kiste ist
Auf der 4M hat das ja immer richtig
Krass rumgerödelt und war lahm
As fuck, wenn man viele Jetbrains
Sachen gleichzeitig geupdatet hat
By the way, mir fehlt immer noch ein bisschen RAM
Hier, guck mal, der Mini-PC
der hat immer noch nur 8g gramm also eine zweite eine zweite 8g muster wie
sieht eigentlich die last mal kurz lasst mal kurz checken wie sieht eigentlich
die die ram preisentwicklung so aus sie ist es immer noch so krass hier genau 88
es oder ddr 5 perfekt
Preis pro Gig.
Guck mal, das geht sogar halbwegs.
Amazon.
Hast du die Google News gelesen?
Welche Google News?
Oh, guck mal, es ist ein bisschen günstiger geworden.
Kann das sein?
Kann das sein, dass die Rampreise wieder ein bisschen runter sind?
Okay, das muss ich mal angucken, mal irgendwas
Gescheites hier
Das da zum Beispiel
Naja
Ne, nicht wirklich
Die sind nicht
Die sind nicht wirklich viel runter
Ein bisschen, ein bisschen runter, hä?
Ein bisschen, ein bisschen ist es
Weniger geworden
Ja, dann kaufe ich mir doch einfach noch ein zweites 8-Gig-Modul, weil ich habe ja noch ein Slot frei.
Mama chatarino
Was das msn punkt kommt alle das hatte ich erst drei jahre mehr auf acht 30 jahre
Google
moment moment moment moment warum habe ich hier so warum macht er denn firefox
developer edition auf
Okay, da muss ich jetzt erst einmal hier
U-Block, Origin, Firefox
Developer Edition
Also das muss sein, weil
ohne
kriegst du ja da echt Anfälle,
wenn du Seiten hier ohne
Blocke aufmachst.
So.
Google AI Breakthrough is pressuring
Memory Chip Stocks from Samsung to
Micron
Aha
Und das
Das heißt jetzt was?
Diese Seite ist so unübersichtlich
Was lieber
64 Gig ECC
Oder 128 Non ECC
im Homelab. Ja gut, das kommt ein bisschen drauf an,
was dir wichtig ist, ja. Wenn dir das,
was ECC
bietet, wichtig ist, dann
ECC,
wenn du,
also ich bin, also weißt du, was ich machen würde?
Weißt du, was ich wahrscheinlich machen würde?
Ich würde wahrscheinlich 64 Gig
Non-ECC kaufen,
weil es deutlich günstiger ist
und ECC jetzt
nicht unbedingt
muss man haben ist.
Ich weiß, dass Rinas Forum sieht das anders
Ja
Wenn du
Ist halt die Frage, willst du viele VMs laufen lassen
Kommst du irgendwie ans Limit bei 64 Gig
Man muss nämlich auch dazu sagen
Also
SOdim
ECC
Gibt es ganz wenige RAM Riegel
Also nur ganz ganz wenige Hersteller
Insgesamt jetzt
Also
brauchst du es oder normaler größe medien server ein paar docker container dafür
brauchst du wahrscheinlich noch nicht einmal 64 g dafür würden wahrscheinlich sogar 32 g reichen
normal okay dann geht's dann geht's aber musste mal gucken also wenn ihr das das preislich wert
ist, also ganz ehrlich, 128
Gig brauchst du nicht für ein bisschen
Medienserver und Docker-Container.
Also ich meine, okay, wenn du jetzt
Docker-Container laufen lassen willst,
die selbst wiederum, also jetzt
was ich meine ist halt, man braucht jetzt nicht
für ein paar Docker-Container automatisch viel RAM,
wenn die Docker-Container selbst
halt viel RAM brauchen, zum Beispiel
weil man irgendwelche
KI-Sachen laufen lassen will oder sowas, ja,
dann braucht man auch viel RAM.
Aber
wenn du da die üblichen Verdächtigen
laufen lassen willst, wenn ich so an Medienserver
denke, wird das wahrscheinlich
Sternchen R sein,
was du laufen lassen willst.
Ähm,
also, wahrscheinlich
brauchst du nicht immer 64 Gig.
Aber für Medienserver und Docker-Container
brauchst du auf jeden Fall schon mal keinen, nicht unbedingt ECC ran.
Ja, kommt also wie gesagt, kommt drauf an, was deine Docker-Container verbrauchen.
Aber ich würde mal eher drauf tippen, 64GB non-ECC reichen da auch dicke aus.
Es sei denn, du willst unbedingt ECC-Rabendotus, man.
Das kann ich dir jetzt ja nicht sagen, ob du das brauchst.
Mal angenommen, du hast ZFS laufen und willst es noch sicherer machen, als es eh schon ist.
Quasi auch noch irgendwelche geflipten Bits während der Übertragung abfangen.
Was halt kein... also naja.
Dann ECC-RAM.
Man braucht aber für ZFS kein ECC-RAM.
Auch wenn das Freenas-Forum da was anderes behauptet.
ZFS ist immer noch sicherer ohne ECC RAM wie andere Fallsysteme ohne ECC RAM.
Das darf man nicht vergessen.
Naja, also du brauchst nicht unbedingt ECC für ZFS.
Man kann ZFS ohne Probleme auch ohne ECC RAM laufen lassen.
Wie gesagt, das Freenas Forum sah das früher ja immer anders.
Da wurdest du geflamed.
Aber das Freenas Forum ist auch nur eins hinter dem Mikrocontroller Forum.
Vom, sagen wir mal, vom Nettigkeitsfaktor her.
Da würde ich dir nicht so viel drauf geben.
ECC ist nicht wirklich wichtig.
Aus meiner Sicht, ja.
Also ECC kannst du dir in der Regel eigentlich schenken.
Warte mal, ich muss noch kurz niesen.
Boah.
Also ich bin nicht mehr erkältet, ne.
das alles schon weg sein über eine woche aber irgendwie läuft man morgen bisschen die nase
aber jetzt nicht so erkältungs mäßig sondern weiß ich will ich bestimmt einer zeitumstellung
also da musst du dir generell keinen gedanken darüber machen wenn leute im internet wegen
irgendwas rum flamen also ich bin der meinung im heimbereich ist etc haben jetzt nicht so wichtig
Bitfehler an sich
sind jetzt ja auch nicht wahnsinnig häufig
und dass dir das da
irgendwas unwiederbringbar
zerstört, das ist sehr sehr unwahrscheinlich
das ist richtig
du brauchst natürlich auch einen Server der ECC RAM unterstützt
das kommt ja auch noch dabei, das ist richtig
was auch viele
Geräte gar nicht machen, also zum Beispiel
mein NAS kann das gar nicht
das hat zwar witzigerweise im BIOS
ein Setting für ECC RAM
aber die CPU, die eingebaut ist, unterstützt überhaupt keinen ECC-Rahmen.
Also fragt mich nicht, was die sich da gedacht haben.
Keine Ahnung.
Wenn das jetzt irgendeine Kiste wäre,
sagen wir, ich würde bei einer Versicherung arbeiten
oder bei einer Bank arbeiten oder so
und das wäre irgendein Archivsystem,
wo so revisionssicher und und nach gesetzlichen regelungen daten für zehn plus jahre irgendwie
immer schief gespeichert werden müssen und auch einzelne kleine fehler dazu ganz viele problemen
für und führen könnten ja dann würde ich auch etc aber einbauen aber ich kann
dir nur sagen ich betreibe meine server auch ohne etc
haben die letzten server den ich mit etc ram hatte nach was wo ich untersuchen
serverraum vielleicht
Der letzte Server, den ich mit ECC-RAM hatte, war diese große fette 4HE-Kiste hier.
Seitdem.
Und das ist...
Guck mal, das Video war schon vor 5 Jahren und da habe ich umgebaut.
Das war 6 Jahre her.
Also...
Ich habe seit 6 Jahren daheim keinen Server mit ECC-RAM.
Ich vermisse das nicht und ich habe es in Zukunft auch nicht vor, wieder ECC-RAM.
Ach, guck mal hier.
2017, da hat man es doch ganz gut gesehen.
Die Kiste hier war mit ECC-RAM.
Hier da oben. Die Kiste
war mit ECC-RAM.
Das war auch, also das war für die
damalige Zeit brutal Oversized, was ich
mir da gekauft habe. Das habe ich mir komplett
selbst zusammengebaut damals.
Also Gehäuse gekauft, Mainboard gekauft,
alles mögliche.
Das war richtig, richtig, richtig
teuer und Oversized für mich daheim.
Das hatte 2017 schon alles 10 Gig und sowas.
Mainboard.
Stimmt, was waren da für CPUs drauf?
Da muss ich jetzt mal kurz gucken.
Was hatte ich denn damals für CPUs?
Intel Xeon D.
Okay, was war das für einer?
Muss ich mal kurz gucken.
Das weiß ich gar nicht mehr, was das für einer gewesen ist.
Guck mal, Alter.
Das Ding hatte damals schon 8 Kerne.
Das war brutal
Oversized
8 Kerne, 16 Threads
Okay
Die
Die Taktfrequenz
War jetzt nicht sonderlich hoch
Aber das war eine richtige
POG CPU damals
Guck mal hier
Also das war ein ordentliches
Teil.
Man muss überlegen, das Nass, was ich
jetzt habe, was ich 2026
gekauft habe,
das hat auch 8 Kerne und ist
schneller. Das ist ein halbwegs aktueller
Ryzen. Aber da liegen
halt auch mal fast 10 Jahre dazwischen.
gab es schon die ersten Threadripper. Ja, kann sein.
Aber das...
Guck mal, das gibt es seit 2015.
Also das Ding war damals echt ziemlich
ähm
Oversized für mich daheim
Die Kiste hier
Video du darfst angehen
Die war etwas Oversized für mich
würde ich sagen. Ich weiß nicht, mache ich das Ding denn
überhaupt noch auf irgendwo mal im Video,
dass man reingucken kann?
Ähm.
Ich mache vorne auf, wo man die
Platten sieht.
Oder? Genau.
Ich hatte damals auch extra
so einen Wechselrahmen gekauft mit
Hotswap-Fähigkeit. Also ich habe, das
war mein erstes und einziges komplettes
Server-Build, wo ich wirklich
alles selbst gekauft habe und alles selbst gebaut habe.
Also ich muss sagen, das Ding, das war auch stable.
So ist das nicht.
Ist jetzt nicht so, als würde ich,
als hätte ich es ausgetauscht, weil es irgendwie Schrott war.
Nee, nee, das hat wunderbar funktioniert.
Wahrscheinlich hätte ich das auch noch Jahre weiter verwenden können.
Aber mir war insgesamt, ehrlich gesagt,
das total Oversize und der Stromverbrauch auch zu hoch.
Hast du schon das Lohnt sich das Finanzamt Video gesehen?
Nee.
Habe ich noch nicht.
Guck mal, damals hatte ich, was hatte ich hier für Festplatten?
Guck mal, das sind das, das sind, ähm,
WD-Green, oder?
2 Terabyte, guck mal.
2 Terabyte WD-Green-Platten.
Das ist gut, das war 2017, ne?
Ach, guck mal hier, hier mache ich sogar auf, die Kiste.
Ist immer ein bisschen sidetracked, aber okay.
Guck mal, da ist noch der uralte
access point das ist ein tp link der billigste tp link access point überhaupt man muss aber sagen
ein vorteil hatte diese alten diese alte access point krempe der eine access point hier oben im
ersten stock in der ecke hat für das komplette haus und die terrasse gereicht mittlerweile
brauche ich mehr access points dafür der war halt auch lahm das war glaube ich maximum 56
mbit oder sowas also das schnell schnell war das teil nett aber ging besser durch wände durch aber
von der abdeckung her so ein publischer access point in der ecke im ersten stock fürs ganze
haus nicht schlecht also das umso langsamer das wlan und so besser geht es durch die wände und
es war 2,4 Gigahertz.
Ja.
Jetzt brauche ich mehrere Access Points dafür.
Oh, naja.
Gut, ich wette mit euch,
Leute, die Kommentare sind voll.
Alter, Max, Kabelmanagement.
Oh, lulululul.
Oder irgendwie sowas in der Richtung.
Nee, gucken wir jetzt nicht rein, aber das steht garantiert
in den Kommentaren. Die Leute machen sich ja immer
gerne wichtig, was Kabelmanagement angeht.
Oder, oder...
Chat, erinnert
sich noch einer dran? Mikrorisse?
Mikrorisse im
Mainboard?
Weil ich das Gehäuse auf die
Seite gedreht hab, Mikrorisse
im Mainboard hab ich jetzt. Also, Chat,
ich muss sagen,
für das, dass mein Mainboard ja voller
Mikrorisse ist, funktioniert mein
Rechner erstaunlich stabil.
Ja, da sieht man, das war schon ein bisschen gebastelt, was ich da gebaut habe.
Und zwar der Lüfter.
Hier, der Lüfter war mir eigentlich zu laut.
Deswegen habe ich den gemoddet mit einem Noctua-Lüfter.
Also ich habe den ursprünglichen Lüfter rausgemacht, also abgeschraubt von der CPU.
und hab einen Noctur-Lüfter drauf gemacht.
Und das waren noch
SAS-Platten.
Äh, nee.
Das waren SATA-Platten, aber es waren
SAS-Controller, so rum.
Guck mal, was das für ein ultra-fettes
Mainboard noch war.
Guck mal, wie fett das Mainboard ist, Alter.
hinten auch der teure noktor lüfter den habe ich glaube ich heute sogar noch
irgendwo im im einsatz der ich weiß jetzt kann ich wo aber die habe ich da
alle wieder raus gebaut die noktor lüfter und habt ihr jetzt wobei ich
glaube jetzt mittlerweile nicht mehr meint habe ich hatte die oder ich glaube
ich habe die in meinem vorschau rechner die noktor lüfter drin
Beim Stream-Vorschau-Rechner, der hier neben steht.
Naja.
Zumindest das war die letzte Kiste, die ich selbst gebaut habe.
Mit ECC-RAM.
Und die lief gut, aber ECC-RAM wäre auch ohne gegangen.
Ich habe mich damals wahrscheinlich vom Freenas-Forum beschwätzen lassen,
dass unbedingt ECC-RAM und ZFS sein muss.
Also kaputte Lüfte hatte ich auch nur sehr selten.
Das einzige, wo ich mich jetzt wirklich spontan noch dran erinnern kann, war, ich hatte mal ein Mainboard von Asus.
Asus...
für einen...
Athlon XP, glaube ich.
Warte mal, das muss ich jetzt mal gucken.
Ihr wisst, dass ich auf so altes Zeug stehe.
Asus Mainboard,
Athlon XP.
Und...
War das vielleicht sowas hier?
Es hatte zumindest
einen Lüfter.
Einen Lüfter auf dem Mainboard.
Und der ist...
Ne, das sah schon besser aus.
Das hatte Nvidia Chipset.
Kann man da vielleicht noch danach suchen?
Athlon 64 könnte auch sein.
Enforce 2 im Test.
Okay, okay.
Ja, ja.
Die Northbridge, die Southbridge damals.
Weiß ich nicht, ob es da Bilder...
Zumindest ist er auch vollkommen egal.
Zumindest hatte ich damals ein Mainboard von Asus.
Ne, das war das nicht.
Das war ein Mainboard mit einem Kühler drauf.
Und der Kühler, das war auch bekannt bei Asus, der war kaputt.
den konnte man sich umtauschen lassen.
Ich war aber zu faul, den Lüfter umtauschen zu lassen
und habe den jahrelang damit kaputt mit dem Lüfter betrieben.
Und da muss man ja echt mal sagen, Hut ab, Hut ab von vor Asus.
Ich habe dann irgendwann, keine Ahnung,
zwei oder drei Jahre später den Rechner auseinandergebaut
und dachte mir, ey, jetzt ist eigentlich ein guter Zeitpunkt,
den Lüfter zu tauschen.
Da konnte ich irgendwie drei oder vier Jahre später
noch bei Asus
den Lüfter austauschen lassen.
Und das hat funktioniert.
Also der war
ist gut damals.
so sah das nicht aus, ach keine Ahnung
finde ich nicht mehr
aber zumindest
weiß ich noch, dass das mit
ja, das sieht schon ein bisschen eher aus
zumindest weiß ich noch, dass das mit
Nvidia Chipset war
damals hat ja tatsächlich Nvidia noch
Mainboard Sachen hergestellt
war glaube ich das letzte
Chipset, die die damals hergestellt haben
danach gab es das nicht mehr
Und damals habe ich den Fehler gemacht, das Raid von Nvidia zu benutzen.
Damals konnte man mit dem Nvidia Chipset, konnte man quasi so zwei Festplatten in RAID 0 zusammenschalten.
Und das hat überhaupt nicht richtig funktioniert.
Ich hatte damals zwei 80 Gig Festplatten, waren glaube ich 80 Gig, 80 Gig Festplatten im RAID 0.
Also das war noch vor SSD und allem.
und das Problem war,
ab und zu ist der Rechner abgekackt.
Und wenn du den Rechner
nicht schnell genug resettet hast,
hat es angefangen, das Raid zu zerstören.
Du musst es wirklich, sobald du gemerkt hast,
oh, der Rechner hängt, musst du es sofort
runterresett.
Und wenn du nicht am Rechner warst, wenn er immer hängen geblieben ist,
hat es dir dein Raid halb zerschossen.
Also das war ganz, ganz großer
Crap, Alter.
dieses Nvidia
RAID 1 damals bei den
Athlon XP Boards.
Du hast dir einen 5 Luft
gekauft, Beste.
Das Ding ist nur,
also wie gesagt,
die Netzwerkkarte geht mir extrem auf den Sack
und die
SSD Performance ist auch sehr variabel.
Drücken wir es mal so aus.
Das könnte aber auch an der Software liegen.
Wir müssen noch,
wir müssen da demnächst übrigens mal
testweise
Arch, by the way, drauf installieren.
Vielleicht installiere ich das am besten auf
einen USB-Stick oder sowas. Oder ne,
ich installiere das einfach auf einen der zweiten
SSDs.
A8NS, das könnte tatsächlich
sogar ein SLI-Mainboard gewesen sein.
Ne, passiv, so ein
Passivkühler hatte das nicht drauf.
So sah das
nicht aus.
Aber das
Mainboard sieht in der Tat recht...
Ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne.
Das hatte hier kein...
Ne, Moment, was ist das hier überhaupt?
Doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, das könnte es sein.
Dieser hässliche Lüfter, genau.
Was ist denn das hier?
Was bin ich denn hier sehend? Was ist denn das?
Sieht aus wie ein S0-Ram-Sockel,
aber was ist denn das?
Chat, habt ihr irgendwie einen Plan, was das ist?
Das Teil hier?
Sieht aus wie ein S0-Ram-Sockel, oder?
Du hast recht, das ist das Mainboard.
Du hast recht, das ist es.
Deluxe.
Ja.
Das ist das Mainboard.
Du hast recht.
Aber was ist...
Chat hat...
Hä?
Was ist denn das hier?
Kann mir das irgendjemand...
Der sieht aus wie ein S0-Sockel.
Dual-Videocard.
Was ist das denn?
Da muss ich mal kurz...
Das interessiert mich jetzt.
Da muss ich mal kurz nach dem Manual suchen von dem Ding.
Manual.
Gibt es das noch?
Guck mal, Asus hat da sogar noch hier die...
Natürlich.
Natürlich hat sie das nicht.
Manuals.
Bedienungsanleitung.
Ja, ja.
Kann man da...
Kann man da bei Asus irgendwie...
Support only?
Kann man da irgendwie noch danach...
Ups.
SO?
Nicht S0?
Ja, was auch immer.
SO-Dimm.
Andere Modelle finden.
Okay, gut hier.
Produkte.
Mainboard.
Support.
Okay, wie finde ich...
Oh, man.
Manual.
Wie heißt das Ding?
A8N SLI.
A8N SLI Manual.
Aha, hier.
Guck mal.
Da ist es. Release 2005. Ja, es kommt hin. Da müssen wir mal gucken, was das für ein komischer...
Was war das? Genau, was das hier für ein komisches Ding ist.
When used to graphics, but do not plug in Easy Plug. Was?
Okay, das ist der SLI-Konnektor?
Was?
Das ist der SLI-Konnektor?
So.
Ups.
Sah
Sah SLI damals so aus?
Ne oder hä?
Das ist ein SO dem Sockel
Oder?
Jetzt bin ich maximal verwirrt was das ist
Das ist der SLI Connector
Ich check's nicht
Ja ich check's null
Ich check's absolut gar nicht was das ist
Hast du kein Plastikschirm?
Ich dachte auch, SLI kommt oben über die Grafikkarten drüber.
Was zum Teufel?
Das verwirrt mich richtig hart.
Aber die sagen offiziell, das ist der SLI-Connector.
Einfach nicht hinterfragen.
Guck mal, das hat er noch.
Das Mainboard hat tatsächlich noch PCI-Steckplätze gehabt.
Da kann ich mich gar nicht...
Das war schon, ich dachte PC Express alles.
Muss ich mir jetzt angucken.
Weiß nicht, also.
Irgendwie macht mich, beschäftigt mich das jetzt mehr als es sollte.
Hatten die da, die ersten Varianten nicht einfach einen bestehenden Connect?
Ich habe keine Ahnung mehr.
Ich hatte damals nie SLI.
Jetzt auch nicht.
Das muss ich mir jetzt angucken.
So, wo baut man RAM ein?
Das heißt ja nicht viel Unterschied zu heute.
PC Slots.
Express Slots.
This motherboard does not support
the scalable link interface mode
for two identical.
Was?
Hä?
Jetzt verstehe ich es noch weniger.
Es hat SLI, aber es supportet nicht SLI.
Hä?
Was?
Okay.
Damals wäre ich auch maximal verwirrt gewesen.
Da hast du noch...
Ah, guck mal hier.
Du hattest noch PS2 und einen Druckerport.
Wobei, Druckerport ist ja eigentlich verkehrt.
Das ist ein Parallelport.
Parallelport
Aber immerhin schon Onboard-Netzwerk
Zeug, ordentliche Audioanschlüsse
Wahrscheinlich mit absolut mieser Qualität
Hatte das eigentlich schon
USB, ne das hat nur alles USB 2
War noch kein USB 3 am Start
So ich warte jetzt bis hier
Der SLI-Connector mal gezeigt wird
Der IEE1395...
Ist das Firewire, Leute? Kann das sein?
Ist das...
Ist das Firewire?
Das ist fucking Fire...
Moment! Mein Mainboard hatte damals
Firewire!
Da kann ich mich ja gar nicht mehr dran erinnern!
Firewire, Alter!
Sagt das überhaupt
jemand noch was?
Never connect a USB-Cable to doing so much damage to mother...
Konnte man das überhaupt connecten?
Klar.
Okay, wo ist der SLI?
Ich will jetzt wissen, wie das funktioniert.
Okay, das ist so obvious für die, dass das da überhaupt keine...
überhaupt keine erklärung überhaupt mehr braucht dazu ja das ist so ob wir es wie das ding funktioniert
das aha ok installing sr die graphics card prepared graphics cards ist kräftig goldfinger ja genau oben
Okay, das wird eingebaut
Ja
Und dann
Ja, was zum Teufel ist denn jetzt
Dieses Ding hier
Was
Aha, Moment, Moment, Moment
Jetzt kriegen wir es erklärt
Setting der Asus Eats Cards
Selector Card
die it's it's selektor card ok your mother package comes preinstalled asus it's selektor
card it's by default the card is set for a single graphics card to use two graphics
cards and you must first set the selektor card to dual video card locate the selektor
Card und dem Motherboard.
Push
die Knöppe.
Pull the Selector Card
out. Invert.
Man schaltet
damit um zwischen Single
Kartenbetrieb und mehrerem
Kartenbetrieb.
Das ist ein Jumper. Ein großer Jumper
quasi im Endeffekt.
Alter, das war
ja richtig, richtig Pfeifett
damals für SLI.
Okay, immerhin. Jetzt wissen wir, was das ist.
Man flippt das quasi so
für Dual- und Single-Card.
Habt ihr sowas jemals schon gesehen?
Also das war
mir jetzt komplett neu. Aber gut, immerhin
Geheimnis gelüftet,
Leute. Um mein
Mainboard, was ich vor
20 Jahren hatte, Alter.
Das hat schon 1 Gigabit, ja?
Das war richtig, richtig, richtig geiles Board
damals.
Ich hieß Pock, Pockbord.
Gibt es das heute eigentlich noch zu kaufen?
Ich gebe es jetzt einfach mal just for fun bei.
What?
Moment.
Nee.
Gibt es nicht mehr.
Gebraucht gibt es das Ganze noch für 60 Euro bei Ebay.
Was? Letzter Preis.
Jetzt können wir mal alles zumachen hier.
Reboot.
Nee, eigentlich nicht Reboot.
So, hat der Kram jetzt
alles geupdatet?
Jawohl.
Excellent, excellent, excellent, excellent.
Gut, Chad.
Jetzt wurden wir
leicht sidetracked, würde ich sagen.
Du, ganz leicht.
Wir wurden 30 Minuten sidetracked oder 25, 30 Minuten sidetracked von einem Mainboard, was ich vor 20 Jahren hatte, wo ich absolut nichts davon habe, dass ich jetzt weiß, was dieser komische Schalter auf meinem 20 Jahre alten Mainboard gemacht hätte, hätte ich ihn damals gesetzt.
Aber gut, manchmal muss ja nicht alles einen Sinn haben.
Gut, dann gucken wir doch mal, was trendet denn auf Shithub?
diese woche so today was trendet today super powers
real time face swap and one click video deep fake with okay leute leute leute
also wenn ich das hier lese weiß ich doch sofort instant wofür die leute das
verwenden werden oder das doch das doch so klar was hat was mit sowas direkt direkt läuft
salesforce monka s ai ai ai ai ok schalten wir das mal um auf was sinnvolles dies week
Also.
AI.
Was ist das denn?
Open Source Long Horizon?
Alter, da verstehe ich ja nicht mal den ersten Satz.
An open source, long horizon, super agent harness.
What?
Chat, kann mir das irgendjemand...
Okay, wir fragen jetzt einfach.
Wir fragen jetzt einfach AI.
Was macht dieses Projekt?
Ne, Eli5, this project.
Machen wir jetzt.
Deerflow bei Open Source Super Agent.
Ja, was? Ich weiß doch nicht, was ein Super Agent Harness ist, Alter.
Chat, Chat, jetzt mal Hand aufs Herz, ja?
Hat irgendjemand von euch denn Ahnung, was ein Super Agent Harness ist?
ok wir fragen mal chat gpt vielleicht kann das besser wir können auch perplexity fragen wir
können auch noch die china china china china chinesen model auch noch was ist wir fragen
jetzt einfach mal alle alles wird jetzt gefragt so also chat gpt sagt es auf die
Dear Floor as a team of smart robot helpers instead of one chatbot.
Normally when you use AI like ChatGPT, it's just one brain talking to you.
But Dear Floor is more like a whole team of AIs working together.
Hä?
Jetzt check ich jetzt aber noch weniger.
Okay, ChatGPT labert hier wieder rum.
One helper makes the plan, another helper looks the...
Ach, sowas ist das!
So mehrere K.I.s, die sich gegenseitig füttern, oder was?
Was?
Oh.
Was sagt das China-Chinesen-Model dazu?
Es denkt, es denkt.
Okay, also Super-Hannes.
Open Source Long Horizon
Super Agent Harness
Ich kann noch was fangen
Was ist ein
Der Ausdruck
Open Source Long Horizon Super Agent Harness
Ist kein einzelner
Fest definierter Fachbegriff
Sondern ein zusammengesetzter
Buzzword Begriff, ja das dachte ich mir ja irgendwie schon
Aus der KI Agenten Szene
Man kann ihn sinnvoll
mit Open Source. Long Horizon.
Das kommt aus der KI-Planung und bedeutet,
der Agent kann über längere Zeiträume
und viele Schritte hinweg planen und dann...
Ach so.
Super Agent.
Mehrere Tools benutzen. Okay.
Harness. Steuerungssystem.
Okay, das macht
jetzt schon mehr Sinn.
Das macht jetzt schon mehr Sinn.
Long Horizon bedeutet,
über längeren Zeitraum, also er hat quasi ein längeres
Gedächtnis, so, okay.
Okay, okay, okay. Jetzt,
ich mein, immerhin haben wir das Projekt jetzt verstanden.
Classic.
KI?
Guck mal,
ein YouTube AI Slop
Generator.
AI? AI?
AI, AI, AI, AI, AI, AI, AI, AI, AI, AI, AI.
WTF.
Ist diese Woche noch irgendwas anderes dabei?
Okay, Language.
C...
Nee, nee, nee, nee.
Komm, komm.
Just for fun.
C++.
Nicht, dass es mich in irgendeiner Art und Weise interessiert.
FreeCut.
Trennet.
Open.
Das hatten wir das letzte Mal schon.
Hatten wir das letzte...
AI.
Nintendo Switch firmen wir.
Dugtibi? Ich dachte, Dugtibi ist written in Rust blazingly fast. Das ist C++ tatsächlich, ja? Ich dachte, Dugtibi ist Rust, Alter. Ne, ist es nicht. Es ist C++. Clipboard Manager, OCR, Time Series, FMT-Lib.
Das, ohne Scheiß Leute, mit FMT-Lib kann man tatsächlich halbwegs sinnvoll in C++ Text printen und formatieren und sowas.
Das ist eines der wenigen C++-Libs, wo ich sagen würde, die ist angenehm, im Rahmen angenehm zu verwenden.
Mittlerweile ist ja auch einiges von FMT-Lib in der Standard-Library angekommen bei C++.
vpn client open battery information hat 1300 sterne aber keine beschreibung alles klar
ok irgendwelches
für akkuschrauber oder was keine ahnung aber warum nicht
Rendering Library, ok.
Damit kann man, ok, dass irgendwas für Game stellt.
Tensors flow Elektron tja da wäre das
da kommen wir nicht dran vorbei mittlerweile ist ja auch die windows taskleiter die windows
taskleiter ist nicht elektron glaube ich zumindest ich weiß nur dass in react programmiert ist
wahrscheinlich react native und dann zu irgendwelchen windows geschichten so also
Also das hat mich jetzt schon mal gar nicht interessiert.
Dann viel interessanter.
Was ist denn in der Blazingly Fast Krustentiere Welt diese Woche am Trend?
Anis.
Minecraft.
Screenpipe.
Agents.
Okay.
KI.
Starship.
Starship ist nice, Leute.
Starship verwende ich auch.
Der Prompt hier ist Starship.
Beste.
Starship ist...
Mir war gar nicht so klar, dass Starship written in Rust ist.
Aber deswegen ist mein Prompt natürlich noch blazingly faster.
Cross-Plattform...
Ah, Gemini ist hier.
Okay.
Jetzt habe ich auch mal ausprobiert, wann ich meins...
Deno?
Codex?
war nicht so spannend dann was trennt bei go magic highly opinionated mt sam das letzte
mal schon da wusste ich auch nicht genau was ein mt proto proxy ist die ploi open
source plattform für creating safe isolated productions sandboxes was wollt ihr von mir
Developer-Centric API
Integration Testing Tool. Ach, Tests.
Keck, wait, Alter.
Trivi. Hatte Trivi nicht richtig krasse
Sicherheitsprobleme
die letzten Wochen über?
Mit, äh, wurden die
nicht auch Supply Chain Attacked oder so?
Da war doch was.
Ich erinnere mich da dunkel
dran, dass da irgendwas war die letzten 1-2 Wochen.
KI?
Kai Kai Kai Schuss hat keine Beschreibung ok China Chinesen Kram wahrscheinlich ok
markt und mehr muss ich nicht sehen
hannes ist das auch ein long horizon das ist nur ein hannes das ist kein long horizon hannes
jetzt das ist das ist ja nicht so gut weil es nicht noch ein bisschen
cloud native manager da weißt du auch nicht wirklich was damit gemeint ist oder der cloud
native manager service engineering plattform ist open source cloud native
manager enables design and management of all kuba netz space infrastructure
applications das ist quasi ein ein meter frontend für kuba netz oder wie ist das
Das könnte in der Tat gar nicht mal so übel sein.
Choose your playground.
Äh, launch.
Was kann man sonst noch?
Natürlich muss ich sign up.
Na klar.
Was ist das jetzt genau?
Das ist so ein Meta-Kubernetes-Dashboard.
dashboard
Krasse animations
Guck mal da hast du auch eine übersicht geht das geht das geht das mit kubernetes services oder nur wenn du service mesh laufen hast
Das scheint mit allem zu gehen
Okay das für übersicht ist ganz ehrlich ich sage ich mal dass hier werden video was von weniger animation profitiert hätte oder
Du kannst dich auf nichts konzentrieren, Alter.
Chat, ich bin einfach nicht mehr Zoomer genug.
Für die Zoomer-Generation ist das sicherlich mega nice.
Ich würde es gerne mal sehen, ohne dass es sich animiert.
Okay, Alter, du kannst, sobald mein Auge sich auf was fokussiert hat, ist es schon wieder weg.
stimmt wenn smash du hast recht wenn da was von
mesch drin steht aber da war auch deployments und so drin eben
also die haben es mit animation wirklich komplett übertrieben
wts alle wir hatten das an die das kannst du dir angucke
okay das aber was man sich was man sich mal im hinterkopf behalten kann das finden sie
die doch im ersten Blick alle mal so schlecht ist. Pocket Base.
Car Agent.
Ah, KI.
TypeScript.
Ah, das ist der
TypeScript Compiler
nach Go
Port von Microsoft.
Da sind ja immer noch
Dicke dabei.
Hab ich da grad Harness gelesen.
Harness scheint so ein neues
Buzzword zu sein.
China-Chinesen-Zeug?
Weisha?
Macht was?
Englisch.
Oh.
Und was soll es sein?
AI-API-Gateway.
Ah, dass du deine Quotas besser auslasten kannst.
Okay, das macht in der Tat Sinn.
wenn man viel ist vielleicht auch mit unterschiedlichen teams benutzt ich
denke auch so was ist also quasi wenn man jetzt mehrere teams hat ja manche teams benutzen er
ein mehr manche weniger und sonst was und dann kaufte anstatt dann für jeden entwickler oder
jedes team den api kaufst du dir ein enterprise kiesel nach dem motto und alle können es darüber
dann benutzen und kannst du besser auslasten ja das ist das so was nicht verkehrt cube ctx
das kenne ich ja das ist ein cube ctl plugin zum cluster switchen und ja es ist heißt cube ctl das
Das heißt nicht Cube Cuttle.
AI.
Okay.
Und jetzt als letztes.
Was passiert bei C Sharp?
So, das ist immer das langweiligste.
Enhance.
Application Design to Optimize.
Enhance the Windows Experience.
Gut, das würde ich wahrscheinlich nicht ausführen.
Aber.
Sieht schon mal verwirrend aus.
WinHands.
Ach, da kann man Zeug quasi installen, uninstallen.
Ja, gut.
Ganz ehrlich, solche Tools sind so alt wie Windows selbst.
Früher war es so, dass solche Tools noch auf irgendwie...
Auf der Computer...
Nee, Computer Build hatte nie eine CD, ne?
Was war denn die PC-Welt oder sowas?
Ja, die CT hat ja meistens damals auch schon sinnvolle Sachen gemacht.
So auf der PC-Welt-CD waren früher solche Tools drauf.
So nach dem Motto 50 Windows-Optimierungstools.
Power Tool.
Stock Sharp.
Trading.
File Manager.
Aspire.
Ich muss mich ja da immer mal outen bei Aspire.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, wozu das eigentlich gut sein soll.
Microsoft hypt das ja schon seit so zwei, drei Jahren, aber absolut keinen Plan, warum und weshalb und was es eigentlich macht.
.NET Runtime.
OCR Tool.
Steam Achievements.
PowerShell.
Jellyfin für die ganzen Linux-Distributionen, Runterlader, Screenshot, Runner, okay.
Was?
C-Sharp Library and Console App for using new Feature Control APIs available in Windows 10.
Was? Windows 10 ist ja auch nochmal das Neueste.
ich weiß überhaupt nicht was es was es sein soll manager class okay ein arm
irgendwelches windows zeug gut jetzt wissen wir bescheid was auf github so
trennt was macht diese maus hier in der mitte ehrlich gesagt also außer dieses
kuba netz dashboard nicht das weiß jetzt nicht so spannend was aber auch daran
liegt das 95 prozent wieder gewesen sind so eine kunde eine runde ask aquarium entspannung trinken
ja ct war damals auch schon gut ich meine ich habe ja seit über 20 jahren oder länger 25 jahren
oder so eine ct abo und ich ließ die eigentlich so gut wie gar nicht mehr aber ich habe das abo
immer noch die die die stapeln sich du meinst wir müssen gucken wir müssen gucken wie das
wetter wird weil wir nicht aus dem fenster gucken können das recht snow
das stimmt hinten und vorne nicht hier schneit doch nix moment ich muss auch kurz in mein
Home Assistant gucken.
Äh, mein Home Assistant ist down.
Was ist denn jetzt los?
Was ist das?
Chat, wir...
Chat, ich glaube,
wir hatten Stromausfall heute Nacht.
Die Kiste im Wohnzimmer ist auch nicht
mehr an. Der Raspberry Pi hier
hängt auch.
Ich glaube, wir haben einen Stromausfall.
Ja klar, deswegen ging heute Morgen auch das Licht nicht an.
Wir haben einen Stromausfall.
Hm.
Der wäre aber auch heute Nacht dann ausgefallen.
Was aber auch heißt...
Doch, ich hab eine USV.
Ey, wisst ihr, was ich gemacht hab?
Ich hab, ähm,
mein NAS an die USV gestöpselt.
Und nicht mehr das NAS,
also, Schwachsinn,
ich hab das neue NAS jetzt an die USV gestöpselt.
Und
das alte,
oh Gott, das ist natürlich wieder geil,
das einzige Mal,
wo mir die USV hätte was bringen können,
habe ich es jetzt vorgestern oder so
umgestöpselt
sehr schlau
ich habe das neue NAS an der USV anhängen
und das alte, also ich habe das neue NAS
ins Rack gestellt
das alte, das hängt jetzt zwar noch dran
aber außerhalb vom Rack
weil ich mir gedacht habe
nächsten 1-2 Wochen baust du das eh ab
Das heißt, das einzige Mal, wo mir die
USV hätte was bringen können,
hat sie jetzt nichts gebracht.
Geil.
Top. GG.
Hat sich ja richtig gelohnt.
Okay, da muss ich
nachher anscheinend
wirklich mal die ganzen Sachen neu starten,
dass das ordentlich funktioniert.
Und das stimmt übrigens auch nicht,
dass es hier schneit.
Also schneien tut hier nichts.
In Hanau.
Das ist aber echt,
das ist aber richtig kacke, dass es
Stromausfall gegeben hat.
Ob das was mit der Zeitumstellung zu tun hat?
Was es in Stromausfall gegeben hat?
Dass die irgendwas verkackt haben?
Wahrscheinlich.
Ist doch eher sonst ein bisschen großer Zufall, oder?
Ah
Komisch
Na gut, dann muss ich nachher ein paar Sachen neu starten
Warum möchtest du Bitworn nicht?
Weil ich Keepers hab
Und ich für mich keinen Grund sehe umzustellen
Was wäre denn aus deiner Sicht der Vorteil von Bitworn gegenüber KeyPass, wenn ich schon alles in KeyPass drin habe?
Ich weiß, dass man KeyPass in Bitworn importieren kann.
Aber ich sehe jetzt den großen Vorteil, jetzt nichts umzustellen.
Und irgendwie traue ich KeyPass noch einen Ticken mehr.
Moment, Frankfurt ist wohl... Wo hast du denn das her?
Frankfurt ist wohl die fahrradsfreundlichste Großstadt in Deutschland.
Ja, da müssen die anderen mal richtig beschissen sein, weil nach Frankfurt reinfahren traue ich mich auch nicht.
Zugriff von mehreren Geräten aus.
Ja gut, aber ich habe meinen Keypass einfach auf dem einen und dem anderen Desktop rechne und woanders gar nicht.
Also brau, macht nichts.
ähm 2FA hat aber in der gleichen
Passwortsafe App wie deine Passwörter
nichts zu suchen weil ansonsten
untergräbst du quasi den Sinn von 2FA
hat das mit dem
das mit PW Safe auf der Arbeit geklappt
ne
oder besser gesagt noch nicht
also prinzipiell
klappt das ja aber irgendwie
habe ich von denen nichts mehr gehört und deswegen
ist mir das jetzt auch egal
Gab es da irgendeinen Newspost?
In Frankfurt ist die fahrradfreundlichste Großstadt
Kann man nicht danach in News suchen?
Frankfurt am Main ist die fahrradfreundlichste Großstadt
WTF, Alter
Es ist richtig beschissen in Frankfurt
Fahrrad zu fahren
Ich traue mich da immer nicht
Also guckt mal, wenn man hier
What the fuck
Achso ich bin auch dumm
Ich hab den falschen Knopf gedrückt
Maps Frankfurt
So
Ähm
Können wir das ganze vielleicht hier so machen
So guck mal
Wenn man von hier unten
Also ich fahre ja, ich bin das schon gefahren.
Ich bin schon gefahren hier von Hanau, hier am Einradweg lang, hier unten lang nach Frankfurt.
So, und irgendwo geht es dann in die, ich glaube hier, hier ist auch der Willy-Brandt-Platz, genau.
Hier geht es dann über die Brücke rüber.
Und ganz ehrlich, hier in die Innenstadt würde ich nicht fahren wollen mit dem Fahrrad.
Ganz im Ernst.
Es ist so beschissen zu fahren.
Ich weiß nicht, wo da die fahrradfreundlichste...
Okay, die fahrradfreundlichste Großstadt heißt ja nur, dass die anderen Städte noch beschissener sind.
Das heißt ja nicht, dass es gut ist.
Was hat der eigentlich für Bewertung?
Ne.
Also ab hier traue ich mich nicht mehr richtig.
Naja.
Wenn das die fahrradfreundlichste Großstadt ist, dann scheint das so zu sein.
Das heißt, die anderen sind noch beschissener.
Du traust dich nicht, in bestimmte Gassen reinzulaufen.
Also, ich vermeide einige Straßen in Frankfurt auch.
Weniger, weil ich Angst habe, überfallen zu werden.
Das kann dir da natürlich auch passieren.
sondern hauptsächlich
wegen den Leuten dort
und weil es da auch immer stinkt, es fuck.
Also wahrscheinlich ist Frankfurt
ganz gut,
aber halt vielleicht nicht unbedingt
im Bahnhofsviertel.
Also Nidda Straße und sowas in Frankfurt, das muss nicht unbedingt sein hier.
Da sind immer die Spezialisten am Start.
Da ist auch irgendwo, irgendwo hier, Silvestraße, sonst wo, irgendwo hier ist auch Scientology.
Keine Ahnung, hier irgendwo.
Irgendwo hier ist Scientology auch.
Die haben eine ganz dicke Panzertür dran, Scientology.
Kann man sich ja fragen, warum, ne?
Keck Alu, ja.
It's me.
hoffentlich haben die da auch viele Katzis.
Das ist das einzige, warum ich nochmal in die Türkei gehen würde.
Oder, nee, das einzige Positive,
was ich wahrscheinlich nochmal im Türkei-Urlaub abgewinnen könnte,
ich war ja früher ab und zu mal da,
mittlerweile habe ich ja überhaupt kein Bock mehr hinzufahren,
sind die Katzis, die es gibt.
So.
Also wenn man den Hauptbahnhof vermeidet, ist Frankfurt ziemlich cool.
Das stimmt.
Ich habe letztens sogar auch irgendwie mal so ein Top-Ranking der europäischen Städte gesehen.
Und da war Frankfurt ganz vorne mit dabei.
Frankfurt, lebenswerteste Stadt.
Da gab es letztens so ein komisches Ranking.
Hier, Frankfurt glänzt in den Top 10 der lebenswertesten Städten.
Ja.
Äh, hallo?
Äh.
Hier, Frankfurt auf Platz 7 der lebenswertesten Städte der Welt.
Zürich, Schweiz, Wien, Österreich.
Ich habe Genf.
Ist das Genf?
Schweiz.
Kopenhagen.
Dänemark.
Neuseeland.
Amsterdam.
Frankfurt.
Mercer sagt es.
Was auch immer Mercer ist.
Aber wenn Reddit das sagt,
also ganz ehrlich, da traue ich eher Reddit.
Wenn Reddit das sagt, dann ist das so.
Nur Großstadt.
Ja gut.
Klar.
Aber habt ihr gewusst, dass es in Frankfurt
mega viele Millionäre gibt? Ja.
Ich glaube, es gibt kaum eine Stadt
auf der ganzen Welt.
Oder sagen wir mal so, Frankfurt ist auf jeden Fall
weltweit ganz vorne mit dabei,
wenn es
um...
darum geht, wie nah Arm und Reich
zusammen sind.
Du hast in Frankfurt
kann es sein,
dass der Milliardär
gerade
an der Straße vorbeiläuft
wo der Drogenrabhängige
sitzt und kurz vorm Abkratzen ist
so innerhalb von ein paar Meter Abstand
also es gibt glaube ich
wenige Städte auf der Welt
wo Arm und Reich so nah
zusammen sind wie in Frankfurt
nach welchen Kriterien wird das Ranking gemacht
keine Ahnung, müssen wir mal gucken
ob die das
schreiben, wie sie das
ermittelt haben.
Das ist Mercer's Quality of Living
Data... Okay, was auch immer.
Warte mal.
So.
Also wo die meisten, wo in Hessen die meisten Millionäre wohnen, ist glaube ich Königstein.
Königstein im Taunus.
Hier wohnen wohl die meisten, die meisten Millionäre.
In Hessen.
Königstein.
Generell in dieser Ecke hier.
Ich meine, ist ja auch irgendwie...
Das ist da übrigens der Opel-Zoo.
Opel-Zoo ist auch nice.
War ich früher öfters mal.
Wo ich noch klein war.
Hab ich richtig abgefeiert damals.
Also, äh...
Okay, das lese ich mir jetzt nicht durch.
Das ist mir zu viel bla bla bla.
About.
Leading provider of data.
Ja, ja und wie...
Das finde ich immer geil, wenn sie schreiben,
wir sind führend im Bereich XY.
Ja, das kann ja jeder behaupten, aber was genau?
How we calculate?
Okay, okay, hier.
Hier kriegen wir jetzt die Erklärung.
Also, wie haben sie das bestimmt, dass Frankfurt auf Platz 7 der lebenswertesten Stadt der Welt wohlgemerkt ist?
New York City serves as the base city for global ranking.
Aha.
Aha, okay.
Moment, wir...
Wir sind mal cloud native.
Nee, AI native.
Akzeptieren.
Äh.
Okay.
Äh, geh weg.
Mal gucken, ob die das sinnvollerweise erklären.
New York City dient als Referenzstadt für unsere globalen Ranking,
das in diesem Jahr eine spannende Auswahl...
Blablabla.
Bei Mercer erstellen wir mit Stolz unser jährliches weltweites Ranking
zur Lebensqualität im Rahmen der
Worldwide Quality of Living Survey.
Wir erstellen individuelle Bereiche
und... Ja, und wie? Wie?
Wie?
Wir erheben und analysieren die Daten und sind...
Die Daten sind bestrebt, unsere...
unsere Bewertungen
überarbeiten und bedeuten, politische Wirtschaft
entwickelt einzubeziehen.
Äh...
Kann das sein, dass die einfach
nur labern und überhaupt nicht erklärt wird,
was die da eigentlich machen?
Ey, Eislobstädteranking.
Egal, nichtsdestotrotz, ob Frankfurt jetzt Top 7 der weltweit lebenswertesten Städten ist, scheiß drauf.
Aber Frankfurt an sich ist echt ganz okay.
Die meisten Leute denken bei Frankfurt ans Bahnhofsviertel.
Das Ranking ist für den Arsch.
Ans Bahnhofsviertel und an die ganzen fertigen Leute und Halbafrika am Hauptbahnhof.
Aber drumherum ist Frankfurt gar nicht so verkehrt.
Ich bin nur selten drumherum.
Ich bin halt hauptsächlich im Bahnhofsviertel.
Deswegen ist für mich Frankfurt nicht so geil.
Tja, so sieht's aus.
Selbst, ganz ehrlich, selbst das Bahnhofsviertel muss jetzt nicht Angst haben, da alle paar Minuten überfallen zu werden oder so.
So schlimm ist es auch nicht.
Also das sieht teilweise schlimmer aus, als es ist.
Wobei man auch sagen muss, es ist jetzt nicht so, dass es nicht vorkommt.
Mein ehemaliger Chef wurde am Hauptbahnhof oder auf dem Weg oder irgendwie in der Nähe vom Hauptbahnhof schon überfallen.
Da musste ich als Azubi, das weiß ich noch nicht, das könnt ihr euch überlegen, das ist eine ganze Weile her, der wurde überfallen in der Nähe vom Hauptbahnhof und sein Portemonnaie abgenommen.
Und da musste ich als Azubi damals zu einem der Polizeireviere in Frankfurt und die Brieftasche, das Portemonnaie von meinem Chef abholen wieder.
Und natürlich hat man schon die ein oder anderen Sachen im Bahnhofsviertel mitgekriegt, ja.
Also wir haben ja zum Beispiel mal live zugeguckt, wo...
Da ist... Die sind hier... Die sind hinten an der Taunusstraße, irgendwo war das.
Sind zwei Frauen gelaufen.
und von hinten
kam eine angerannt,
haut der einen auf den Kopf,
schnappt sich ihre Handtasche
und flitzt damit weg.
So, und das Witzige,
oder was heißt Witzige, ja, das Witzige
daran ist, die kannten sich wohl,
weil die hat ihm dann hinterhergerufen,
ich weiß nicht mehr, wie der hieß, der hat ihm dann
hinterhergerufen, also die ihm, ja,
die kannte den, die hat ihm dann hinterhergerufen
so nach dem Motto, ey Karl, was machst
du denn?
Also das heißt, die kannten sich auch noch.
Frankfurt-Warnhofsviertel halt, ja.
Also da hat man schon die einen oder anderen Sachen mitbekommen.
Aber man muss da keine Angst haben, dass man quasi da jede Minute die Chance steigt, dass man überfallen wird.
auf der anderen Seite schön ist es jetzt auch nicht unbedingt.
Was ist die Lebenswerte München?
München ist teuer.
AF.
München ist hier übrigens gar nicht drin.
Was ich interessant finde, es ist sehr viel in der Schweiz drin.
Da gehe ich auch mal von aus, das stimmt.
Es ist zwar auch teuer,
aber ich glaube, da ist die Welt noch in Ordnung.
Wobei, keine Ahnung, wie die Schweizer das sehen.
So, dann gucken wir mal auf YouTube, was da so abgeht.
Was wir uns angucken können.
Ich wollte hier unbedingt mal dieses Video von Morpheus gucken.
Was wird mir hier denn für komisches Zeug empfohlen, Alter?
Nein, das guckt man nicht.
Ich wollte mir eigentlich mal dieses Video von Morpheus angucken, weil mich interessiert, was der dazu sagt.
Ich gucke in letzter Zeit tatsächlich richtig gerne die Videos von ihm.
Das ist eine Kombination aus, ich finde oftmals die Themen ganz interessant.
Das sind oftmals Themen, mit denen ich mich selbst gerade beschäftige.
Und, das kommt, das ist für mich immer ein großes Plus, ich habe bei ihm den Eindruck, dass er weiß, wovon er redet.
nicht wie bei anderen Channels, die dann mit irgendwelchen Begriffen um sich hauen
und du hörst das und verstehst halt selbst, um was es geht und denkst dir so,
also so benutzt man das eigentlich nicht.
Und deswegen gucke ich Morpheus in letzter Zeit echt ganz gern.
Das ist die Kombination aus Themen und dass man echt das Gefühl hat,
der weiß, wovon er redet.
beziehungsweise ich kaufe ihm das ab, dass er gewisse Kompetenz auf dem Gebiet besitzt.
Deswegen gucke ich das gern.
Shorts ausblenden.
Da gibt es doch garantiert irgendeine Browser Extensions für um YouTube Shorts auszublenden, oder?
Wobei es halt die Frage ist, ob man sich noch mehr Browser Extensions da...
Homelab 2026.
Das Kubernetes-Homelab-Setup ist...
Alter, warum?
Warum wollen die alle Kubernetes im Homelab haben, Alter?
Kann mir das irgendjemand erklären?
Hat jemand wirklich ein großes Anwendungsgebiet,
äh, einen großen Anwendungsfall für Kubernetes im Homelab?
Außer basteln und lernen?
Das ist ja vollkommen okay.
Aber Anwendungen laufen lassen? Warum?
Ich verstehe das nicht.
Warum kaufen alle diesen Mähroboter?
Ich kaufe ihn nicht.
Die typische Bürojob-Erfahrung.
Okay, der benutzt Pepo-Emojis.
Warum machen Bürojobs Lowkey?
Warum machen...
Oh Gott, das ist Zuma-Speak, Leute.
Oder Gen-Alpha-Speak.
Egal, da müssen wir jetzt durch, Leute.
Warum machen Bürojobs Lowkey keinen Sinn?
Ist eine Frage, die ich mich in meinem ersten Job, der im Büro war, das ein oder andere Mal gefragt habe.
Aber schau mal, Premium-Dialekt.
Der hat schon mal einen Pluspunkt bei mir.
Ja gut, ja gut.
Bewerbung ist ja heutzutage eh so ein Ding.
Ich habe letztens auf Reddit gelesen,
das ist Reddit, Leute, das muss man ja mit einer Portion Skepsis sehen.
Ich habe letztens auf Reddit einen gelesen, der hat sich beworben,
ich glaube als Junior?
Nee, Moment, war als...
Nee, nee, nee, das war was ganz anderes, hatte mit Entwickler nichts zu tun.
Genau, der hat jetzt, jetzt weiß ich wieder,
letztens in Reddit, das hat ich gelesen von einem,
Der hat sich beworben als, ähm, weiß nicht, wie man das nennt, so als, als, ähm, Aufpasser in einem, in einem, äh, wie, wie heißen diese Dinger, wo man klettern gehen kann? Dort, wo es so Kletterwände gibt, wie heißt denn das? Kletterstudio? Ne, äh, wie nennt man sowas? Bouldern, ja, aber wie, wie heißt denn so, wie heißt, wie heißt denn solche Läden?
Kletterhalle, Kletterpark, ja genau, sowas.
Der hat sich so quasi als, als, ja, weiß nicht,
hat Mitarbeiter von so einem Kletterpark beworben.
Er meint, der klettert halt selbst auch gerne,
kennst ja ganz gut aus.
Und er musste irgendwie drei oder vier oder fünf,
keine Ahnung, Durchgänge machen
mit irgendwelchen komischen Teambuilding-Spielchen
und sonst was.
Hat er auch gemeint, alter, er bewirbt sich jetzt ja hier nicht
auf irgendwie einen super hochkomplizierten Sonstwas-Shop.
Der musste das NASA-Spiel machen.
Kennt ihr das NASA-Spiel?
Das NASA-Spiel geht ungefähr so.
Ihr sitzt, ich bin mir nicht sicher,
ob ich das hundertprozentig wiedergebe.
Ihr seid mit eurer Mannschaft irgendwie auf dem Mond gestrandet
und habt jetzt diese Teile noch retten können
aus dem Wrack von eurer Rakete.
Und welche dieser Teile,
ihr könnt nur so und so viel Kilo mitnehmen, welche dieser Teile nehmt ihr mit?
So, und dann muss man so Gruppenarbeit machen, welche Teile davon sind besonders wichtig,
um so die Evakuierungsrakete zu erreichen zu können und sowas.
Und bei diesem Spiel geht es darum, dass in der Regel die Ergebnisse, die eine Gruppe trifft,
besser sind als die Ergebnisse, die ein Einzelner trifft.
Also als erstes muss sich jeder Einzel überlegen, welche Teile würde er mitnehmen, quasi zur Evakuierungsrakete, um da hinzukommen und danach überlegt sich die ganze Gruppe, welche Teile sie mitnehmen und wie sie am besten zur Evakuierungsrakete kommen und rauskommen soll am Ende, dass das, was die Gruppe sich überlegt hat, meistens besser ist, als das, was die Einzelnen sich überlegt haben.
Und dieses Spielchen musste der halt machen
Als Aufpasser in einem Kletterpark
Ja, das ist halt
Guck mal, ob ich das finde, das ist halt ein kompletter
Kompletter Witz gewesen
Okay, das muss
Irgendwas sein, so die letzten
Monat
Ja, okay.
Findet man nicht.
Keine Ahnung.
Naja.
Zumindest das fand ich halt schon richtig dämlich.
Ja.
AK realisierst, dass du in der Welt nicht wegkommen wirst ohne Geld, sind das so die zwei Möglichkeiten, die du...
Ja, Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment. Ohne Geld kommst du nicht weit.
Das heißt aber nicht, dass du das Geld selbst verdienen musst.
Entweder kannst du das Geld erben oder du machst das wie...
Du machst das wie dieser eine Typ, was letztens durch die Nachrichten geht.
Du kommst aus... Wo kam der her? Aus dem Kosovo oder so?
kommst her,
setzt hier
acht Kinder in die Welt, begehst
Straftaten und kassierst 7500
Euro im Monat. Das kannst du natürlich
auch machen.
Und was ich besonders witzig fand, dass
der Typ mit Vornamen Huso hieß.
Was ein Name,
Alter. Aber scheint
wohl so in der Balkanregion
ein ganz normaler Vorname zu sein, dass man
Huso heißt.
Aber ohne Geld ist schlecht.
... in einen Job zu kommen.
Außer du bist jetzt die Ausnahme und so gut in dem, was du machst,
dass die Unternehmen auf dich zukommen und dich haben wollen.
Ja, durchschnittliche Chat-Experience hier, oder?
Ich selbst habe keine Beziehungen, die mich in irgendeine Firma bringen konnten, gehabt.
Und ich glaube, das trifft auch auf die Großeltern der Leute zu.
Kinder sind teuer, das ist richtig, aber da soll halt was arbeiten gehen.
Heißt, die beste Chance, die man hat, ist es, sich auf einem der 100 Jobportale, die es gibt,
für gefühlt jede Bürostelle in der Nähe zu bewerben.
Weil wir erinnern uns, wir wollen ins Büro, nicht auf den Bau oder in die Werkstatt.
Im Endeffekt spammt man dann Bewerbungen und mit etwas Glück und vielleicht auch ein kleines bisschen Qualifikation für die beworbene Stelle, steht man dann früher oder später vor Ort für das Vorstellungsgespräch.
Ich habe mich da für eine Stelle im Projektmanagement in einer Elektronikfirma beworben.
Projektmanagement ist ja schon mal komplett für einen Arsch.
Das ist ja schon per Default ein Haufen von Buzzword, Bullshit, Bingo, heiße Lufträder.
Und ich weiß noch, wie extrem nervös ich davor war.
Vor allem, weil ich direkt aus der Schule gekommen bin und halt ehrlich null Plan von
irgendwas hatte.
Im Endeffekt war es eh nur das normale Gespräch von, was sind deine Interessen, warum bist
du hier, kennst du dich mit irgendwas aus und bla bla bla, sodass die halt einen Basic-Überblick
übereinbekommen.
Mein Glück war da aber, dass die gerade extremen Personalmangel in ihrem Team hatten und ich
glaube zu viert die arbeit von sechs gemacht haben und sich irgendwie keiner für die stelle
das behauptet aber jedes team egal wo du hinkommst sind die leute ich mache die arbeit für zwei oder
hier im team wir sind nur fünf leute aber wir schaffen das was zehn schafft ich will das jetzt
aber auch mal gar nicht in abrede stellen ist das ja auch so aber nachdem es ja kaum eine definition
gibt wie viel fünf zu schaffen haben wie viel zehn zu schaffen haben ist das immer so manchmal
auch ein bisschen selbstüberschätzung weil
das high performer das high performer mindset das high performer mindset ist
man muss was geiles machen dann muss man also man macht 30 prozent der zeit was
geiles ja man vermittelt aber den eindruck dass man immer 100 prozent der
Zeit was Geiles macht und in Wirklichkeit
macht man 30% der Zeit was
Geiles und
redet die andere
Zeit darüber, was man Geiles gemacht hat.
Das ist das Wichtige.
Und dann brauchst du noch
zig Side-Projekte
und musst am besten
noch Triathlon oder so machen,
wie die ganzen High-Performer
Leute. Also Side-Hustles
brauchst du, mindestens
20 Stück.
Du musst richtig
krass Ausdauersport machen
und du musst geile Sachen auf der Arbeit
machen und noch viel wichtiger, geil über
deine geilen Sachen reden. Das ist das
Allerwichtigste.
Das High-Performer-Mindset.
Und das
Wichtigste ist, eigentlich fast das
Wichtigste ist, du brauchst
ein gewisses Gespür dafür und
das haben viele High-Performer.
Du brauchst ein gewisses Gespür
dafür. Okay, mal vielleicht
sollten wir nochmal unterscheiden zwischen
krassen Karriere-Crindern und High-Performern.
Das ist ja nicht unbedingt das Gleiche.
Ich rede jetzt eher von den Karriere-Crindern-High-Performern.
Du brauchst ein gutes Gespür dafür,
was gut ankommt,
wo sich Zeit zu investieren lohnt und wo nicht.
Das haben die ganzen krassen Karriere-Crindern.
Also nehmen wir jetzt mal das Beispiel von Microsoft.
Der Chef hat da letztens eine Mail rumgeschrieben. Leute, wer keinen Bock auf KI hat, kann sich ja auch gleich verpissen. Jetzt ist halt die Frage, was machst du jetzt?
Wenn du jetzt High-Performer-Karriere-Crinder bist und du hast die Auswahl zwischen, ich fixe Bugs in Microsoft Notepad, die es seit 25 Jahren schon gibt und mach da draußen eine richtig gute funktionierende Anwendung wieder.
oder du baust einen Co-Pilot-Button in Notepad ein,
den keine Sau haben wollte,
aber von dem du weißt, dass dein Chef richtig drauf steht,
wenn das ein Co-Pilot-Button gibt.
Was machst du dann?
Wenn du ein High-Performance-Karriere-Criner bist,
dann wirst du dich auf jeden Fall für den Co-Pilot-Button
in Notepad entscheiden.
Und das machst du dann so gut,
wie es so nebenbei
so irgendwie noch geht, ja, also
das darf jetzt nicht,
das darf jetzt nicht ganz, wo es Bugs in Notepad
gibt, zum Beispiel wenn du Markdown
links öffnest,
kann random Code ausgeführt werden.
Ähm,
du machst das so, dass es ganz
ganz gut ausschaut
und die restlichen 70%
deiner Zeit benutzt du
allen zu erzählen, wie geil du bist,
dass du einen Copilot-Button
in Notepad eingebaut hast.
das wird auf Dauer für den Karriere-Crime deutlich förderlicher sein,
wie als du fixst alle Bugs, die es im Output noch gibt.
Das ist einfach so.
Also du wirst immer besser fahren damit karrieretechnisch,
wenn du was machst und drüber redest, als wenn du nur was machst.
Selbst wenn das vielleicht unterm Strich
für die Firma viel besser ist,
das ist egal.
Du musst drüber reden. Wenn du nicht drüber redest,
kriegt dein Kram keiner mit. Und wenn den Kram
keiner mitkriegt, ist auch egal,
wie viele geile Sachen du machst.
Und was halt
so viele Hardcore-Karriere-Crinder
haben, die haben ein gutes
Gespür. Also die können sich gut verkaufen,
ja, und die haben ein richtig gutes
Gespür dafür. Das ist ja auch ein gewisser Skill.
Und die haben ein gewisses Gespür dafür, was gut ankommt und können sich auch gut auf die Sachen fokussieren, die gut ankommen. Also sprich, wenn die was machen und feststellen, ey, das ist eigentlich was, was nicht so gut ankommt, dann wird das auch wieder links liegen gelassen und sich auf das nächste Prestigeträchtige fokussiert.
also das ist auch schon ein Skill
kann man
sich drüber lustig machen oder so, aber die können schon was
und die Leute können sich in der Regel auch gut verkaufen
so, wie ich jetzt super sidetracked
wieder vom Video
ja und was auch wichtig ist
du musst Leute
wie nenne ich denn das jetzt am besten?
Du musst dir Leute warm halten.
Also wenn du krasser Karriere-Criner bist,
dann musst du permanent socializen mit irgendwelchen Leuten.
Natürlich nur mit den Leuten, von denen du denkst,
dass sie dich weiterbringen.
Es ist ja nicht so, dass die Leute
da krasses Socialize und Netzwerken machen,
weil sie sich so gut mit den Leuten verstehen.
Nee, nee, die Netzwerken mit Leuten,
wo sie denken, dass sie die weiterbringen.
Also der Hausmeister kann der netteste Dude sein
und die können sich persönlich mit dem richtig gut verstehen,
aber mit dem wird natürlich nicht genetzwerkt,
weil der bringt die Leute ja nicht weiter.
Die halten sich halt die passenden Leute warm,
weil sie auch ein bisschen die Hoffnung haben,
dass die sie halt weiter mit hochziehen.
Und da gibt es ja sogar Untersuchungen zu, das ist ja auch so.
Also wenn du dich mit Leuten quasi auf dem Weg nach oben
und du willst auch nach oben, wenn du dich mit denen gut stellst,
dann ziehen sie dich, Chancen sind zumindest ganz gut,
ziehen sie dich weiter mit hoch, weil die kennen dich, die wissen,
okay, mit dem kommt man gut klar, was der macht, macht immer einen guten Eindruck,
dann ziehen die dich mit.
Und deswegen sind die auch alle immer so krass am Netzwerken und so auf,
oh, cool und oh, zeig mal her, in Wirklichkeit interessiert die das ja alles nicht.
Die hoffen nur, dass beim nächsten Mal derjenige daran denkt, sagt,
ach guck mal, den könnten wir da vielleicht auch noch unterbringen.
Also, vielleicht habe ich das jetzt auch zu negativ ausgedrückt,
weil ich kein Netzwerker und krasser Socializer-Dude bin.
Vielleicht unterstelle ich das denen ja auch.
Vielleicht gibt es da auch genug Leute bei,
die der Meinung sind,
boah, es ist das Geilste auf der Welt zu socializen
und ich unterhalte mich ultra gerne mit Menschen
und lerne neue Menschen kennen
und bin so interessiert an anderen Menschen.
Kann ja auch sein.
Ich unterstelle den meisten aber mal,
denen gehen die eigentlichen Menschen auch am Arsch vorbei.
Das ist für die einfach nur
Karrieremöglichkeiten.
Was geht?
Ja, weiß nicht.
Es geht gerade
mich über aktuelle Sachen
auslassen im Business Enterprise Umfeld.
Von dem ich denke,
dass es so ist. Also jetzt aber mal
ohne Mist.
Wenn ihr eine Sache machen wollt,
karrieretechnisch,
die euch wirklich was bringt. Ich muss mal kurz ein bisschen
Gedudel anmachen.
Ne, ne, ne, ne.
Nicht Twitch-E-Mails.
Wenn ihr eine Sache machen wollt, die euch
karrieretechnisch wirklich was bringt. Und das ist auch was,
das kann jeder machen.
Dann ist es
über die Sachen,
die ihr macht,
von denen ihr denkt,
dass die sich gut eignen, um sie in die Breite zu tragen.
Dass ihr da drüber redet.
Also, nur mal so als Beispiel.
Ihr habt jetzt, was habt ihr denn gemacht?
Ihr habt ein Shell-Skript gebaut, was, keine Ahnung,
euch regelmäßig Nachrichten schickt, wenn die Festplatte vollläuft.
Ich weiß, das ist kein Sinn für...
So, das habt ihr gemacht, dann habt ihr eine Webseite gebaut, wo jeder easy sein Passwort drüber resetten kann, was früher ein großer Akt war.
Und dann habt ihr dafür gesorgt, dass es in der Kantine jetzt auch veganes Essen gibt.
So, keine Ahnung. So, und das habt ihr letzten Monat über gemacht. So, und jetzt müsst ihr euch überlegen, okay, was von diesen drei Sachen ist denn für alle besonders interessant?
veganes essen wahrscheinlich nicht unbedingt best script für festplatten auslastung auch
nicht unbedingt aber dass leute jetzt nicht mehr dreimal anrufen müssen sondern ihr passwort über
eine webseite resetten können das ist gut damit kann sich jeder identifizieren damit kann sich
euer chef identifizieren oder abteilungsleiter identifizieren der chef vom chef identifizieren
das ist ein gutes thema also sich ein gutes thema also das beste thema raussuchen von dem was man
gemacht hat, wo man halt nicht
was, wie gesagt, nicht das
Thema, was
das technisch raffinierteste
ist unbedingt, ja,
oder das, was für euch,
wo es euch am meisten
unter den Fingern gejuckt hat, das ist
nicht unbedingt das beste Thema, um das so in die
Breite zu tragen, ja, ihr müsst euch das
Thema raussuchen, was
möglichst viele verstehen,
wo möglichst viele
was Positives für sich erkennen,
am allerwichtigsten ein Thema,
was euer Chef versteht, was der Chef von eurem Chef auch verstehen kann.
Und das Thema nehmt ihr dann und dann labert ihr darüber ein bisschen.
So nach dem Motto, habt ihr schon gesehen hier,
also was weiß ich, ist es irgendwie eine Abteilungsversammlung oder irgendwas,
da sagt ihr, ey, Chef, kann ich da nicht mal was vorstellen das nächste Mal.
Dann stellt ihr euch hin, sagt, guckt mal hier, jetzt könnt ihr euer Passwort resetten,
müsst ihr nicht dreimal anrufen.
dann wird das immer breit getreten und sonst wie.
Und das verbinden die Leute dann mit euch.
Also das Beste, was man karrieremäßig machen kann
und wahrscheinlich auch eines der einfachsten Dinger ist,
überlegen, was von dem, was man gemacht hat,
ist ein gutes Thema, um es so ein bisschen in die Breite zu tragen
und dann einfach drüber labern.
Einfach drüber labern.
Das ist besser.
Chat, was meint ihr?
Wer hat, wenn es darum geht,
angenommen, die überlegen sich jetzt hier ein neues Budget für nächstes Jahr,
wem können wir mehr Geld geben?
Allein schon die Überlegung ist natürlich ein bisschen,
freiwillig werden sie es wahrscheinlich eh nicht machen,
aber überlegt euch mal, es gibt jetzt ein Budget,
so, und wer bekommt eine Bonuszahlung nächstes Jahr?
Wir haben ein bisschen extra Budget, wer bekommt eine Bonuszahlung?
Derjenige, der ein paar coole Sachen gemacht hat
und 70% der anderen Zeit drüber labert, dass er coole Sachen gemacht hat.
Oder jemand, der 90% der Zeit coole Sachen gemacht hat
und sich 10% der Zeit erholen muss, weil er so fertig ist davon.
Unterm Strich für die Firma besser ist wahrscheinlich der Typ, der 90% macht,
weil der schafft einfach wie verrückt und macht immer gute Sachen, aber keiner kriegt es mit.
der Typ, der 30%
coole Sachen macht,
vielleicht sogar noch mit ein bisschen Gespür dafür,
was denn Sachen sind, die gut ankommen
und 70% der Zeit drüber labert,
der ist viel präsenter.
Ja.
Deswegen ist es auch wichtig,
gebe ich dir recht,
dass man einen gescheiten Chef hat,
der das auch passend verkaufen kann.
Also am besten ist, wenn ihr den Chef habt,
dem erzählt ihr dann, was ihr Cooles gemacht habt
und der sagt dann, sag mal,
willst du das nicht mal auf der nächsten Abteilungsrunde erzählen oder sowas?
Oder willst du das mal nicht auf unserem nächsten XYZ-Kram vorstellen?
ja wenn das wenn das klappt hast du glück das klappt aber oftmals nicht
zumindest ein chef und ein projektleiter müssen sie auch erst mal mitkriegen
ja man sagt er immer selbstlob stinkt aber das ist im business enterprise
umfeld nicht so du darfst natürlich nicht unbedingt sagen guck mal her ich
habe wieder was richtig geiles gemacht du musstest du musst das verkaufen als
ich habe für euch was du also nicht ich habe für euch was tolles gemacht sondern
sondern hier gibt es was Tolles für euch.
Ja?
Oder guckt mal, was wir im Team Tolles erreicht haben.
Aber wichtig ist natürlich schon,
dass alle raushören,
dass ihr was Geiles gemacht habt.
Das ist so.
Also wenn ihr die Auswahl habt,
zwischen einem, der 90% schafft,
geile Sachen macht,
super Arbeit leistet,
aber nicht drüber redet,
versus einen, der 30% schafft und geile Sachen macht,
ein super arbeit leisten 70 prozent darüber oder 60 prozent darüber redet dann wird der einfach
unterm strich mehr davon haben obwohl er vielleicht weniger geile sachen gemacht hat das ist einfach
so mehr labern und weniger arbeiten wenn du karriere machen willst ist das so so doofs
klingt, das ist so.
Oder du bist richtig krasser
High Performer,
dann arbeitest du bis zum Umfallen, machst
geile Sachen, redest drüber,
machst noch Triathlon
und
hast noch 20
Side-Hustle-Projekte.
Das kannst du natürlich auch machen,
so 80-Stunden-Woche.
Ja, natürlich, ganz ehrlich, woran haben Chefs Interesse? Überlegt euch mal.
Chefs haben Interesse daran, erstmal das grundlegende Interesse, dass sie von ihrem Chef keinen auf den Deckel bekommen.
Das ist erstmal so, die Basics Sachen müssen schon ordentlich erledigt werden, ja.
Also Chefs haben erstmal großes Interesse daran, dass sie selbst, so wie ihr auch, ja, dass sie selbst keinen auf den Deckel bekommen.
Und das nächste ist, die haben natürlich ein großes Interesse dran, ihre Abteilung oder ihr Team oder ihr Projekt als besonders erfolgreich darzustellen. Ja warum? Weil das auch positiv auf die zurückfällt. Und es ja letztendlich auch irgendwo ihre Aufgabe ist als Führungskraft, Projektleiter, Abteilungsleiter, dass es erfolgreich läuft.
Da haben die ja ein eigenes Interesse dran.
Und das heißt, sobald ihr denen auch ein bisschen Futter gebt,
wenn ihr denen sagt, ey, guck mal, das und das haben wir hier Cooles gemacht und so,
dann verkaufen, also viele Chefs verkaufen das auch wahnsinnig gerne als tolle Sache weiter.
Weil das sie selbst gut dastehen lässt.
Und sie müssen ja auch selbst irgendwie zeigen, dass sie gute Arbeit leisten.
Also das ist jetzt ganz klar.
Also deswegen, das ist das Erste und Einfachste, was man machen kann,
regelmäßig seinem Chef zu erzählen, was man für coole Sachen gemacht hat,
beziehungsweise was für coole Sachen erledigt wurden.
Und wenn es ein guter Chef ist, allein schon auch aus eigenem Interesse,
verkauft er das weiter.
Was natürlich blöd ist, es gibt es auch,
welche, die quasi das eher so dann nur als ihre Errungenschaft verkaufen,
und weniger für die Leute, die es dann letztendlich gemacht haben.
Ja, hast du auch die einen oder anderen Deppen dabei,
aber in der Regel haben die Chef ja auch ein gewisses Interesse dran,
dass die Leute in ihrem Team zufrieden sind.
Und wir gehen jetzt mal davon aus, dass die meisten das gescheit machen.
Naja gut, super krasses Sidetracking.
Aber wenn wir eine Sache davon festhalten können, ist
Nicht nur tolle Sachen machen
Sondern am besten
Tolle Sachen machen
Und anstatt die zweite tolle Sache
Dann direkt anzufangen
Über die erste tolle Sache einfach mal
Bisschen reden
Das Sidetrack ist spannender als das Video
Das kann schon sein, gucken wir mal
Du hattest bisher immer nur Chefs
Die es für ihren Erfolg verkauft haben
Ja, das ist scheiße
Da fragt man sich halt auch, wer das denen glaubt.
Also ich meine, gehen wir mal von aus, bleiben wir mal bei dem Beispiel, was ich vorhin hatte.
Irgendjemand hat eine super Webseite gebaut, wo die Leute ihr Passwort drüber resetten können, ohne dass es jetzt irgendwie fünf Anrufe braucht.
Frage ich mich, wie der Chef das
allein sein Erfolg verkaufen
will, weil
da müssten wir dem Chef glauben, dass der
programmieren kann.
Oder sowas machen kann. Es gibt genug
Chefs, die können das. Gerade
so Teamleiter und sowas. Die waren ja früher selbst mal
in der technischen Position Teamleiter geworden.
Aber sicherlich
traut man das nicht jedem zu.
Frage ich mich, wie die das dann verkaufen wollen,
dass das nur auf ihrem Mist gewachsen ist.
Aber gut.
Ich meine, es gibt sicherlich die einen oder anderen, die das dann ein bisschen verzerrt darstellen, so nach dem Motto, meine Leute haben ja vor mir nichts hingekriegt und nur durch meinen super Führungsstil haben wir jetzt diese tollen Erfolge erzielt und sowas. Ja, das gibt es natürlich auch. Aber wie gesagt, nachdem die meisten Chefs ja auch irgendwie ein Interesse daran haben, dass die eigenen Leute zufrieden sind, ist das auf lange Sicht auch doof, aus denen ihrer Sicht das so zu machen.
Weil das kriegen die Leute natürlich ja auch mit
Wenn nichts bei ihnen davon ankommt
Von den Sachen
Ja sowas
Ist dann immer komplett lächerlich
Da weißt du auch gleich
Da willst du nicht länger sein
In dem Team
Also ich finde mein Chef, mein aktueller
Und auch mein letzter, muss man auch dazu sagen
Das ist ja nicht alles schlecht gewesen in der alten Firma. Die haben das eigentlich immer ganz gut gemacht.
Zum Beispiel vor einem Jahr hat er ja auch gesagt, ihr Max, besser gesagt, das ist umgedreht.
Wir haben darüber geredet, dass es bei uns ja alle paar Monate eine Abteilungsversammlung gibt und da kann man neue Themen vorstellen.
und da habe ich zu ihm gesagt, ja, wie wäre es denn, wenn man hier dieses Monitoring-Thema mal vorstellt
und da hat er auch gesagt, oh ja, super Idee und hat mich gleich angemeldet und eingetragen,
dass ich das da vorstellen kann.
Ist doch super.
Ja, da haben alle was davon.
Ganz ehrlich, ich habe was von, weil ich da auftauche und mein Name da mit in Verbindung gebracht wird
und ich zeigen kann, was ich Tolles gemacht habe.
Und mein Chef hat was von, weil er irgendwie auch zeigen kann, guck mal, was in seinem Team so tolle Sachen laufen.
Also das ist eigentlich für alle gut, ja.
bezüglich deines setups warum nutzt du eigentlich kein rdp für die verbindung zwischen einem pc und
einem was zwischen einem pc und mini pc weil rdp laggy as fuck ist mach mal mit rdp also rdp
ist laggy und ruckelig.
Beides, ja.
Mach mal mit
Display.
Mach mal
mit RDP 240 Hz
so flüssig wie
hier. Okay, bei euch
im Stream sieht es nicht ganz so flüssig aus,
weil der Stream nur 48 FPS hat.
Aber das ist butterweich und komplett
lagfrei. Das kriegst du über RDP
nicht hin. Keine Chance.
Und auch
bei 4 in 10 nicht.
was ihr vielleicht habt was ihr vielleicht habt auf der arbeit ihr habt diese es gibt von microsoft
und nvidia gibt es so eine ich weiß nicht wie das heißt es gibt so eine so eine rdp extension
wenn dein pc eine grafikkarte hat beziehungsweise kann auch kann auch virtualisiert sein und so eine
so eine per pass through
S-I-O-V-Path-through-Grafikkarte
sein.
Da gibt es so eine Extension,
dass du quasi auch
3D
beschleunigte oder GPU
accelerated Graphics irgendwie über RDP
machen kannst. Gibt es seit ein paar Jahren.
Das ist dann ein bisschen weniger lagfrei und
fühlt sich ein bisschen besser an. Aber es
ist ein Unterschied. Also wenn du
beispielsweise mal per
es könnte sein, dass das
RemoteFX heißt. Ja, das könnte tatsächlich so sein.
das ist dann ein bisschen weniger
laggy und ein bisschen weniger gezuckelt,
aber wenn du mal den direkten Vergleich hast,
ja, zwischen einer Kiste mit RDP
oder einer Kiste
über irgendeine Game Streaming,
ja, letztendlich
könntest du ja auch Moonlight oder so,
Nvidia Game Stream machen,
hast, das ist einfach
komplett anders, das fühlt sich viel,
viel direkter an und
weniger geruckelt und es fühlt sich
viel mehr an, als sitzt du vorm richtigen PC.
So, und wie ich das jetzt gemacht habe ist, mit meinem Setup, das ist jetzt nicht VMware, wo ich jetzt bin.
Das ist ein Mini-PC. Guck hier.
Das ist ein Cache-OS auf einem Mini-PC mit einem Ryzen 7048 HS.
Richter HS hier, die CPU.
Das ist ein Mini-PC. Das ist ein...
Ja.
So ein Mini-PC ist das.
So, und wie ich das aktuell mache, ist folgendes.
Ich habe den Mini-PC auf meinem fetten Desktop-PC stehen.
Und ich capture den Output per Capture Card.
Boah, ich zeige euch das mal.
Also hier, ne?
Ich zeige das jeden Stream.
Und ich werde das auch jeden Stream zeigen, solange es Leute interessiert.
Und Leute fragen, also folgendes.
Guck mal, so funzt das.
Das hier ist mein Windows-Desktop-PC.
Fette Kiste mit 4090, 13.900K, 64GB.
4 TB SSD, also das hat ordentlich Power, das Teil.
Da habe ich mehrere Desktops unter Windows.
Guck mal.
Desktop 1 ist mein ganz normales Windows-Zeug, was ihr hier seht.
Desktop 2 ist in Wirklichkeit gar kein Linux, sondern ist ein OBS.
Ist ein OBS mit einem Video-Capture.
und zwar habe ich eine Elgato 4K Pro, das ist eine PCI Express Capture Card.
Ich brauche kein Path Through, ich brauche kein 240 Hertz Path Through, hat es aber auch, hat es aber auch.
So, und die Capture Card, die kann 1080p mit 240 Hertz capturen.
Das heißt, ich habe den HDMI Output von dem Mini PC an den HDMI Input von der Capture Card angeschlossen
und hab hier drauf
einfach nur OBS im Fullscreen.
Und das ist
nahezu lagfrei.
Also das hat ungefähr
10 bis 15 Millisekunden Delay.
Damit kann man wirklich leben.
Selbst Audio hat kaum Delay.
Also damit kann man wirklich leben.
10 bis 15 Millisekunden.
Ich würde jetzt vielleicht keine
Competitive Games hier drauf spielen.
Aber dafür ist es auch nicht da.
10, 15 Millisekunden ist vollkommen fein.
Das ist, guck dir mal.
Das sind, ähm, das ist ein Frame Versatz bei 60 FPS.
Also während des 60 FPS
Wären das quasi
Ein Frame
Delay
Ich glaube damit kann man wirklich leben
Max hat mit 10-15 Millisekunden Delay
Immer noch eine schnelle Reaktionszeit
Und 80% des Chats
das stimmt wahrscheinlich weil ich habe eine reaktionszeit von um die 150 millisekunden das
mit 42 das sage ich auch gerne das bin ich irgendwie stolz drauf weil ich finde das mega
nice da ich so als alter sack immer noch so eine schnelle reaktionszeit da sieht man mal was 35
jahre pc gaming alles so anrichten so wie ich das mit der maus mache kann ich ja auch noch zeigen
mit der maus ist eigentlich relativ simpel guck mal ich habe hier ein programm laufen das nennt
sich desk flow desk flow ist ein maus und tastatur sharing programm und das habe ich auch ich mache
mal hier wieder full screen und das habe ich auch hier laufen also ich schere die maus und tastatur
über desk flow so und wie das jetzt insgesamt funktioniert bis wir noch am
zocken ja aber in letzter zeit tatsächlich
weniger shooter kram und ich habe battlefield 6 immer noch nicht gespielt
ich habe auch irgendwie gar keinen bock richtig auf battlefield 6 als es da mal
einen ordentlichen server browser gibt und feste server wo man dann auch die
leute kennen und so da hätte ich schon wieder bock drauf aber das werden wir
nicht sehen.
Das ist
Mouse Without Borders.
Mouse Without Borders habe ich auch laufen.
Für den Vorschau-Rechner auf der anderen Seite.
So, und wie ich das Ganze jetzt mache, ist folgendes.
Guckt mal. Ich zeige euch jetzt mal
die einzelnen Steps. Also,
wenn ich
Control-Windows-Taste
rechte Maustaste, äh, rechte
Pfeiltaste drücke,
Zockst du Cute Games?
Ne.
Es sei denn, alte Pixel Games sind Cute Games
bei dir.
Cute Games.
Ich hab letztens
das verrückteste, glaube ich,
Cute Game überhaupt gesehen, ey.
Ich hab nen Pass of Exile.
Ich guck ab und zu mal Pass of Exile Streamer.
Am liebsten guck ich da
Passive Exile Speedrunner.
Guck ich mir mega gern an.
Ich hab schon ein paar Seasons
nicht mal Passive Exile gespielt, aber ich guck trotzdem gerne.
Und da hat letztens irgendein
Passive Exile Streamer
hat
in den
in irgendwelchen Wartezeiten
oder so dazwischen
wahrscheinlich bei irgendwelchen Traits oder so
hat er irgendein
Cute Anime Game
gespielt und das war ganz
abgedreht.
Das war...
Da habe ich auch erst gedacht, WTF,
was bin ich hier sehend?
Das war ein Game
mit Anime-Girls, aber
das waren Pferde.
Fragt mich bitte nicht, Leute.
Fragt mich nicht, keine Ahnung.
Das waren Pferdemädchen.
Und die haben...
Die musste man trainieren
zum Rennen.
Für Rennen.
Alter, was bin ich hier
sehend, man?
Oh, guck mal.
Das könnte das tatsächlich sein,
oder? Wartet mal.
Ich glaube, das ist es.
Ja.
Genau.
ETF, Alter.
da habe ich auch gern was bin ich hier sehen weil da so aber kommen wir zurück
diese girls sind auch an echte rennpferde angelegt ernsthaft okay aber
ich wollte ja eigentlich sagen wie ich das hier mit mit windows und linux hier
zusammen mache. Also, wenn ich jetzt
wenn ich jetzt
auf meiner Tastatur
Control-Windows-Taste
rechte Pfeiltaste drücke,
dann komme ich auf den zweiten Desktop. Ihr seht es ja auch hier unten.
Guck, komme ich vom ersten...
Face-Gesicht, danke schön für den Zap. Komme ich von dem ersten auf den zweiten
Desktop. Auf dem zweiten Desktop
ist mein OBS im Fullscreen.
Und ihr seht, Maustaste funktioniert
immer noch nicht. Es ist immer noch die Windows-Maus.
Ich bin immer noch nicht auf Linux.
Das heißt, jetzt muss ich hier drücken,
Alt-Ä, dann
komme ich hier rein. Das funktioniert folgendermaßen.
In
Deskflow habe ich
Hotkeys angelegt.
Wenn ich
Alt-R drücke,
switche ich zur Linux-Kiste.
Wenn ich Alt-Ö drücke,
nee, Schwachsinn, wenn ich Alt-R drücke,
switche ich zur Linux-Kiste. Wenn ich Alt-Ö drücke,
switche ich zum Desktop.
Und jetzt habe ich ein
Makro gebaut,
was mir diese Tasten
nacheinander drückt.
Also Logitech.
Oh, bei einer Logitech-Tastatur habe ich hier ein Makro, was mir das drückt.
Guck, das drückt.
Oder ich muss hier drauf gehen, das drückt mir.
Linke Windows-Taste Control, Pfeil nach rechts und dann drückt es Alt-A.
Das heißt, wenn ich jetzt die Taste mit dem Makro drücke, dann switcht es den Desktop,
drück den Shortcut aus
Desktop und ich bin mit der Maus hier drinnen.
Drücke ich die andere Taste,
switch das per Desktop auf
meinen Desktop zurück und switch den Desktop.
Ich hoffe, man hat
das jetzt verstanden. Deswegen kann
ich hier zwischen Linux und Windows umschalten
und auch Maus und Tastatur sharen
und es ist alles auf dem gleichen
Monitor. Und es ist
nahezu lagfrei.
Chat, man hat's verstanden, oder?
hoffe ich.
Das ist ein bisschen
high fat, ja.
Hups.
Falsches Emote.
Aber es ist für mich
das beste Setup, was es gibt.
Jetzt gucken wir das Video mal fertig.
Vielleicht sagt das Video auch, keine Ahnung.
Okay.
... in ihrem Team hatten und ich glaube zu viert die Arbeit von sechs gemacht haben.
Ja, das behaupten ja alle immer.
Und sich eben keiner für die Stelle beworben hat, weswegen ich da eigentlich von Anfang an ziemlich fix drinnen war, solange ich die Stelle haben wollte.
Anschließend habe ich mir dann noch einen Schnuppertag ausgemacht, also einen Tag oder in dem Fall ein paar Stunden,
in dem mir meine potenziell zukünftige Arbeit vorgestellt worden ist.
Und was glaubt ihr, habe ich irgendwas davon gecheckt?
Nö.
Ich verstelle aber trotzdem ohne Wenn und Aber angenommen, weil Geld definitiv.
Das finde ich auch immer witzig, wenn sie dich dann im Vorstellungsgespräch fragen,
so, ja, warum wollen sie denn zu uns?
Ah ja, weil ich Geld brauche.
Das darfst du da aber nicht sagen.
Da musst du dir dann irgendwas aus den Fingern saugen.
Dann in den Job gelandet.
Was mich auch zum zweiten Punkt bringt, und zwar den ersten Tag im neuen Job.
Zu 100% ist jede Nacht vor dem ersten Tag erstmal todesnervös.
Also ich bin da wirklich wachgelegen und wusste überhaupt nicht, was mich erwartet.
Was dumm ist, weil ich zum einen schon mehrere Praktika davor gemacht habe
und wortwörtlich beim Schnuppertag genau erfahren habe, was mich erwartet,
aber trotzdem ist es so.
In der Früh, wenn du angekommen bist, gehst du dann rein und kennst dich genau nüsse aus.
Klar, du warst schon wenigstens einmal fürs Forschungsgespräch da, aber trotzdem weißt du nichts.
Wahrscheinlich waren deine Anweisungen für den ersten Tag auch einfach nur,
sei um die und die Uhrzeit da und dann holt dich wer ab.
Aber bis sich die Person herbequemt und dich auch wirklich abholt,
hockst du erstmal doof rum. Und was bei mir auch so war, am ersten Arbeitstag, das ist ja dann
meistens sowas wie 1.1., 1.4., 1.9. oder irgendwie sowas, da sind dann noch mehr Leute da am ersten
Tag, die auch keinen Plan haben. Kann halt zwischen 20 Sekunden und 10 Minuten alles sein. Und dann
stehst du halt wie ein Kind, welches sich verlaufen hat, da und schaust, dass du so professionell wie
möglich erscheinst. Wenn dich dann endlich wer vom Eingang abholt, bekommst du nochmal eine kurze
Begrüßung in die Firma, musst den Arbeitsvertrag
unterschreiben, falls das nicht schon vorschossiert ist.
Okay, das ist bei mir immer vorher
passiert. Dann geht's auch schon in dein neues Büro,
wo du sowohl deinen neuen Arbeitsplatz als auch deine
neuen Kollegen kennenlernst. In meinem Fall
waren die zum Glück alle richtig entspannt und nett.
Leider kann's aber genauso gut sein,
dass du mit so richtig nervig... Was viel besser
ist, wenn man die Möglichkeit
hat, die Kollegen
oder zumindest die
meisten davon vom Team
mal wenigstens vorher kurz
Hallo gesagt zu haben.
Weil dann weiß man, dann wissen die schon, okay, da kommt kein totaler Depp und du weißt, okay, auf den ersten Blick gehen die ja auch halbwegs klar.
Das ist immer ganz praktisch.
... Leuten im Büro sitzt, um es mal nett auszudrücken.
Ich bin auch in einem offenen Büro gesessen, also in einem großen Raum mit, ich glaube, zwölf Leuten oder so, anstatt in einem kleinen zu zweit oder dritt und eines kann ich euch sagen, das war Horror.
Aber nicht mal, weil es jetzt so laut war.
Großraumbüro mit zwölf Leuten ist mal richtig für den Arsch.
Vor allem, da läuft halt permanent einer rum.
Permanent geht einer aufs Klo, permanent geht einer ans Telefon,
permanent geht einer zum anderen und guckt da irgendwas.
Permanent wird rumgestanden, Kaffee getrunken.
Also zwölfmal ein Großraum, das ist krass für den Arsch.
Bei uns, ich bin jetzt eigentlich ganz froh, wie es bei uns aktuell ist, wenn das Büro
komplett voll ist, passen maximal 2x4 Leute rein.
Das sind immer so 4er Sitzgruppe, also 4 Tische zusammen, dann ist eine Trennwand, so eine
schaltschutzwand dann kommt eine kleine sitzecke dann kommen noch eine trennwand
und dann kommen noch mal vier arbeitsplätze und wenn das büro voll ist
dann ist schon ein bisschen anstrengend und das bei acht leuten drin das gute
bei uns ist dass die büros eigentlich zu 95 prozent der zeit fast leer sind
Was es zwar auch war, wenn halt durchgehend irgendwer redet oder telefoniert,
sondern es ist einfach nur anstrengend und man fühlt sich die ganze Zeit beobachtet.
Ich meine, ich will ja eh nicht da hocken und nur chillen, aber chill doch mal Bro.
Warum starfst du mir gefühlt den ganzen Tag auf den Rücken oder den Bildschirm?
Halt den Kopf gerad und kümmere dich um deine eigenen Sachen.
Wie euch vielleicht auffällt, stellt sich jetzt aber immer noch eine große Frage.
Was muss ich jetzt wirklich machen? Wie ist der Job?
Und die Fragen klären sich jetzt auch im nächsten Punkt und zwar im
sich langsam einleben, wie ich ihn jetzt nennen würde.
Die ersten Wochen bis Monate oder eher Wochen bekommt man da im Normalfall nur die relativ leichten.
was wir schon für abgedrehte Sachen hatten.
So nach dem Motto, ha, vor zwölf Jahren.
Das ist ungefähr so, wie wenn ich euch immer Dinge erzähle.
So nach dem Motto, ey, habe ich euch schon mal erzählt,
vor zwölf Jahren, als wir Wartungsarbeiten am Wochenende hatten,
wo der Techniker seinen USB-Stick aus Versehen im Fahrstuhl verloren hat.
Und da kriegst du immer die Geschichten erzählt.
So nach dem Motto, Alter, das hat doch überhaupt keine Relevanz jetzt mehr.
Wie kriegst du immer History?
Kriegst du immer History erzählen?
Früher, als wir noch Solaris-Systeme hatten,
da war das ja ganz kompliziert.
Kannst ja froh sein, heute ist das alles viel besser.
Das Schlimme ist,
das machen die ja gar nicht,
weil die meinen das ja gar nicht böse.
Die wollen ja wirklich ein bisschen was sehen.
Das Schlimme ist, ich mach das ja auch.
Ich mach das ja auch
Was ich unserem ehemaligen Azubi
Für olle Kamellen schon erzählt hab
Und ich glaube, der tut immer nur so, als dass es ihn interessiert
Hat er ja auch recht
Keine Sau interessiert das, was ich da erzähle
Über irgendwelche Sachen, die 15 Jahre her sind
Aber wenigstens tut er so, als dass es ihn interessiert
Ja
Mich würde es auch nicht interessieren
An seiner Stelle
Okay.
Es gibt auch Firmen, die stellen jemanden ein, weil der Alte, der das gemacht hat, schon gekündigt hat.
Und du sitzt dann da und eigentlich weiß keiner, die wissen, dass jemand gebraucht wird.
Aber eigentlich wissen die nicht so genau, was und wie und warum und weshalb und wie jetzt.
Alfred, das kann ich tatsächlich nicht unterschreiben.
Dass die alten Leute massiv anstrengend sind.
Also wir haben zwei Leute im Team, die gehen bald in Rente.
So.
Mit einem davon verstehe ich mich, also ich verstehe mich eigentlich mit beiden, ja.
Also mit einem von dem verstehe ich mich echt ganz gut.
Mit dem kann ich auch durchaus da mal eine halbe Stunde ein bisschen schwätzen und so und alles top.
Der andere ist ein bisschen anstrengend.
Aber ich glaube, dass es nicht daran liegt, dass der anstrengend ist, weil der alt ist.
Sondern die anderen Leute erzählen mir eher, dass als der noch jünger war, dass der noch anstrengender war.
Historisch gewachsen, das sage ich aber auch gern.
Wisst ihr, der eine, der nimmt alles immer so super korrekt.
Der korrigiert auch gerne Leute.
Das nervt mich ja immer ein bisschen.
dann hat mich am Anfang, mittlerweile kann ich das einfach zur Kenntnis nehmen und sagen,
ja, ja, okay, mir fällt jetzt kein gutes Beispiel ein.
Ja, okay, stellt euch mal vor, stellt euch mal vor, ja,
ihr redet jetzt mit jemand über den Twitch-Chat, okay?
So, und ihr sagt dann, was weiß ich, der eine ist noch nicht so lange auf Twitch
und der andere ist schon länger auf Twitch und die reden dann so über Stream
und was sie sich gerne für Streamer angucken, so, und der eine sagt dann,
Ähm, ja, und was ich bei Wobblors ganz cool finde, dass der so viele verschiedene Emojis hat für den Chat.
So, da ist es eigentlich klar, was er meint.
Der andere ist noch nicht so lang auf Twitch und es ist klar, was er meint.
Ja, er meint Twitch-Emojis.
Aber dann gibt es Leute, die müssen dann währenddessen reinkrätschen, wenn sie das Gespräch von der Bande her angehört haben.
Die sind überhaupt nicht dran beteiligt.
die kommen dann um die Ecke und sagen,
nein, nein, das stimmt aber nicht.
Das sind eigentlich Emotes, keine Emojis.
Und so jemand ist das, weißt du?
Der muss dann immer so nach dem Motto,
ah, Moment, das heißt eigentlich streng genommen so.
Kennt ihr so Leute?
Actually.
Ja, genau.
So was in der Richtung.
Es ist eigentlich keine Automatisierung,
sondern streng genommen eine Ablaufsteuerung.
Sowas in der Richtung, ja?
Gibt's da so Leute?
Ja.
Das Rack in der Kammer, das existiert
immer noch, klar.
Ja, klar.
So, mal fertig gucken.
Ich würde erwarten, dass du voll dabei bist, aber so war es zumindest bei mir.
Aus meiner Erfahrung wird einem auch ein Kollege zugeteilt, der so mehr oder weniger da ist, um dich richtig einzuschulen und zu dem du für Fragen und das Ganze kommen kannst.
Also einfach gesagt, einer der dich babysittet.
Ich zum Beispiel war nach so einem Monat ziemlich gut eingeschult, würde ich sagen, und habe vieles allein handeln können, ohne eine Kurz-Erklärung zu bekommen.
Das ging aber richtig schnell.
Bei uns habe ich nach einem Monat bei den wichtigsten Abkürzungen halbwegs mal durchgeblickt,
dass ich wusste, was die Leute meinen.
Also, wisst ihr, was ich auch immer geil finde?
Wenn Leute E-Mails an größere Verteiler schreiben,
wir sind in Deutschland, E-Mails ist da immer noch das Standardding,
E-Mails an größere Verteiler schreiben zu einem Thema, womit sie sich auskennen, ja?
Das ist dann so, so keine Ahnung.
Wir haben letztens auf dem ZKB das GTA R neu gestartet und das FLM kam dabei nicht richtig hoch, weil die Latenz zwischen PFA und ZDIC zu hoch war.
Was habt ihr gemacht? Was willst du mir damit sagen, Alter?
Das ist dann so eine typische Mail, die wird einfach ignoriert
Und eine Woche später
Kommt dann nochmal eine Nachmail
Habt ihr dazu noch weiteren Input?
Sagt der Alter, ich hätte ja vielleicht was dazu gesagt
Wenn ich verstanden hätte, was du eigentlich geschrieben hast
Sieht dein Arbeitsplatz auch so aus
äh, weiß ich nicht, kann man das Video aufmachen, ohne dass da irgendwas Schlimmes passiert?
Wie jeder Administrator, der was auf sich hält, habe ich natürlich auch einen adäquaten Arbeitsplatz.
Werkzeug, Notizbuch...
Diesen Schraubendreher hier, der sieht aus wie das Ding, was, ähm...
War das Nocturne oder so früher mitgeliefert hat?
Oder be quiet? Be quiet?
Ja, be quiet kann sein, ja.
Ist das ein VDE?
Schrauber?
Da ist es aber. Ich habe keinen VDE-Aufdruck gesehen.
Ne, so sieht mein Arbeitsplatz ab überhaupt gar nicht aus.
Auf meinem Schreibtisch ist nichts drauf.
außer das Notebook,
der Monitor,
Maus und Tastatur.
Maus und Tastatur schließe ich auch immer ein,
wenn ich gehe, weil wir haben ja so Wechselarbeitsplätze.
Ähm,
ich habe keine Festplatten rumliegen,
nichts, weil ich mit Hardware nichts zu tun habe.
Notizbücher
habe ich auch nicht mehr, keine Offline-Dinger.
Ähm,
Kaffee trinke ich nicht.
Energydrinks trinke ich nicht. Chips habe ich nicht rumstehen.
Ne, mein Arbeitsplatz sieht überhaupt nicht so aus.
Aber es hat trotzdem Dinge gegeben, die ich original nach 10 Monaten immer noch gefreestyled
habe, weil mir die einfach so schlecht erklärt worden sind und ich irgendwann einfach noch
nicht mehr fragen wollte. Also Grüße getraut an meinen alten Chef, wenn da was nicht passt,
Tut's mir leid.
In der Zeit ändert sich dein Status dann auch von der Neue zu einem vollwertigen Mitglied des Teams.
Was so viel heißt, wie du bist jetzt ein vollwertiger Teil der Firma und darfst hier die nächsten Jahre vergammeln.
Und wisst ihr, was das noch für ein Punkt ist?
Dass er das Gefühl hat, er vergammelt in der Firma, liegt aber daran, dass er Projektmanagement macht.
Der, wo man merkt, dass man in einem Bürojob ehrlich keine 40 Stunden arbeitet, außer man ist wirklich extrem unterbesetzt.
Es kann je nach der Position und dem genauen Job nämlich schon mal gut vorkommen, dass man gut und gerne mal in vielleicht vier statt acht Stunden mit seiner ganzen Arbeit für den Tag fertig ist.
Es kann aber auch sein, dass man einfach den ganzen Tag gar nichts macht, weil man von morgens bis abends mietet.
Wo wir gerade dabei sind, das mache ich doch immer ganz gerne.
Lasst mal checken, wie sieht dann mein Meeting-Pensum für nächste Woche aus?
Wartet mal, Sekunde, Sekunde.
Die wichtigen Sachen müssen wir jetzt gleich mal erklären.
Schau mal doch mal.
Also.
Meeting-Stells.
Oh, ich muss mein Passwort eingeben.
So, gucken wir doch mal.
Teams?
Alter.
Verwaltete Software-Update.
Geh mir nicht auf den Sack jetzt.
Ich will doch einfach nur Teams aufmachen.
Also, so.
Jetzt. Gucken wir mal.
Ähm.
Montag, da bin ich nicht da.
Dienstag, Sprint Review.
Ah, excellent.
Sprint Review.
Also geht, okay, geht 9.30 Uhr los.
Danach Daily Scrum.
Dann Team Daily.
Dann Sprint-Retrospektive
Dann Sprint-Planung
Dann, das kann ich jetzt nicht vorlesen
Dann gibt es Infoveranstaltungen zu IAC und Cloud-Themen
Ich muss das jetzt mal ein bisschen umschreiben
Das war es dann für Dienstag
Das heißt, ich bin von 9.30 Uhr bis 14.30 Uhr quasi permanent am Mieten.
Ja, Moment mal.
Sprint, das heißt ja nicht, dass Daily Scrum und Sprint für das gleiche Projekt ist.
Zwangsläufig.
So.
Weiter.
Mittwoch.
9 Uhr geht es.
Mittwochs geht es 9 Uhr los.
Infoveranstaltung, so was es Neues gibt
Dann
Daily Scrum
Danach Service Meeting
Zu einer
Anwendung, die ich mit betreue
Beziehungsweise ich betreue die Server unter der Anwendung
Dann gibt es ein
Meeting mit einem Softwarehersteller
Der Zeug für uns programmiert
Dann gibt es
Team Meeting
Ne, Gruppen Meeting
dann gibt es team meeting dann gibt es austausch und fix fürs projekt und dann ist es 15 uhr also
es geht los es geht los ist schon keine mittwoch geht los 9 uhr nächstes meeting 9 uhr 30 nächstes
meeting 9 uhr 45 nächstes meeting 10 uhr 30 überschneidet sich mit dem team meeting 10 uhr
35 das geht dann bis kurz vor 12 dann wird mittag gegessen dann 12 uhr 45 geht es weiter 14 uhr und
abschließend noch 15 bis 16 uhr austausch und synchro fix nice ok also im prinzip mache ich
Dienstag außer Gemiete nicht viel
und ich mache Mittwoch außer Gemiete
gar nichts.
Dann gucken wir mal Donnerstag.
Donnerstag Service Meeting
für einen Service, wo ich nichts mit zu tun habe.
Gut, das kann ich skippen.
Aber parallel habe ich was anderes.
Service Meeting für
ein Service, mit dem ich was zu tun habe. 9 Uhr.
Daily Scrum
9.30 Uhr.
Team Daily 10 Uhr.
Dann irgendwas
mit Cloud Gedöns
Haschikorb um 11.
Ähm.
Ja, und dann habe ich von
11 bis 13.30 Uhr nix
am Donnerstag.
Um 13.30 Uhr bis
14.30 Uhr habe ich noch irgendwelche
Terraform-Bastelgeschichten.
Also Donnerstag ist tatsächlich ein Tag,
wo ich mal drei Stunden oder sowas machen kann.
Nice, oder? Und Freitag auch.
Freitag auch. Freitag ist auch dann nur Daily Scrum.
Äh, Team Daily.
und danach um 14 Uhr noch mal was.
Also Donnerstag kann ich drei Stunden was machen.
Freitag kann ich vielleicht so vier, fünf Stunden was machen.
Restliche Zeit wird...
Also ich kann...
Runden wir es mal auf.
Ich kann ungefähr zehn Stunden was arbeiten die Woche.
Der Rest ist Gemiete.
Nice.
Ah ne, Moment.
Freitag ist Feiertag.
Stimmt, am Freitag mache ich gar nichts.
Ach, deswegen war so viel frei am Freitag.
Deswegen waren so wenig Meetings am Freitag.
Das erklärt es natürlich.
Wie viele dieser Meetings sind wirklich notwendig?
Na, wenn du die Veranstalter der Meetings fragst, jedes einzelne.
Wart ihr eigentlich von der Sicherheitslücke betroffen, bei der die aus dem Bett geklingelt wurden?
Das meinst du, wo die Polizei bei manchen Admins vor der Tür gestanden hat?
Nee, waren wir nicht.
Okay, so.
Schauen wir mal weiter.
Übrigens, Chat, wenn ich diese sinnlosen Montags, äh, nicht Montags, Sonntagsmorgens Laberstells und Videoguckstreams gefallen, könnt ihr mir jetzt mal an der Stelle ein Follow dalassen, würde mich freuen.
Schön, dass auch so viele da sind.
Ist immer eine gute Zeit, Sonntagsmorgens zu streamsen.
Freut mich, dass ihr so zahlreich erschienen seid.
Wenn es nicht gefällt, dann direkt bannen.
bringt nicht vergessen sehr gut erst recht dann wenn es euch nicht gefällt
dürft ihr auch da bleiben ist auch okay
er diesen mist gibt es glücklicherweise auf twitch nicht
ja schön herr misser
gut da kommt man das jetzt endlich mal fertig hier mitbekommen weil wie gesagt
ich selbst hatte das glück in einer unterbesetzten abteilung in der uns
eigentlich auch mit mir noch mindestens eine Person, am besten zwei gefehlt haben und in der das Business auch mit Abstand am besten gelaufen ist zu sein.
Der Fakt, dass wir eh schon Stress damit hatten, alle Kunden richtig zu betreuen, hat mich aber auch nicht davon abgehalten, pünktlich zu gehen.
Weißt du, ich habe um Punkt 6 angefangen und um Punkt 15 oder so.
Ganz ehrlich, sehe ich ganz genau so.
Sehe ich ganz genau, Moment, wann ist der hin? Moment, Moment.
Der Fakt, dass wir eh schon Stress damit hatten, alle Kunden richtig zu betreuen, hat mich aber auch nicht davon abgehalten, pünktlich zu gehen.
Also ich habe um Punkt 6 angefangen.
Um 6 Uhr?
Um Punkt 15 Uhr das Haus.
Okay, 15 Uhr ist eine gute Zeit zum Heimgehen.
Aber 6 Uhr anfangen ist ja richtig mies.
Da musst du 5 Uhr irgendjemanden aufstehen.
Oder noch früher.
Ich bin früher jahrelang 5.45 Uhr aufgestanden.
Du konntest es komplett vergessen.
Ich war einfach nur im Arsch die ganze Zeit.
Komplett im Arsch.
Ja, aber pünktlich anfangen, pünktlich gehen, das ist ja was, wo die ganzen Boomer immer so tun, so nach dem Motto, die jungen Leute wollen nicht arbeiten.
Nee, die jungen Leute haben nur keinen Bock, sich ausbeuten zu lassen. Und dass Teilzeit immer weiter auf dem Vormarsch ist, kann ich auch verstehen, weil du bezahlst so abfuck viel Steuern und wenn du erstmal auf einem gewissen Gehaltsniveau bist, dann juckt dich das bisschen weniger auch nicht.
Du sparst ja auch ein bisschen Steuern dadurch.
Und die Lebenszeit, die du dadurch mehr kriegst, ist einfach nicht aufzuwiegen.
So.
Verlassen.
Könnt ihr mich verhaten, aber ich durfte original nicht mal Überstunden machen.
Wow, keist, Alter.
wegen der schlechten Wirtschaftslage halt ehrlich verboten. Wisst ihr außerdem, was man in der
Einlebungsphase bis auf die eigentliche Arbeit noch lernt? Richtig, wie man so richtig schön
Zeit totschlagen kann. Vor allem, wenn man mal einen Tag hat, wo man wirklich nach vier Stunden
nichts mehr zu tun hat. Ich mein, was soll ich sonst machen? Nach mehr Arbeit fragen? Safe nicht.
Wahrscheinlich mache ich fürs gleiche Geld die doppelte Arbeit von den anderen, nur weil die sich
Zeit lassen. Und dann lernt man halt mal so die Basics wie draußen mit anderen einen Kaffee
trinken, ne Raucherpause machen, auch wenn man so wie ich nicht Raucher ist und sich nur dazu stellt.
Ja, ein bisschen Füße vertreten ist ja schon in Ordnung.
Chillen, aka TikTok schauen.
Oder was auch ein Banger ist, wenn man schon weiß, dass der heutige Tag langweilig wird und man gleichzeitig statt festen Arbeitszeiten hat,
einfach früh als der Chef kommen und eierchillen, bis der da ist.
Würde ich selbst natürlich nie machen, aber man bekommt halt mit, dass solche Sachen theoretisch funktionieren würden, solange man nicht komplett damit übertreibt.
Was ich auch immer geil finde ist, es gibt Leute, die brauchen für alles ewig, wirklich ewig.
So nach dem Motto, kannst du mir da mal einen User anlegen? Das ist eine Sache von fünf Minuten, die brauchen zwei Wochen dafür. Und jedes Mal, wenn du die fragst, sagen sie so, oh, es ist so viel zu tun, Alter, was ich jetzt noch alles machen muss. Und wir machen, da kommt wieder diese Aussage, ich mache jetzt ja eh schon hier die Arbeit von zwei und es ist unglaublich stressig, jetzt kommt gleich, Alter, what the fuck.
und dann gehst du dann mal da vorbei
und da chillt der übelst rum.
Und dann muss man sich mal überlegen,
da muss man sich mal überlegen,
eigentlich,
so preis-leistungsmäßig,
macht der es ja richtig.
Alle denken,
das ist unser wichtigster,
bester Mann, weil der immer
drüber erzählt, wie krasser
Arbeit und wie viel er macht und wie anstrengend
es ist und in Wirklichkeit schildert
sich das Leben.
Der macht es eigentlich genau richtig.
Der verkauft das gut,
was er macht. So wie ich das
vorhin gesagt habe.
Das war nur ein Beispiel
mit dem User jetzt. Das war nur ein Beispiel.
Mir ist gerade nichts besseres eingefallen.
Glücklicherweise muss ich keinen
mehr anrufen zum User erstellen.
Gut, Ticket verlangen finde ich gut, Ticket verlangen mache ich auch mittlerweile.
Bei den meisten Sachen.
Egal, fertig, guckt.
Okay, ich habe zwar gesagt, dass man zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt schon ein fest verbauter Teil in der Firma ist,
aber das war vielleicht nicht ganz richtig.
Der Zeitpunkt, wo das nämlich der Fall ist und das Einlernen in meinen Augen auch offiziell vorbei ist,
ist, wenn man in seinem Kalender sieht, dass wieder mal ein Meeting eingetragen ist
also alles normal, aber dein Chef dann zu dir kommt und dir erklärt, dass du derjenige bist, der das leiten wird.
Da heißt es dann auch so richtig Arsch lecken, vor allem wenn man bis jetzt einer von denen war,
die so unterqualifiziert für ihre Stelle sind, dass sie beim Einlernen auch nichts gecheckt haben
und bis jetzt eigentlich nur mit Nicken und Sätzen wie, ja, das muss ich noch abchecken, überlebt haben.
Ich weiß nicht, irgendwie...
Da sind wir dran, Leute. Da sind wir dran. Ich nehm das mal mit und da sind wir dran.
Glauben die anscheinend, dass man sich da so richtig drauf freut und alles?
Und vielleicht ist das bei manchen auch der Fall, aber ne Bro, da habe ich überhaupt keinen Bock drauf.
Das Meeting wird auf gut Glück gefreestellt und solange man wenigstens irgendwas weiß und nicht den ganzen Tag nur verstecken gespielt hat, wird man das im Normalfall auch überleben.
Oder man tut es halt nicht und expost sich vor allen Leuten im Meeting als Imposter, der in weitem nichts weiß und ziemlich sicher bald gekickt wird.
Wenn man das Meeting aber überlebt und dabei vielleicht sogar noch ganz gut performt hat, weil man gar kein Imposter ist, ist man komplett gekocht.
Und warum? Ganz einfach.
Wenn du Pech hast, bist du jetzt offiziell einer von denen, zu dem andere Leute kommen, um Fragen zu stellen, wenn sie sich nicht auskennen.
Und was war bei mir das?
Ja, aber das finde ich nicht schlimm.
Also mir ist es lieber, jemand fragt was oder wenn das was ist, worauf er weiß, dass ich mich auskenne oder wo ich weiß, dass er sich auskennt,
anstatt dass da irgendwas gebastelt wird und am Ende geht es kaputt.
Bestes Beispiel dafür, da habe ich sogar mal ein Video auf YouTube drüber gemacht.
Wir haben mal auf der alten Arbeit oder auf der vorletzten Arbeit war das sogar noch,
Wir haben mal einen Storage-Experten neu eingestellt dort. Und er hat am ersten oder zweiten oder dritten Tag, zumindest war es in seiner ersten Woche, hat der irgendwas am, ich kann das jetzt nur weitergeben, ich habe ehrlich gesagt keinen plassen Schimmer, was es ist, am Interwisan-Routing irgendwas gemacht.
ergibt das Sinn?
Chat, wer kennt sich mit Storage aus?
Gibt es sowas wie Intervisan-Routing?
Ich weiß nur,
mir hat damals einer von unseren
anderen Storage-Leuten erzählt, er hat was am
Intervisan-Routing gemacht.
Also ich hab keine Ahnung, was
ein Inter-V-San-Routing ist.
Das scheint es zu geben.
Intervisan-Routing.
Alles klar.
Zumindest hat er irgendwas am Intervisan-Routing.
gedreht
Und daraufhin war das Storage kaputt.
Das ist ja schon mal geil in der produktiven Storage in der ersten Woche was kaputt zu machen, aber dann kam der Hit.
Anstatt dass er gesagt hat, ups Leute, ich glaube ich hab da Mist gebaut,
ist er aufgestanden, hat seine Jacke genommen und war drei Stunden erst mal weg.
Ist einfach geflüchtet, ist einfach abgehauen.
Einfach Ragequit.
Er hat wahrscheinlich gehofft, in der Zeit, wo er weg ist, erledigt sich das von alleine wieder.
Ist einfach Rage quittet.
Und als er dann wiedergekommen ist, hat man natürlich schon längst rausgekriegt, dass alles im Arsch war und dass er das gewesen ist.
Und das war der erste, den ich gesehen habe, der raus-eskortiert wurde.
Ja, das war der mit der Security.
Das erste, den ich gesehen habe, der raus-eskortiert wurde und nicht mehr rein durfte.
Habe ich vorher auch noch nicht erlebt, dass es das gab.
Das Geiste daran, ich habe mich ja selbst nicht richtig ausgekannt.
Wenn ich gerade mal so meine Aufgaben bewältigen kann, habe ich doch keine Ahnung, was richtig ausgekannt.
Alter, achso, nee. Ich dachte, das ist eine 19-Zoll-Kiste, ist es aber gar nicht.
Gerade mal so meine Aufgaben bewältigen kann, habe ich doch keine Ahnung von irgendwelchen anderen Dingen, die in anderen Abteilungen oder bei anderen Kunden abgehen.
Eine gute Sache hat das Ganze aber trotzdem.
Weil man jetzt nicht mehr der ist, auf den extra viel Aufmerksamkeit gelegt wird, muss man nicht mehr auf krampfreien Hasseln, um gut dazustehen,
weswegen die größte Mission eigentlich ist, zu entscheiden, ob es besser ist, die eigene Arbeit schnell fertig zu machen und dann auch beschäftigt zu tun, während man irgendwas macht,
oder sie ganz langsam abzuarbeiten, sodass man sich den ganzen Zirkus spart.
Und ja, das ist genau der Punkt, bei dem mir dann dieser Satz in den Kopf gekommen ist.
Bürojobs machen ja überhaupt keinen Sinn.
Ich meine, versteht mich nicht falsch.
Weniger arbeiten fürs gleiche Geld ist top und alles.
Also ich will nicht sagen, dass ich lieber den ganzen Tag unter großem Druck stehen will.
Aber irgendwann denkt man sich dann auch einfach nur noch, was das für eine Scheiße ist,
dass man jetzt sein restliches Leben in irgendeinem Büro sitzt, für kurze Zeit etwas zu tun hat
und danach Great Pretender spielen darf, um nicht als der Faule dazustehen.
Klar ergeben Bürojobs Sinn.
Das kommt drauf an, was du für einen Job hast.
Wenn man Projektmanagement heiße Lufträder ist, dann mag das durchaus so sein.
Aber ich habe das Glück, mich interessiert ja auch noch zumindest zum größten Teil.
Nicht immer, mich interessiert aber auch zum größten Teil das, was ich mache.
Da habe ich keine Schmerzen mit.
Und ich habe da auch nicht das Gefühl, groß abzugammeln.
Natürlich interessiert mich nicht alles.
ja irgendwelche
prüfungs dinger compliance sachen oder hier musste noch im ticket die uhrzeit mit dran
schreiben und fünfte dings irgendwelche accounts durch klicken finde ich auch nicht geil ja musste
die büroarbeit machen aber was ist für ein sinn macht oft so wenig arbeit auf so viele leute
aufzuteilen ist wieder eine andere sache in meinen augen das wird mich loki einfach depressiv machen
wenn ich das für mein restliches Leben machen muss, weil ich mich einfach so nutze...
By the way, ich bin nicht so firm im Gen-Alpha-Speak.
Was bedeutet Low-Key in dem Zusammenhang?
...und gelangweilt fühlen würde, dass es einfach nicht mehr lustig wäre.
Aber zum Glück hatte ich ja eh nur Stress in meinem alten Job, also war das ja nicht mein Problem.
Was aber nach meinem Wissen auch noch ein richtiger Game-Changer ist,
was das ganze zu wenig Arbeiten gleich wieder geil macht, ist Homeoffice.
Da sitzt man dann zu Hause herum, macht seine Aufgaben, aber kann jederzeit Pause machen, ohne offiziell Pause zu machen.
Heißt, theoretisch machst du deine Sachen und wenn du fertig bist, schaust du einfach YouTube oder eine Serie und behältst halt dein PC und dein Handy im Blick, falls du angerufen wirst.
So, das war es jetzt aber auch schon mit dem Video.
Das werde ich am Wochenende, nächstes Wochenende werde ich das machen.
Nächstes Wochenende
habe ich Bereitschaft
für das gesamte Osterwochenende
also das heißt von
Donnerstag so irgendwie
18 Uhr rum bis
Montag früh
habe ich Bereitschaft
es sind keine Wartungsarbeiten oder irgendwas
geplant, das heißt ich werde eigentlich nur
das Handy neben mir liegen lassen
und hoffen, dass keiner anruft
gibt das extra Kohle?
Das gibt massive Kohle, Alter.
Das ist ja nicht einfach nur Bereitschaft,
du könntest, wenn du wolltest,
das ist ja wirklich Bereitschaft mit
vorgeschriebener Reaktionszeit.
Also, ich bin ja da auch wirklich eingeschränkt,
ich kann jetzt nicht sagen, ich fahre jetzt mal nach Frankfurt oder so.
Das gibt
für in der Regel nichts
zu tun, massive Kohle,
Alter.
Ich weiß, es hat jetzt vielleicht nicht so einen roten Farben.
Lowkey gibt das hier Kohle.
Barbar strukturiert, aber für einen kleinen Rant über Bürojobs am Mittwoch passt das schon.
Ich meine, ich schon was Wahres dran.
Kommt halt, es liegt halt auch ein bisschen daran, wenn man so einen Bullshit-Job hat, dann, ja, empfindet man das wahrscheinlich auch nur als Abgammeln.
Was kriege ich eigentlich für komische Videos hier empfohlen? Das juckt mich doch hinten und vorn.
Okay, das kenne ich schon.
Wo ist der Haken?
Okay, gucken wir mal.
CT 3003.
Guck mal hier.
Das ist mein neuer Arcade-Automat.
Sieht doch nice aus, oder?
Sieht nice aus.
Ist aber was, was mich persönlich irgendwie nicht so schockt.
Wahrscheinlich bin ich ein bisschen zu jung noch,
dass ich diese ganze Arcade-Geschichte mitgekriegt habe.
Klar, ich kenne Spielautomaten und sowas.
Also nicht die Slot-Automaten oder sowas.
Arcade-Automaten.
Aber das ...
Das hab ich nie so abgefeiert.
Ich glaub, da bin ich einen Ticken zu jung für.
Ein paar Jahre älter ...
Wahrscheinlich würd ich da voll draufstehen, ja.
Kann man auch problemlos mit zwei Leuten draufspielen,
so ein bisschen Street Fighter und so.
Oder halt auch ungefähr Zehntausende andere Spiele.
Also wirklich Zehntausende.
Und jetzt kommt das Ding.
Natürlich nur selbst gerippte ROMs.
Das Ding hat 350.
Obviously, logisch, oder?
Und nebenbei Linux-Distributionen runterladen.
Euro gekostet.
Mit allem.
Das ist aber sehr günstig, 350 Euro.
Für so ein komplettes Ding.
Das guckst du wahrscheinlich scharf an und es fällt auseinander.
Im Speichermedium, auf dem das hier läuft.
Da habe ich nichts schön gerechnet.
Das, was ihr hier seht, ist komplett die mitgelieferte Hardware für 350 Euro.
Da habe ich nichts dazu getan oder dazu gekauft.
Und gleich mal als Spoiler vorweg, das Teil macht mir richtig Spaß.
Aber ein paar Haken gibt es trotzdem.
Bleibt dran.
Was haben Arcade-Automaten mit Identitätsdiebstahl zu tun?
Wenig.
Aber Identitätsgipfelstahl ist halt doof.
Und da kommt Inkognitenspiel.
Ich dachte, jetzt kommt NordVPN oder sowas.
Arcade-Automat ist und war schon immer so ein Sehnsuchtsgerät von mir.
Ich wünsche mir eigentlich immer schon so ein Ding.
Weil ich liebe Arcade-Spiel.
Bei mir sieht das anders aus.
Wo ich richtig Bock drauf hätte, was zu bauen, was ich aber nicht mache.
Ich sage euch gleich, warum.
Wo ich richtig Bock drauf hätte, mal sowas zu bauen,
ist ein PC mit,
gehen wir mal auf Ebay,
ich würde gern einen Rechner
mal bauen mit
zwei Voodoo 2
Karten per SLI
und einer TNT 1
und einem, was auch da war, keine Ahnung,
Pentium 2 450 oder sowas.
Quasi zu der Zeit, wo ich
mich so richtig krass für Hardware interessiert
habe und das das Beste war, was es gibt,
das hätte ich gerne mal
als Rechner. So, warum ich es nicht
mache, ist folgendes. Das liegt gar
nicht so sehr am Geld. Es ist unsinnig teuer
heutzutage, diese Dinger. Ja, okay, aber
damals waren die noch teurer, aber
im Prinzip sind diese Karten schon wirklich brutal teuer
geworden. Ne, die sind heute teurer als damals
neu.
Aber ich mache das nicht, weil
ich genau weiß,
der eigentliche Reiz
daran ist nur das
Zusammenbauen und vielleicht noch das
einrichten und wenn ich dann erst mal habe werde ich es wahrscheinlich nie
benutzen so deswegen mache ich das nicht
wie läuft ein neues nas und was hast du dich für um v oder lxc wird nur noch gar
nichts meine die die ssd performance ist mir etwas zu variabel noch mal gucken
woran das liegt.
Als Deko-Objekt, ja.
Wobei man sagen muss, als Deko-Objekt macht dann so ein
Arcade-Automat schon ein bisschen mehr her.
Und ich liebe auch
Software-Frickeln mit Emulatoren und so.
Und deshalb kam für mich
nie so ein wirklich echter
Arcade-Automat in Frage, weil man da halt
nur ein Spiel drauf spielen kann.
Eben die Platine, die da eingebaut ist.
Ja klar, man kann natürlich auch einen echten Automaten zu so einer Emulationskiste umbauen.
Im besten Fall sogar mit dem Original-Röhrenbildschirm, was natürlich cool ist.
Dafür fehlt mir aber einfach das Heimwerker-Talent.
Ja, so ein CRT-Bildschirm bei den Dingern ist schon nice.
Das ist mir zu viel Holz und Lötarbeit.
Und teuer sind die Originale natürlich auch.
Deshalb habe ich mich zuerst auch gefreut, als vor ein paar Jahren diese hübschen Kisten von Arcade One-Up auf den Markt kamen.
Sogar mit lizenzierten Spielen und den entsprechenden Gehäusedesigns.
Aber das Problem für mich als 1,94 Meter Typen, die sind klein.
Die sind nur zwei Drittel so groß wie echte Automaten.
Auch wenn immer drei, vier gesagt werden.
Dann musst du per Mal gebückt davor stehen.
Zwei Drittel trifft es besser.
Also das ist so richtiges Rückenschmerzen-Territory für mich.
Deshalb habe ich da nie zugeschlagen.
Dafür aber bei diesem Teil hier, was jetzt bei uns im Büro steht.
Aber 350 Euro oder Dollar?
Zugeschlagen.
Dafür aber bei diesem Teil.
350 Euro, das ist schon echt billig, ja.
Also ich gehe mal davon aus, das Ding, das hustest du an und es fällt auseinander oder so.
Anders kann ich mir das nicht vorstellen.
Ich meine, da ist die komplette Elektronik dabei.
Das Gehäuse.
Der Bildschirm.
Sound.
Und?
Also
Das ist echt billig
Hier, was jetzt bei uns im Büro steht
Das heißt, steht ja auch dran
Iconic Arcade und kommt von
Achtung, da wird ihr jetzt nicht auf Anhieb drauf gekommen
Medion, also die Marke
Die ihr wahrscheinlich von Aldi kennt
Also unter anderem steckt Medion dahinter
Und die Iconic Arcade Geräte
Die sind zumindest so groß
Dass ich da ohne Krankengymnastik
Danach dran spielen kann
Der Automat hier, den ich gekauft habe, misst 1,58 Meter in der Höhe.
Das ist zwar etwas kleiner als zum Beispiel ein Original Pac-Man Automat, der damals 1,73 Meter hoch war,
aber hey, ich finde es komplett ausreichend, funktioniert für mich gut.
Ja, und was ist da nun drin außer dem Gehäuse?
Ein 21 Zoll Full HD LC Bildschirm, ein Soundsystem mit zwei 4 Zoll Lautsprechern,
ein Arcade Steuerbord mit zwei Mikroschalter-Joysticks und 16 Tasten und natürlich auch ein Computer.
Das ist ein Raspberry Pi 4 mit einem Gigabyte RAM und einem Netzteil.
Das Netzteil versorgt auch gleich Bildschirm und Soundsystem mit Strom.
Ob es sich da schon lohnt, den RAM abzulöten?
Praktisch.
Ja, und das alles für 350 Euro.
Das ist echt günstig.
Und allein der Raspi würde im Kit mindestens 72 Euro kosten.
Bleiben noch 278 Euro für die anderen Komponenten.
Bin mir recht sicher, dass man die für den Preis auf dem freien Markt so nicht oder sehr schwierig bekommt.
Das denke ich auch.
Also allein für so ein Gehäuse, unlackiert aus MDF, das habe ich im Netz gefunden, dafür werden 350 Euro aufgerufen.
Also nur für das Gehäuse.
Also Preis-Leistung wirkt erstmal richtig gut.
Aber obwohl der Karton 29 Kilo wiegt, habe ich dann schon beim Auspacken gemerkt, das ist jetzt nicht so die super stabile Qualität.
Das Material...
Das habe ich mir auch gedacht.
Wie gesagt, ich bin immer noch der Meinung, wahrscheinlich wenn du das Ding scharf anschaust, fällt es auseinander.
Ist ziemlich dünn, das sind so Holzfaserplatten mit mehr Fasern als Holz.
Ich würde aber trotzdem sagen, dass das seinen Zweck erfüllt.
Also man könnte das Teil zwar auf keinen Fall in eine Kneipe stellen oder so, wo Leute in Zuständen rustikal damit umgehen.
Aber hier in meinem Heiseumfeld mit so feingliedrigen Computerleuten, da passt das schon.
Für den Aufbau habe ich so zwei Stunden entspannt gebraucht, war alles gut dokumentiert, hat auch Spaß gemacht.
Also am Ende mit der Verkabelung, da war es ein bisschen verwirrend, aber habe ich dann irgendwann hinbekommen.
Was man aber ziemlich deutlich merkt, das Ding ist auf keinen Fall dafür gemacht, dass man es mehrfach auseinander und wieder aufbaut.
Also für den Transport oder so.
Das ist dafür gemacht, das einmal irgendwo hinzustellen.
Ja, und dann überlebt es da wahrscheinlich eine Zeit, sage ich mal.
Ich habe auf jeden Fall auch einmal den Fehler gemacht, dass ab Werk schon fertig...
Guck mal, guck mal.
Ich hab auf jeden Fall auch einmal den Fehler gemacht
Die Schrauben sind einfach da reingedreht
Das sind keine
Inserts oder irgendwas
Wie nennt man das?
Ich kenn nur diese Dinger für einen 3D Drucker
Threaded Inserts oder wie heißt das?
Diese Dinger hier
Sowas gibt's doch garantiert
Auch für Holz, oder?
Ja, solche Dinger
das ab Werk schon fertig verschraubte
Controllerboard oben mal aufzuschrauben,
also die obere Platte.
Ja, und da kam mir dann beim Schraubenlösen
direkt die Späne hier entgegen.
Also ich sag mal, lieber nicht zu viel
rumschrauben, wenn das Teil einmal steht.
Also ihr könnt den Arcade-Controller-Kasten
mit Raspi auch separat
verwenden und dann einfach an einen
Fernseher anschließen über HDMI.
auch ganz schön oder ihr könnt auch nur den oberen Teil des Iconic Arcade verwenden,
so als Bartop oder Tabletop. Die Technik ist komplett da oben drin, das Untergestell ist rein
mechanisch und optional. So, jetzt zur Software und hier war ich wirklich positiv überrascht.
Da liegen ein USB Stick und eine leere Micro SD Karte bei. Ja und dann schaltet man das Ding ein,
bootet von USB Stick und dann kann man hier so aussuchen, welche der drei Linux Emulations
distri ist man auch die micro sd drauf installieren will also war der retro oder die sind auf dem usb
stick schon drauf ok box und das finde ich schon war zu sehr das ist ja das haben wir mal nach
geguckt das heißt das ist irgendein käfer auf japanisch glaube ich ob das war ihnen käfer und
mal ziemlich erstaunlich für so ein konsum produkt das da so eine offenheit klebt wird das hat mir
ganz gut gefallen. Und was ich auch gut fand, auf dem USB-Stick ist so ein komplettes Testprogramm,
mit dem man die beiden Sticks und jede Taste auf Funktion prüfen kann. Durchaus sinnvoll.
Weil ich Bato Serra Ultra bin, habe ich mich natürlich nicht nur sofort für Bato Serra
entschieden, sondern ich hatte auch direkt einen aktuellen Bato Serra Stick griffbereit,
also die ganz normale Version für Raspis, also keine spezielle Iconic Arcade Variante. Und da
war ich jetzt nochmal positiv überrascht, denn das Teil funktionierte out of the box,
ohne jegliche konfiguration youtube videos kann ja das wieder machen wenn ich dafür frei im kopf
bin dem ganz normalen barthes herr aber ich war tatsächlich die letzten monate ein paar mal kurz
davor auch vielleicht auch mal so ein update video warum ich jetzt zwei jahre kann oder zwei jahre
nicht ein jahr kein video gemacht habe ich habe zwar zwei jahre keines gemacht aber das problem
existiert erst seit einem jahr klar ist so ein standard usb arcade encoder board drin dass sich
als Standard Game Controller ausgibt, aber trotzdem, man kann sich auch mal freuen über so viel Problemlosigkeit.
Es ist auch zum Beispiel direkt möglich, mit beiden Joysticks das Menü zu steuern, was ich auch ganz nett finde.
Ja, mit der B-Taste ruft man dann ein Spiel auf und man kann dann direkt loslegen.
Allerdings sind bei Bartos Serra zwar Spiele vorinstalliert, aber vermutlich sind es nicht die, die ihr euch erhofft.
Das sind halt so freie Homebrew-Titel. Ganz nett, aber wie gesagt, nicht die echten Spielhallen-Spiele.
Na, ROMs haben wir natürlich alle eh nur von den originalen Medien gerippt.
Ja, es geht wieder ganz okay, ja.
Und hier kommen wir jetzt in den allseits beliebten rechtlichen Graubereich.
In diesem Video hier habe ich das mal etwas ausführlicher behandelt, unter anderem auch, wo man legal ROMs herbekommt.
Deshalb gehe ich jetzt hier nicht weiter darauf ein und gehe einfach mal davon aus, dass ihr ROMs habt.
Ja, und dann habt ihr zwei Möglichkeiten, die auf den Automaten zu kriegen.
Entweder ihr habt ein Linux-System, da könnt ihr dann einfach den Bato Serra-Datenträger reinstecken und dann seht ihr im Laufwerk Share schon das Verzeichnis ROMs und die Unterordner für alle unterstützenden Systeme.
Ich muss jetzt mal gucken, wie man Bato Serra auf Japanisch ausspricht.
Korrekte Ausschreibung ist
mit weichem C
wie S
Bartosera
das spricht die Japaner bestimmt nicht so aus
Kiyosera
Bartosera
was sagt diese komische Seite
hier dazu
Tocera.
Nein, das ist Text to Speech, Alter.
Ja, hoffe ich auch.
Oder ist ja schon bergauf gegangen.
Geht auch noch bergauf.
Guck mal nicht, wie man es ausspricht.
Arcade-Spiele sind das zum Beispiel.
Das ist Japanisch.
Das spricht man bestimmt, keine Ahnung.
ähm, Batus, ne,
wie würden wir sagen, Batosera
oder so, Batosera.
Und MAME
auf dem Raspberry 4 würde ich
FB Neo empfehlen, weil der
performanter ist als MAME, allerdings auch
weniger Spiele unterstützt. Also ihr könnt
beides benutzen. Ihr könnt in beide eure
ROMs reinkopieren. Ja, direkt
auf den Datenträger schreiben, geht aber
wirklich nur auf Linux-Systemen, weil
Bato Serra das Filesystem
Ext4 verwendet. Das können Windows und
macOS standardmäßig... Es gibt, habe ich
letztens mal auf GitHub gesehen,
es gibt für Windows
einen Ext4-Treiber.
Warum auch immer man
das verwenden sollte, aber
hier, guck mal.
Ext4-Filesystem for Windows.
Gibt es.
Warum? Ich weiß es nicht. Aber es gibt's.
...dich nicht
lesen und schreiben. Wenn ihr Windows oder Mac
OS benutzt, könnt ihr aber was anderes
machen, was ich sowieso eleganter finde.
Sobald ihr Bato Serra mit eurem Netzwerk
verbunden habt, also hier im Menü auf
Netzwerk, gibt Bato Serra den
Share-Ordner im Netzwerk frei.
Ja, das ist mit Sicherheit sinnvoller.
Da kann man dann die Linux-Distribution
drauf kopieren.
Müsstet ihr dann Bato Serra sehen und wenn
ihr da drauf klickt, dann seid ihr
da drin und dann könnt ihr ROMs übers
Netzwerk auf Bato Serra kopieren.
Richtig schön wird es, wenn ihr noch Videos
und Bilder zu den einzelnen Spielen einbindet,
die kann Bato Serra auch automatisch runterladen
über den sogenannten Scraper.
Ja, und ihr solltet auf jeden Fall auch noch ein Theme runterladen,
das euch gefällt.
Das geht hier im Hauptmenü unter Updates und Downloads
und dann Themes.
Und am Ende kann das so aussehen.
Ha, schön.
Ach so, ja, ja.
Retro Achievements unterstützt Bato Serra
und damit der Automat natürlich auch.
Liebe ich ja persönlich,
weil es noch so eine zusätzliche Spaßkomponente einbaut.
Wenn ich Next 4 am Windows auslesen will,
mache ich das in der Regel so,
Ich starte meine Linux VM und USB passt durch das, was ich auslesen will.
Wie spielt sich das Ding jetzt? Kann ich nur sagen, gut.
Ich hatte mir die Controller-Haptik wirklich schlechter vorgestellt, aber ich mag die Buttons ganz gerne.
Die haben einen ziemlich langen Hub, klingen so ein bisschen klapperig, aber ich finde die befriedigend, muss ich sagen.
Die Joysticks sind mir vielleicht etwas zu leichtgängig, sind auch wirklich gut geschmiert, kann man hier sehen.
Aber ich kann da trotzdem okay drauf spielen.
Das ist alles keine Sanwa, super Qualität, aber auch nicht viel schlechter.
Auch sehr gut finde ich das Soundsystem, das hat richtig Wumms.
Kann man richtig laut machen.
Und auch super, dass da ein direkt zugänglicher Lautstärkeregler eingebaut ist.
Das Display ist allerdings, ja, billig.
Also das ist so ein richtiges Steinzeit-LCD mit hoher Blickwinkelabhängigkeit.
Gerade bei diesen ollen Dingern, bei den alten Spielen,
willst du ja eigentlich eher was haben, was richtig
schnell reagiert.
Du willst ja da keinen Delay oder
irgendwas haben oder schlieren oder sowas.
Ein CRT wäre natürlich am
nicest.
Also ich hatte am Anfang gedacht, dass man wahrscheinlich
die Controller austauschen muss, wenn man
da langfristig Spaß haben will. Aber
jetzt würde ich sagen, es ist eher das Display.
Also wenn ich mir aussuchen könnte, besserer
Monitor oder bessere Controller,
würde ich auf jeden Fall den Bildschirm nehmen. Vielleicht etwas größer, OLED wäre cool, aber ja,
ist natürlich alles auch deutlich teurer. Aber das Gute ist ja, dass das alles Standard-Hardware ist,
mit Standard-Schnittstellen. Man kann also völlig problemlos zum Beispiel ein Raspi 5
oder ein x86 PC da einbauen. Ist alles USB, HDMI und Klinkenbuchse. Und das haben auch viele schon
gemacht. Seht ihr hier in diesen Videos. Also das Teil gemoddet, zum Beispiel mit so einem nicen
Marquis-Display da oben drauf.
Hätte ich auch gerne, aber
ich muss auch sagen, ich habe Hemmungen,
viel Geld da reinzustecken, weil
die Basis, also das Gehäuse,
mir einfach zu klapprig ist. Wenn ich
mir so Edelbuttons und Edel-Displays
einbauen will, dann doch lieber
auch in so ein passendes Edel-
Gehäuse. Also ich nutze das Teil
auf jeden Fall jetzt erstmal ohne Modding,
weil es definitiv auch so... Ich glaube,
ja, da ist schon was dran.
Also wenn man sich so ein Ding komplett holt für
350 Euro, dann ist es wahrscheinlich
auch am besten, man benutzt es komplett und schraubt nicht
groß dran um.
Schon doll Spaß macht, gerade in so einer Büroumgebung.
Weil, wenn du da das Display ausbaust, das Ding ist
wahrscheinlich danach Schrott,
wenn du nicht aufpasst.
Ist der Stream bei mir nicht synced oder ist das YouTube-Video
bei mir ist alles super
synced.
Gucken wir mal, ob wir irgendwelche
Wir haben auch keine Frame-Drops oder sonst was.
Also eigentlich sollte das alles wunderbar
in Sync sein.
die ich getestet habe. In den USA
gibt es übrigens auch noch
eine sogenannte XT, die ich getestet habe.
Ich hör gerade an, die Streifen
passen nicht richtig aneinander, aber doch, machen sie.
In den USA gibt es übrigens auch noch
eine sogenannte XT. Ja, Hardware ist dabei.
In Raspberry Pi 4
war glaube ich dabei.
XT-Version vom
Iconic Arcade mit größerem Display
und so einem lizenzierten Gehäusedesign.
Die scheinen hier aber bislang
nicht in den Handel zu kommen.
Ohnehin finde ich ein bisschen komisch,
dass auf der Website die europäischen Produkte gar nicht mehr gelistet sind
und man im Iconic-Webshop auch gar keine Produkte mehr sieht.
Beziehungsweise nur so Beispiel-T-Shirts.
Also es ist alles ein bisschen suspekt, sag ich mal.
Ich bin mir nicht so sicher, was so die Zukunft der Firma angeht.
Muss man mal gucken.
Aber wie gesagt, Preis-Leistungs-Verhältnis.
Ja, Preis-Leistung ist doch super.
Da kann man nichts sagen.
Euro. Ja, kann man nicht meckern.
Halt für so Leute wie mich, die nicht super viel Geld ausgeben wollen,
wie für solche High-End-Dinger.
hier zum Beispiel von Umbrella Arcades, auch wenn die natürlich sehr nice sind,
aber die kosten halt das Zehnfache.
Da läuft auch Bato Serra drauf.
Also rein spielerisch wahrscheinlich kein großer Unterschied.
Wenn ihr handwerklich begabt seid, könnt ihr natürlich auch sowas machen,
wie mein Kollege Johannes von May.
Das ist hier so ein Tischmodell aus feinster Walnuss.
Ist auch schön.
So viele Möglichkeiten.
Aber eigentlich ist ja nur eins wichtig.
Hauptsache, ihr habt Spaß.
Schreibt gerne in die Kommentare, ob ich...
Also für mich ist das nix.
Ich hab da keinen
so Kindheitswunsch
irgendwie seit der Kindheit
nach so einem
Arcade-Automat, aber wenn man in dem
Zeitraum
aufgewachsen ist
und sich das ja immer
gewünscht hat, ist das preis-leistungsmäßig
mega pock.
Ja, also finde ich auch nicht schlecht.
Nein, nein, das gucken wir jetzt nicht.
Wir gucken jetzt mal, was YouTube uns sonst noch empfiehlt.
Kona.
Genau, das Video von Morpheus
wollte ich mir hier angucken. 31 Minuten,
Alter.
Pagge mir das.
Okay.
Dann wollen wir mal.
Wenn wir da nicht anfangen, brauchen wir noch länger.
Wie alt du bist, ohne dich zu identifizieren.
Oh nein, oh nein, es geht um Alterskontrolle, please.
Ich kann es noch mal hören.
Ohne dich zu registrieren.
Gesetzgeber in der EU...
Ich habe mich ja schon oft genug zu ausgelasen.
Habe jetzt keinen Bock.
... den USA und im Bundestag arbeiten gerade gleichzeitig Angesetzen,
die jedes Betriebssystem zwingen sollen,
bei der Einrichtung vorerst nur dein Alter abzufragen.
Und ja, das schließt Linux mit ein.
Aber es geht ja hier um Social-Media-Verbot.
Das heißt, da wird noch mehr kommen als diese Altersverifikation. Wie gesagt, ich denke ja auch, also ich denke mal, dass da jetzt drauf zu sprechen kommen wird, ich denke ja auch, dass das nur ein Vorbote ist, was da noch in Zukunft auf uns zukommt.
Ja, On wegen Social Media Verbot, Klarnamenpflicht, Chatkontrolle, was auch immer.
Das wird ja gerne so unter dem Deck, wobei, komm, bevor ich jetzt lange drüber rumlabere, wir gucken uns einfach an, was Morpheus dazu sagt.
Ich habe mir so ein System gebaut, wie ich es will, mit den Tools, die ich will, ohne dass mir jemand reinreden kann.
Denn das ist digitale Souveränität.
Das ist das, was alle in Deutschland eigentlich mehr haben wollen.
Und die steht jetzt zur Disposition.
Das Ganze wird verkauft als Kinderschutz.
Mal wieder natürlich.
Aber ich sage euch, das hat mit.
Das ist ja immer so.
Das liegt aber auch daran, weil da keiner was dagegen sagen kann.
Da kann keiner was dagegen sagen.
Das ist halt das Ding.
Es gibt ein paar Sachen, die immer gesagt werden.
Es wird gesagt, zum Schutz der Kinder, zum Schutz vor Terrorismus.
Es gibt so ein paar Sachen, die kommen immer so als Begründung.
Natürlich kann man diese ganzen Sachen für viel, viel mehr verwenden.
Und was mich ja mal interessieren würde, weiß gar nicht, ob das irgendjemand mal untersucht hat.
Es ist ja nicht das Erste, was eingeführt wurde, Schutz vor Terrorismus, Kinderschützen und so.
Also wie viel denn jetzt wirklich von dem, was auch gebracht hat.
Ich behaupte mal, dass bei den meisten Sachen, die es mittlerweile gibt, die eingeführt wurden,
kaum dazu geführt haben, dass das eingetreten ist, wie es ursprünglich verkauft wurde.
Und am Ende wird es für irgendwelche Bagatellen verwendet,
weil irgendjemand, irgendein Politiker als Sternchen, was auch immer, Kopf oder so beleidigt hat und dann die Polizei vor der Tür steht oder was auch immer. Das wird ganz schnell zweckentfremdet. Mein Lieblingsbeispiel dafür ist ja immer, hat jetzt nicht direkt, wie soll ich sagen, das an sich ist nichts Schlimmes, aber man sieht daran, dass man nichts drauf geben kann.
während der korona zeit wurde ja in restaurants um die infektionsketten besser nachvollziehen zu
können was ich auch sinnvoll fand ja haben sich auch viele darüber aufgeregt aber ich fand es
an sich nicht verkehrt wurde erfasst so wer ins restaurant gegangen ist wie man die leute
kontaktieren kann und sowas bei infektionen fand ich eigentlich ganz sinnvoll es wurde aber dazu
gesagt dass das streng zweckgebunden ist und nur zum nachverfolgen von infektionsketten verwendet
wird hat natürlich auch keiner was dagegen gesagt war auch so und den konnten wir in der zeit auch
nicht richtig was dagegen sagen und das hat nicht lange gedauert da kam glaube ich sogar die
bayerische polizei um die ecke hat gesagt ach wir hätten jetzt aber auch gerne zur strafverfolgung
und für diese sachen zugriff auf die daten ist jetzt in diesem einzelnen fall vielleicht gar
gar nicht weiter will, vielleicht sogar ganz sinnvoll, aber man sieht, man kann sich auf solche Aussagen nicht verlassen.
Und wo Daten erstmal erhoben werden oder wo es erstmal Infrastruktur gibt,
dann wird die über kurz oder lang auch für andere Sachen gebraucht oder sogar missbraucht.
Kinderschutz ungefähr so viel zu tun wie ein Apfel mit Apple.
In der Ubuntu-Community wird sogar bereits diskutiert, wie man damit umgehen soll und teilweise ist es wirklich hilarious.
Und eine Sache muss ich jetzt auch nochmal an der Stelle loswerden. Man sollte vorsichtig sein. Ich muss das anders sagen. Man sollte vorsichtig sein. Man ist schnell dabei, wenn es der eigenen Überzeugung entspricht, so Sachen gut zu finden.
Also sprich, wenn es sich gegen die Leute richtet, jetzt gerade, die man nicht abkann, dann ist man immer schnell dabei zu sagen, jawohl, richtig, das muss gemacht werden.
Man muss sich aber immer mal im Hinterkopf behalten, sobald Kontrollmechanismen und Datenbanken und irgendwelche Überwachungsdinger geschaffen sind, der Wind kann sich auch ganz schnell drehen und morgen ist man selber dran.
Also man sollte sich diese Sachen immer mal kritisch überlegen, okay, will man das wirklich haben?
Ist das so eine gute Idee?
Und nur weil es heute gegen Leute verwendet wird, die man selbst nicht abkann, heißt das nicht, dass es nicht morgen gegen einen selbst verwendet werden kann.
Canonical, die Macher von Ubuntu, haben sogar offiziell bestätigt, dass sie das Gesetz jetzt rechtlich prüfen wollen.
Und bevor ihr jetzt denkt, es wird ein Video, wo euch irgend so ein Techie erklärt, warum sich Eltern keine Sorgen machen sollen, auf gar keinen Fall.
Ich verstehe die Angst komplett.
Ich finde auch generell, Eltern sollten sich da mehr drum kümmern.
Du kannst nicht erwarten, dass dir alles abgenommen wird.
Du musst den Kindern schon selbst beibringen, es ist vielleicht keine gute Idee, auf manche Webseiten zu gehen.
Oder es ist auch keine gute Idee, sich von shady Seiten irgendwelche Roblox-Plugins zu laden oder sonst was.
Was auf TikTok beispielsweise passiert, der hat jedes Recht besorgt zu sein.
Das Problem ist nicht die Sorge, das Problem ist in diesem Fall, wie so üblich, die Antwort.
Okay, also was passiert eigentlich gerade?
In den letzten Wochen hat sich in Deutschland eine Dynamik aufgebaut, die ich so in der Geschwindigkeit nicht erwartet habe.
Zumindest nicht von Deutschland.
Die SPD hat Mitte Februar ein Impulspapier veröffentlicht mit dem Titel
Ja, die SPD kann mich immer.
Darin fordern sie ein komplettes Social Media Verbot für alle unter 14.
So ein Bullshit, Alter.
Wisst ihr, oh, da gibt's was.
Oh, damit könnte man was Schlimmes anstellen.
Oh, das müssen wir verbieten.
Fällt denen wirklich nichts ein, außer man muss den Scheiß verbieten?
Ich meine, in Australien machen sie das ja schon.
In Australien hat das so gut wie nichts gebracht.
Das juckt keinen.
Und mal ganz davon abgesehen.
Eine Sache, die ich finde, kommt da ein bisschen zu kurz.
Social Media
ist ein
wie soll man sagen
ein essentieller Bestandteil
des Lebens
für jüngere Leute
da können wir jetzt nicht herkommen
und dass die Boomer quasi dann sagen
wir
verbieten das
Moin Michael, 5 Spilian
Das ist so komplett Realitäts...
An der Realität vorbei einfach.
die Wallet oder EUDI Wallet erfolgen sollen.
Haben wir nicht mittlerweile schon mit dem Auswahl...
Okay, die haben vielleicht noch kein Auswahl, aber...
Das heißt, wir brauchen jetzt hier wieder eine Datenbank zentral
mit Leuten und Geburtsdatum und hast du nicht gesehen?
Digitale Brieftasche, in der dann auch sowas wie Perso und Führerschein gespeichert werden sollen.
Und weil ja auch die Digitalprojekte in der EU, in Deutschland immer so gut funktioniert haben.
Was macht eigentlich die elektronische Gesundheitsakte so?
Nicht nur für Kinder, auch für alle Bürger ab 16, also auch für Erwachsene,
soll eine anonyme Altersgruppenverifikation per EUDI-Wallet notwendig werden,
um Social Media überhaupt erst benutzen zu können.
Klar, sonst kann man es ja nicht prüfen.
Die Standardeinstellung ist in diesem Fall ja verbieten und nicht mehr erlauben.
Die SPD betont, dass die Plattformen dabei nur die Altersgruppe erfahren,
nicht die Identität, was so zumindest
sein muss. Ja, ja gut, ja gut,
ich gehe mir jetzt mal
davon aus, dass das sogar stimmt,
aber das heißt ja auf jeden Fall schon mal,
man hat eine zentrale
Datenbank,
wo das drinnen erfasst ist
und das drinnen steht.
Das ist ungefähr so das Gleiche,
wie die Leute sagen, naja, ich
packe alle Sachen in die Cloud,
aber da hat ja keiner Zugriff drauf.
Das
gibt es mehrere Probleme dran.
erstens, warum hat da keiner Zugriff drauf?
Also, weil der Hersteller sagt, weil der Hersteller das sagt,
weil der Hersteller sagt, oh, wir verschlüsseln clientmäßig.
Und selbst wenn man das Sicherste macht, was es gibt,
wenn man Sachen in die Cloud packen will,
das quasi lokal verschlüsseln und dann in die Cloud packen,
wer sagt denn, dass es in 20 Jahren nicht Probleme
in dem jeweiligen Verschlüsselungsalgorithmus gibt,
mit dem man das da hochgeladen hat?
Wie wahrscheinlich das jetzt sein wird, das weißt du ja nicht.
Gab es ja oft genug, so 3DES
wurde auch nicht richtig geknackt.
Aber Computer wurden einfach zu schnell.
Und
deswegen
ist oftmals das Sinnvollste,
wenn die Daten
nicht euer Zuhause
im Endeffekt verlassen, dann sind
sie per Default sicher,
weil sie sind ja nicht weg.
Sie sind ja nicht irgendwo
nicht theoretisch
verfügbar. Die sind bei euch.
Das, was am besten ist, man gibt den ganzen Scheiß erst gar nicht raus,
dann kann auch nichts verloren gehen.
Und ich bilde mir sogar ein,
es gab vor ein paar Jahren einen Versuch
mit so einer zentralen Datenbank.
Ich glaube in Südkorea,
Und da wurden Daten geleakt.
Das kommt bei uns ja auch laufend vor, ja?
Es vergeht ja quasi kein Monat, dass irgendwelche Datenleaks bekannt werden.
Kann, das haben wir uns gemeinsam schon in einem Video über die Kryptografie der Altersverifikation angesehen,
aber das Grundprinzip bleibt bestehen.
Ohne staatliche Wallet kein Zugang.
Die CDU zieht nach.
Auf ihrem Parteitag Ende Februar haben sie beschlossen, dass auch sie eine Altersbegrenzung wollen.
Friedrich Merz unterstützt das öffentlich, das habt ihr wahrscheinlich mitgekriegt.
Und Vizekanzler Lars Klingbeil ist auch dafür.
Wir verbieten beispielsweise Alkohol.
Wir wissen auch, dass man irgendwie trotzdem als Jugendlicher oder als junger Mensch an Alkohol drankommt.
Trotzdem verbieten wir es.
Und diese Debatte müssen wir auch bei Social Media führen.
Die Justizministerin Stefanie Hubig ist...
Ich versuche den Gedankengang gerade irgendwie nachzuvollziehen.
Dann kannst du auch Messer verbieten.
Weil mit Messern kannst du andere Leute abstechen.
Also, du kannst alles irgendwie für negative Sachen verwenden.
Und dass wir uns gesellschaftlich jetzt für ein paar Dinge entschieden haben, die besonders schädlich sind, ja, was weiß ich, rauchen, Alkohol trinken und das kontrollieren, heißt ja nicht, dass man alles kontrollieren muss.
Auch dafür also quasi Konsens innerhalb einer Koalition. Ungewöhnlich.
Bildungs- und Familienministerin Karin Brien geht sogar vor den Bundestag und sagt wörtlich, es gebe einen wissenschaftlichen Konsens, dass Social Media Konsum bei Kindern zum Teil dramatische negative Auswirkungen auf die neurologische Entwicklung hat.
Ey, viel, viel vager kannst du das doch kaum formulieren.
Ja, ich gehe sogar davon aus, dass es Studien gibt.
Und mich würde es auch tatsächlich nicht wundern,
wenn übermäßige Zeit auf Social Media negative Auswirkungen auf Kinder
und generell nicht nur auf Kinder, auf alle haben kann.
Ich kenne diese Studien, aber ich würde mich nicht wundern, wenn das so ist.
Aber das ist was, mit dem wir leben müssen, mit dem wir lernen müssen,
umzugehen und wo man nicht sagen kann, wir müssen das verbieten.
Das ist essentieller Bestandteil des normalen Lebens von ganz vielen Leuten mittlerweile.
Die Leute müssen lernen, das ordentlich zu benutzen und nicht ausgeschlossen werden davon.
Das Problem ist, dieser Konsens existiert so in der Wissenschaft nicht.
Netzpolitik.org hat ihre Rede Punkt für Punkt auseinandergenommen und ich fasse das mal zusammen.
Das volle Ding ist für euch verlinkt unten.
Die Metastudien zeigen eine Korrelation und keine Kausalität.
Das ist ein ziemlich großer Unterschied.
Die Korrelation besagt, Kinder, die viel am Bildschirm sind, haben häufiger...
Auf dem Ausweis bin ich mir ehrlich gesagt gar nicht so sicher, da könnte das so sein,
aber mit dieser EU-Wallet-App ist es dann auf jeden Fall nicht mehr so.
Da muss es ja dann eine zentrale Datenbank geben.
Mich fuckt es übrigens schon ab, dass man Fingerabdrücke abgeben muss für den Ausweis.
Das sehe ich auch nicht ein.
Angststörung. Sie sagt aber nicht, ob der Bildschirm die Ursache ist oder ob ängstliche Kinder sich einfach häufiger mit dem Bildschirm ablenken, weil sie draußen hassen.
Das weiß einfach schlicht niemand mit sich hand.
Ich kann euch sagen, man kann Angststörungen auch von anderem Zeug bekommen als von Bildschirmmocken.
Ich weiß wovon ich rede. Aus absolut schwachsinnigen Gründen.
Wir warten ja bei Medikamenten auch nicht auf perfekte Kausalbeweise, bevor wir sie dann für Kinder zum Beispiel einschränken.
einschränken. Warum sollte das hier anders sein? Das ist tatsächlich das stärkste Argument der Verbotsseite und es ist tatsächlich nicht dumm.
Vorsorgeprinzip sagt wahrscheinlich die meisten was. Aber hier ist der Unterschied. Wenn wir ein Medikament vom Markt nehmen, entsteht keine Überwachungsinfrastruktur,
die hinterher für völlig andere Zwecke benutzt werden kann.
Nebenwirkungen sozusagen, die schlimmer sind als das Problem selber bzw. das Problem nicht mal lösen. Und das Absurde daran ist, die Bundesregierung hat selbst eine
Expertenkommission einberufen,
die bis zum Sommer Empfehlungen erarbeiten
soll. Die sollen also genau
ein Arbeitskreis sozusagen
diese wissenschaftlich noch offenen
Fragen klären. Oder wie man
das heutzutage nennt, Think Tank.
Ich finde dieses Wort
so schlimm. Sondern prescht
vor, weil sie eben Kinder schützen wollen
und das ist politisch unverwundbar.
Dagegen kann kein Abgeordneter stimmen, ohne
Karriere. Das ist ja das, was ich vorhin auch meinte.
Mit der Argumentation kommst
du irgendwie immer durch.
Ich habe vor Jahren schon ein Video über die CDU und ihre Digitalpolitik gemacht.
Über Überwachung, über Staatsrojaner, über das systematische Sammeln von Sicherheitslücken, statt sie zu schließen.
Und natürlich kommt jetzt dieselbe Partei und will eine digitale Ausweispflicht für das Internet einführen.
Ganz ehrlich, ich bin mir noch nicht mal so sicher, ob das so eine alleinige CDU-Geschichte ist.
Wenn sie es könnten, würden es wahrscheinlich alle machen.
Mehr Kontrolle und Überwachung stehen sie alle drauf.
Jugendschutz. Die Ironie schreibt sich ein bisschen von selber.
Wir haben aber sogar
Vergleichsbeispiele. Australien,
Frankreich, England, Deutschland,
über 20 US-Bundesstaaten,
alle haben... Übrigens, Chats, Chats, wo ich das gerade sehe,
ich wusste
jahrzehntelang nicht, wie man dieses hier richtig
ausspricht. Das ist ein
Bundes... Wie heißt Bundesstaat
in den USA? Wisst ihr,
wie man das richtig ausspricht?
Ich dachte früher immer, man spricht das...
Genau!
Meistertyp-Kid.
So spricht man das aus.
Ich dachte früher, man spricht das Arkansas oder so aus.
Das ist Arkansas.
Ja.
Wie räumen wir mal auf diese...
Whatever, ja?
Kansas spricht man genauso aus,
wie es geschrieben wird.
Deswegen dachte ich auch früher, es heißt Arkansas.
Sehr ähnliche, fast identische
Gesetze verabschiedet oder zumindest angestoßen. Und das kam mir komisch vor. Deswegen die Frage
hier von mir, hat da vielleicht jemand nachgeholfen? Und tatsächlich, wenn man dem Geld folgt,
dann geht es hier nicht mehr wirklich um Kinderschutz, sondern um Verantwortung.
Wer hätte das gedacht?
Wenn wir allerdings auf diesem Kanal über Cybersecurity sprechen, denken viele immer
an komplexe Hacks. Aber die Realität ist meistens sehr viel primitiver. Der lukrativste Angriff
heute gegen Privatpersonen ist Identitätsdiebstahl.
Niemand muss besonders Code schreiben oder sich an irgendwelchen krassen Tools bedienen.
Kriminelle bedienen sich ganz einfach an dem, was das Internet über euch ausspuckt.
Also ein vergessenes PDF vom Verein oder ein Leak mit eurer Nummer.
Und schon sind Kredite in eurem Namen aufgenommen oder eure Familie wird mit erschreckendem Insiderwissen am Telefon gescampt.
Die einzige effektive Verteidigung ist es, eure Spuren möglichst loszuwerden und euch aus dem Internet zu entfernen,
wo ihr es nicht haben wollt. Und genau hier kommt
Incogni ins Spiel. Es geht darum, eure
digitale Präsenz einfach aufzuhalten.
Ach komm, wir lassen die Werbung mal. Wir gucken uns auch so das ganze Video an.
Und Angriffsflächen zu minimieren. Denn wer nicht
gefunden wird, kann auch nicht so leicht angegriffen werden.
Das wichtigste Werkzeug dafür ist das
Custom Removal Feature, relativ neu
bei Incogni. Jeder kennt dieses
Gefühl, man googelt sich selbst und findet dann plötzlich
Informationen, die man lieber nicht gefunden hätte.
Irgendwelche alten Fotos.
Ich...
Es gibt von mir super cringe Beiträge
in alten Newsgroups.
da habe ich
da habe ich damals
zu N64
Zeiten
habe ich mich drüber lustig
gemacht, das ist so richtig cringe
Alter, ich war so ein richtig nerviges
Kackkind, so was so
so Gelaber im Internet angeht
also ich würde mir heute richtig auf den Sack gehen
da habe ich in irgendwelchen
Newsgroups gepostet, wie schlecht die
anderen Leute sind, weil sie in irgendwelchen
N64 spielen
irgendwelche Sachen nicht haben.
Einer hat in Mario 64 nicht 120 Sterne.
Alter, wie schlecht kann man sein und sowas.
So Dinge habe ich damals gepostet.
Richtig cringe Sachen.
Richtig kleines Kinderscheiße.
Ich habe mal danach gesucht
und habe die alten Dinger gefunden.
Das ist so cringe, was ich damals für Kack geschrieben habe.
So, haha, lol, wer hat denn nicht 120 Sterne?
Seid ihr schlecht oder was?
So Dinger in der Richtung, hab ich dann da gepostet.
Das ist richtig zum Fremdschämen, wenn ich das heute lese.
Eine ehemalige Uni oder Adressen auf einer völlig fremden Seite.
Statt euch also mühselig durch Impressum-Daten zu wühlen und die Ignoranz der Befreiung zu ertragen, kopiert ihr dann einfach den Link, schickt ihn an Incogni und deren Datenschutz-Team übernimmt für euch den kompletten rechtlichen Kampf.
Bevor wir weitermachen, will ich nochmal ganz ehrlich Danke sagen an Incogni. Wir arbeiten jetzt seit über einem Jahr zusammen und es sind eben genau solche Partner, die diesen Kanal hier finanzieren und dadurch überhaupt ermöglichen und uns die Freiheit geben, so tief in solche aufwendigen Recherchen einzutauchen.
Deswegen vielen, vielen Dank für den Support.
Ohne euch wäre das wirklich alles nicht machbar.
Holt euch eure Daten zurück.
Wenn wir uns das Video mal angucken.
32 Minuten heute vielleicht nicht.
Können wir das nächste Mal machen.
Neben mir als QR-Code.
Und mit dem Code Morpheus spart ihr sogar nochmal volle 60% auf den Jahresplan.
Was ich persönlich sehr geil finde.
Deswegen sichert euch damit ab.
Also 20 Länder, fast identische Gesetze.
Das ist kein Zufall.
All diese Gesetze klingen nicht nur verdammt ähnlich.
Sie klingen wirklich verdächtig gleich.
Als hätte jemand eine gewisse Vorlage geschrieben und dann Ländernamen ausgetauscht.
Und genau das ist quasi passiert.
Um zu verstehen, was hier wirklich passiert ist...
Da wurde wieder hart Lobbyarbeit geleistet, hä?
Einmal in die USA gucken.
Vor ein paar Jahren hat Apple eine neue Funktion eingeführt.
App Tracking Transparency.
Wenn ihr ein iPhone habt, kennt ihr das wahrscheinlich.
Ich kannte es nicht.
Diese Frage, ob eine App euch über andere Apps hinweg tracken darf.
Ein simpler Klick auf Nein und plötzlich kann euch Facebook nicht mehr verfolgen.
Also was ihr auf anderen Websites oder in anderen Apps macht.
Und für euch ist das mega geil, für Meta war das aber eine Katastrophe.
Ich finde das schlecht, ja. Das kann ich mir vorstellen.
Insgesamt ist Geschäftsmodell basiert auf personalisierter Werbung und zu fragen, ob ja oder nein, ist nicht so leicht mit Ja zu beantworten.
Apples Tracking-Schutz hat Meta nach eigenen Angaben allein 2022 rund 10 Milliarden Dollar an Werbeeinnahmen gekostet.
Und über mehrere Jahre kumuliert ist das natürlich deutlich mehr.
Und jetzt passiert was, das man so ein bisschen als Vergeltungsschlag sehen kann.
Meta investiert 2025 eine Rekordsumme von über 26 Millionen Dollar allein in Lobbying, nur auf US-Bundesebene.
Das ist mehr als Lockheed-Marken ausgibt, das ist mehr als Boeing und das ist sogar mehr als Apple und Microsoft zusammen.
Und wofür?
Ah, das heißt, die haben an den richtigen Stellen mal ein paar Urlaube spendiert.
Und ein, sorry, Seminare abgehalten natürlich.
Was passiert eigentlich, fällt mir gerade ein,
mit App-Stores
wie
wie heißt
der App-Store, wo es
die Open-Source-Sachen auf Android gibt?
Das grüne, mit dem grünen Logo.
Droid?
F-Droid.
Was machen denn solche App-Stores
dann eigentlich? Die können doch gleich dicht machen.
Oder einfach die Länder blocken.
Die können das doch im Leben nicht umsetzen.
Richtung eines Accounts. Euer Alter
verifizieren und dann in den Apps
nur noch so ein Signal weiterleiten.
So eine Art Alterstoken.
Ist es ein Kind, ein Teenager oder
eben ein Erwachsener? Meta will
das. Aber warum will Meta
genau das unbedingt? Naja,
in den USA gibt es ein Gesetz
namens COPPA, den Children's
Online Privacy Protection Act.
Der besagt, wenn ein Unternehmen
wissentlich Daten, das wird wichtig,
von unter 13... Da muss man echt mal sagen,
so ein Video, was Morpheus hier macht,
33 Minuten, das ist echt aufwendig, ne?
Also nicht nur die Videobearbeitung, du musst den ganzen Kempel dir zusammensuchen.
Dann drohen ganz massive Strafen.
Meta hat Milliarden von Accounts.
Die Branchenvereinigung ACT hat ausgerechnet, dass die theoretischen ungefähren Strafzahlungen für Meta in zweistelliger Milliardenhöhe ungefähr bei 50 Milliarden liegen könnten,
wenn Meta gezwungen wäre, sein Netzwerk proaktiv nach minderjährigen Nutzern zu durchsuchen.
Und auch bei uns in der EU steht Meta vor Gericht, wegen genau diesen süchtig machenden Algorithmen,
wegen mangelndem Jugendschutz und wegen dem DMA, dem Digital Markets Act.
Und auch bei uns stehen übrigens 6% des weltweiten Jahresumsatzes und damit auch zweistellige Milliardenbeträge als Strafe aus.
Es sieht aktuell wirklich nicht gut aus für Meta.
Vor allem, weil sie sogar Studien genau zu diesem Thema haben verschwinden lassen.
Und genau deshalb wird Meta hier richtig, richtig clever.
In den Gesetzen, die Meta durchdrückt, steht eine sogenannte Safe Harbor Klausel, die besagt, wenn ein App-Entwickler sich in gutem Glauben auf das Alterssignal verlassen kann, das er vom App Store bekommt, dann kann er nicht haftbar gemacht werden.
Metas wissentliche Kenntnis über das Alter der User wird damit juristisch komplett neutralisiert.
Dadurch wandert das komplette Haftungsrisiko zu...
Ah, die können da Hände hoch machen, so so, nee, das konnte ich ja nicht wissen.
Google, die App-Store-Betreiber.
Meta schreibt also ganz gezielt Gesetze, die sie selbst entlasten, aber ihre Konkurrenten belasten
und lobbyiert gleichzeitig gegen Gesetze wie den Kids Online Safety Act, der Meta selbst regulieren würde.
Klar, das wäre ja Arbeit.
Aber das Üble hört hier leider überhaupt nicht auf.
Meta finanziert nämlich nicht nur offen die Lobby-Kampagnen,
sondern verdeckt auch eine Organisation namens Digital Childhood Alliance.
Die tritt auf wie eine besorgte Bürgerinitiative für...
Also wenn man eine Sache gelernt hat, auf Namen kann man nichts geben.
Das, was sich am stärksten immer dafür anhört, ist meistens dagegen.
Aber wenn man sich anschaut, wen die attackieren, dann stellt man fest, eigentlich ausschließlich Erdnuss.
Das sind genauso wie Operationen in irgendwelchen Kriegen.
So okay, wir starten jetzt mal hier irgendwie eine Invasion irgendwo anders hin und dann nennen wir das irgendwas mit Freedom in der Operation.
Google, Meta wird nie erwähnt. Deren Website ging keine 24 Stunden nach der Domainregistrierung live, fertig und natürlich sexy designt, mit Statistiken und Testimonials.
98 Tage später wurde das erste Gesetz unterschrieben, auf dem deren Talking Points standen.
Das nennt man AstroTurfing, eine Fake-Graswurzelbewegung, bezahlt von dem Konzern, der am meisten davon profitiert.
Google hat übrigens öffentlich gegengeschossen und in einem Policy-Beitrag gesagt, dass genau diese Gesetze darauf abzielen, Verantwortung von den Plattformen auf die App-Stores auszulagern und dass sie all das Informationen an Millionen von Entwicklern verteilen würden, auch an mich, der sie eigentlich nicht mehr braucht, mit allen Missbrauchsrisiken, die das eben mit sich bringt.
Und jetzt kommt ein wichtiges Detail, das mir wirklich aufgefallen ist und das in der ganzen Debatte ein bisschen untergegangen ist.
Die EU hat über den Digital Markets Act Apple dazu gezwungen, alternative App Stores zuzulassen.
Das fand Apple nicht so geil.
Das heißt, dadurch könnt ihr jetzt unter iOS auch Apps installieren, die nicht vom App Store von Apple kommen.
Ich weiß, dass man das theoretisch machen kann.
Gemacht habe ich trotzdem noch nicht.
Zum Beispiel von dem von Epic wegen Fortnite.
Eine Errungenschaft also gegen Apples Monopol, damit sie nicht mehr mit uns Entwicklern machen können, was sie wollen.
Ich sag nur, 100 Euro jährlich und das neue Update für den Morphreader ist bei Apple noch immer nicht durch, während Android schon zwei Updates weiter ist.
Aber jetzt soll der App Store plötzlich der einzige Gatekeeper für Altersverifikation werden.
Denn ein Store, der Open Source und ohne Account funktioniert, kann so ein Signal ja gar nicht liefern.
Er speichert ja keine Registrierung von uns.
Ach guck mal, das ist doch F-Droid, oder? Ist das nicht das F-Droid Logo?
Ups.
Ja.
Geht's am Ende.
Das heißt, die Regulierung, die Apple öffnen sollte, wird von der nächsten Regulierung quasi wieder direkt sabotiert.
Und davon profitiert natürlich auch vor allem Meta und Apple so ein bisschen.
Meta hat nämlich keinen eigenen App Store.
Noch viel schlimmer ist aber, das eigentliche Problem bleibt dadurch komplett ungelöst.
Denn selbst wenn morgen jedes Kind perfekt am App-Store-Eingang kontrolliert werden würde, was passiert hinter der Tür?
Der Algorithmus, das endlose Scrollen, das Autoplay und die algorithmische Radikalisierung, all das bleibt für Erwachsene zumindest genauso toxisch wie vorher.
Wenn Meta das Problem durch Auslassen von Kindern an der Eingangstüre löst, müssen sie ihr Kernprodukt nie ändern.
Das heißt, keine Algorithmus-Reformen und die Dark-Patterns bleiben auch bestehen.
Die Frage ist, funktioniert das überhaupt?
Naja, die beste Antwort kommt von einem Land, das es schon versucht hat und das wäre Australien.
Australien hat am 10. Dezember 2025, ist noch gar nicht so lange her, das weltweit erste komplette Social Media Verbot für Untersechse.
In Australien hat es kaum was gebracht.
...Jährige scharf geschaltet.
Also die Leute benutzen es trotzdem noch.
Instagram, TikTok, Snapchat, Reddit, X, YouTube, Threads, Twitch und Kik, alles gesperrt.
Plattformen, die keine angemessenen Maßnahmen zur Alterskontrolle ergreifen, drohen Strafen von bis zu 49...
Dürfen die eigentlich YouTube gucken? Und Twitch gucken? In Australien noch? Oder ist das nicht social genug?
...1,5 Millionen australische Dollar.
Premierminister Anthony Albanese hat sich dafür ziemlich gefeiert.
Dadurch wurden 4,7 Millionen Accounts deaktiviert, entfernt oder eingeschränkt.
Laut den Selbstauskünften der Plattform.
Aber die Realität drei Monate später sieht ein bisschen anders aus.
Ein Bericht des Analysedienstes Custodio, veröffentlicht von Reuters im März, zeigt, immer noch nutzen rund 20% der australischen Teenager TikTok und Snapchat aktiv.
Also jeder fünfte trotz Verbot.
Und ich weiß, was jetzt man sich von euch denkt.
Leute, ich hab ein Problem. Ich muss jetzt gleich essen.
egal wie kommt das video trotzdem fertig das kann das ein bisschen abkühlen 80
prozent halten sich ja immerhin dran wir schaffen ja auch keine tempo limits ab
nur weil übrigens ist ja was heute gibt chat der klassiker ist heute wieder am
start einer der zwei klassiker ist heute am
start bolognese korrekt
Du bist neu, ja schön, dass du am Start bist.
Hast du dich zu Battlefield 6 geäußert?
Öfters schon, ja, aber ich habe Battlefield 6,
ich habe es gekauft, ich habe es noch nicht gespielt
und ich habe auch keinen Bock, es zu spielen.
Es könnte mich vielleicht tatsächlich überzeugen noch,
falls die wirklich einen Serverbrowser einbauen,
also einen richtigen, persistenten Serverbrowser,
sodass man dann auf Servern spielt, wo man die Leute kennt und sowas,
da hätte ich schon Bock drauf.
aber so wie es jetzt aktuell ist vor allem schaffen sie auch irgendwie die
hälfte der entwickler schon wieder rausgeschmissen kommt auch kaum content nach naja
ein paar raser haben guter punkt aber das problem ist die infrastruktur die wir dafür aufbauen die
am ende für alle gilt ja wie übrigens na ja natürlich vpn hätte gedacht am tag des krafttretens
wird noch wichtig keine sorge hat allein der anbieter windstrip einen anstieg der installation
von VPNs in Australien um 500% gemeldet.
Wer hätte das nur ahnen können?
Da waren australische Suchanfragen nach VPNs
in der Woche vor dem Verbot auf dem höchsten Stand seit 10 Jahren.
Und naja, wenn man das jetzt weiterdenkt,
was ist die logische Konsequenz?
Naja, in Deutschland hat die SPD bereits angedeutet,
dass man VPNs regulieren oder einschränken müsste.
Sag mal, fällt denen wirklich nichts anderes mehr ein?
Jeder Scheiß, den es gibt, wird direkt verboten oder was?
so, oh, da, hm, da gibt's was Neues,
oh, das müssen wir verbieten,
und das nächste, ja gut, aber dann müsste man das auch noch,
das müsste auch noch verboten werden.
WTF, Alter, VPNs verbieten,
das ist ja sowas von hirnrissig.
Ob, das ist eine vollkommen legitime
Anwendung, mal ganz davon abgesehen,
dass ganz viele Businessleute auch
VPNs verwenden, wenn das verboten,
ganz ehrlich,
also,
Also man entdeckt, was Überwachung, Kontrolle und sowas angeht, doch deutlich die letzten Jahrzehnte vielleicht, ja, immer mehr parallel zu China und solchen Ländern.
Wenn Jugendliche das Verbot damit umgehen. VPNs einschränken. Tolle Idee. Das ist ungefähr genau das, was China oder Russland oder Nordkorea machen.
Und VPNs kommen bei weitem übrigens nicht nur privat zum Einsatz.
Wir haben einen in unserem eigenen Netzwerk. Firmen haben welche fürs Homeoffice.
VPNs kann man ungefähr so schlecht verbieten wie SSH-Zugang zu einem fremden PC, denn das braucht es einfach für Infrastruktur, für die Arbeit.
Regulieren würde also heißen, man muss eine Lizenz für VPN beantragen oder wie genau darf ich das verstehen, liebe SPD?
Die Gesichtserkennungssoftware zur Altersschätzung funktioniert in der Praxis übrigens genauso wenig.
Sie ist demografisch verzerrt, das heißt bei People of Color oder bei Leuten mit Gesichtsanomalien funktioniert es einfach sehr viel schlechter.
Und Tests haben gezeigt, dass man ähnliche Systeme teilweise durch Fake-Werte oder Make-Up täuschen kann.
Dokumentiert etwa übrigens bei Roblox, das ironischerweise selbst nicht mal unter das australische Verbot fällt.
Und es gibt diesen...
Ausgerechnet Roblox, Alter.
Fallen.
Roblox ist ja die schlimmste Plattform von allen.
Das Ganze perfekt illustriert.
Ein 14-jähriger Junge in Australien hatte sein Alter mal eben auf Snapchat auf 25 gesetzt, wie wahrscheinlich die Hälfte von euch bei YouTube.
Der Account lief weiter. Seine Mutter hat Snapchat kontaktiert und die haben sich geweigert, den Account zu löschen, weil er ist ja 25.
Erst nach einer Medienanfrage von Guardian haben sie reagiert.
Zwei 15-jährige Teenager haben daraufhin mit Unterstützung des Digital Freedom Project eine Klage vor dem australischen High Court eingereicht.
Sie argumentieren, dass das pauschale Verbot ihre verfassungsmäßig implizierte Freiheit der politischen Kommunikation verletzt, weil soziale Medien für junge Menschen die primäre Quelle für politische Informationen sind.
Ich finde, das ist ein gutes Argument, ja.
Wie gesagt, ich bin auch der Meinung, dass Social Media, das ist das wirklich essentielle Bestandteil vom täglichen Leben von vielen Leuten. Das kannst du nicht einfach verbieten.
Das habe ich auch nicht verstanden, was da Discord geritten hat.
Wie gesagt, kurz zusammengefasst, Discord wollte eine globale Altersverifikation einführen mit Gesichtsscans und Ausweiskontrollen.
In einem begrenzten Test in Großbritannien im Januar setzt...
Ach, gibt's das nicht mehr?
Haben die da jetzt irgendwie davon abgelassen oder was?
Ich dachte, das ist immer noch so.
Sie da für den Drittanbieter Persona ein.
Persona nebenbei bemerkt finanziert von Peter Thiels Founders Fund, dem Investor, der auch Mitgründer des Überwachungsunternehmens Palantir ist.
Die kennt ihr ja.
Und Sicherheitsforscher fanden dann heraus, dass Persona weit über die bloße Altersschätzung hinausging.
Abgleiche mit Regierungswatchlists, 269 verschiedene Verifikationschecks, Speicherung von biometrischen Scans, IP-Adressen, Gerätefingerabdrücke für bis zu drei Jahre.
Das alles übrigens nachdem im Oktober 25 bei einem Datenleak des Discord-Kundendienstleisters 5CA die Ausweisdokumente, Selfies und IP-Adressen von etwa 70.000 Nutzer aufgelegt wurden.
Die über das alte Support-Ticket-System für Altersverifikation eingereicht worden waren.
Da haben sich den richtigen rausgesucht.
Das ist nochmal ein separater Vorfall, unabhängig von Persona, aber trotzdem. Daten sind da, Daten werden gestohlen.
Genau, das ist das, was ich vorhin auch meinte.
Das Beste ist, man gibt den Kram gar nicht erst raus, weil dann kann auch nichts geklaut werden.
Die Community hat natürlich revoltiert.
Massenhafte Nitro-Stornierungen, Accountlöschung und TeamSpeak hat übrigens sogar gemeldet,
dass deren Hosting-Kapazitäten in den USA an die Grenzen kamen und viele Leute sind rübergewechselt.
Und das Ergebnis ist jetzt, Discord hat die globale Altersverifikation auf die zweite Hälfte des Jahres verwendet.
Es gibt immer noch viele Leute, die verwenden 2026 TeamSpeak, ne?
Also ganz viele Pro-Gamers.
verschoben oder potenziell sogar noch länger.
Persona wurde übrigens komplett rausgeworfen
und sie haben in einem Blogpost zugegeben,
dass sie bei ihrer grundlegendsten Aufgabe versagt hätten,
nämlich klar zu kommunizieren, was sie tun und warum.
Aber warum hat Discord das auf Ende 2026 verschoben?
Offizielle Antwort ist, wir brauchen mehr Zeit,
aber es könnte auch sein, dass man auf eine gewisse Infrastruktur wartet,
die eben gerade aufgebaut wird.
Auf die EU-DI-Wallets und auf die App Store Signals aus den USA.
Denn wenn der Staat oder ein App Store Betreiber
die Verifikation übernehmen muss, Discord das ja nicht mehr selber machen und riskieren dadurch
keinen zweiten PR-Albtraum. Und bisschen ist die Situation... Ja und vor allem kann Discord ja dann
sagen, ja Moment, wir halten uns doch nur an Gesetze und Vorgaben. Wie üblich irgendwie,
Lobbykrieg in den USA, ein gescheitertes Experiment, paar Desaster, aber alles ein
bisschen weiter weg. Denn die Infrastruktur, die ja gebaut wird, betrifft eben leider nicht nur
Kinder und auch nicht nur Social Media. Es geht danach relativ direkt weiter. Wie wird denn
eigentlich ein Alter geprüft und was ist die nächste Forderung? Kalifornien hat mit dem Gesetz
AB 1043 den Digital Age Assurance Act verabschiedet, der am 1. Januar 27 in Kraft tritt und der besagt,
jeder Anbieter eines Betriebssystems muss beim Einrichten eines Accounts das Alter des Nutzers
erfassen und dieses über eine API an alle installierte Apps weiterleiten.
Für Apple und Google kein Thema, die haben ihre geschlossenen Accountsysteme, bei denen
ist sowas ähnliches schon da quasi.
Aber was ist hier eigentlich mit Open Source?
Für Linux-Distributionen, die von Freiwilligen in ihrer Freizeit entwickelt werden, die keinen
zentralen Server haben, keinen App Store und keine Monetarisierung.
Das ist die ganze Idee hinter Open Source.
Die sollen jetzt auch eine rechtssichere, datenschutzkonforme Infrastruktur aufbauen,
um bei der Einrichtung eines Nutzeraccounts das Alter abzufragen.
Die Server übrigens, die auch ...
Ihr habt ja ... Leute, da gibt's ja wieder Riesendinger, ne?
System D hat das ja eingebaut,
dass irgendein JSON-Datenfeld ausgelesen werden kann mit dem Alter.
Da ist ja auch die Welt halb untergegangen wieder.
Dann gab's die ersten Distributionen,
die dann rausgekommen sind mit irgendwie einem gepatchten System D
oder irgendwelche haben es komplett ersetzt.
Gibt ja schon seit einer Weile Distributionen,
die ohne Systemd kommen.
Hat sich nichts großartig durchgesetzt.
Es gibt sogar einen Debian-Fork, by the way,
der keinen Systemd drin hat.
Ähm, ja.
Da wurde auch riesen Drama gemacht.
Auf Linux basieren sollen das auch.
Wohlgemerkt, das Gesetz greift formal beim Account-Setup auf dem Gerät.
Nicht beim Download.
Aber für Distribution ohne Accountsystem ist das kaum umsetzbar.
Und die Strafen sind von 2.500 bis 7.500 Dollar pro minderjährigen kalifornischen Nutzer.
In der Community kursieren deshalb absolut geile Vorschläge, die zeigen, wie absurd das eigentlich ist.
Man soll zum Beispiel eine Textartikel...
Ich habe gelesen, irgendeine...
Ich glaube, brasilianische Distro?
Oh, nee, nee.
Irgendeine Distro hat jetzt brasilianische User ausgesperrt vom Download,
weil die dort wohl auch so Gesetze in dieser Richtung haben.
Mit Altersverifikation und sowas.
Und da haben die einfach alle Leute aus Brasilien jetzt geblockt.
... unter ETC ablegen, in der einfach das Alter drinsteht.
Da kann ich dann 25 reinschreiben oder sowas.
Dann bin ich für immer 25.
Klar, die kann jeder Zwölfjährige auch mit Sudo in zwei Sekunden editieren.
Oder, bessere Idee noch.
Debus-Services, die ein Alterssignal
bereitstellen oder Geoblocking
für kalifornische IPs, weil man
einfach keinen Bock drauf hat. Aber nichts davon löst
das Problem. Aber alles davon zeigt,
dass Gesetzgeber einfach keine Ahnung haben, wie
dezentrale Technologie funktioniert. Das stimmt wohl.
Und wenn man die Sachen weiterdenkt, dann ist
die Forderung Social Media ab 14
zwar cool, aber das, was hinten drankommt,
ist ein furchtbarer Rattenschwanz.
Für GrapheneOS oder Midnight... Da kommt halt
dann das eine zum anderen. Dann
erst gibt es eine Regelung, okay,
Altersverifikation. Und das
hängelt sich dann immer so weiter, bis man
dann bei VPNs hin. Und da kommt ja wie, VPNs,
VPNs müssen auch verboten werden.
Ja, okay, und was ist jetzt mit den
Verschlüsselungsalgorithmen, die VPNs
verwenden? Ja, dann brauchen wir da auch was.
Ja.
Das kommt dann so von Hundertsten ins Tausendste.
Und am Ende
muss er dann alles verbieten.
BSD ist das Ganze noch ein bisschen
absurder. Midnight BSD hat seine
Lizenz geändert, um kalifornische
Nutzer von der Desktop-Nutzung
auszuschließen. Also direkte Reaktion auf
das Gesetz. Und naja, die EU
baut auch was. Die
Eudi-Wallet, die europäische Version
von ziemlich derselben Infrastruktur.
Die novellierte EIDAS
2.0-Verordnung verpflichtet alle EU-Mitgliedstaaten
ihren Bürgern bis
Ende diesen Jahres eine
zertifizierte digitale Brieftasche
zur Verfügung zu stellen. Das wird knapp.
Ja, das würde
ich mir auch sagen.
Weil wir immer so on time und pünktlich
und vor allem im Budget
immer bleiben bei solchen Projekten.
dafür auch schon einen Age Verification Blueprint entwickelt,
der gerade in Frankreich, Griechenland, Italien, Spanien und ich glaube Dänemark pilotiert wird.
Die Technik dahinter haben wir uns ja schon mal angeguckt,
da sollen kryptografische Zero-Knowledge-Proofs benutzt werden.
Aktuell arbeitet das System aber mit selektiver Datenfreigabe.
Die Zero-Knowledge-Proof-Integration wird gerade finalisiert.
Das Ziel ist aber, einfach nur zu bestätigen, ob jemand über 18 ist,
ohne den Namen oder das Geburtsdatum zu verraten.
Das habe ich in dem anderen Video relativ ausführlich behandelt.
Aber theoretisch klingt das erstmal datenschutzfreundlich.
Aber das Problem ist hier nicht die Kryptografie, sondern die Infrastruktur, was ich da auch schon gesagt habe.
Man muss mehr machen, denn wenn ich das einfach umgehen kann mit VPNs, naja, dann muss man VPNs regulieren.
Und sobald eine staatlich ausgegebene digitale Brieftasche das verpflichtende Instrument für alltägliche Internetnutzung ist,
vom Social Media Login bis zum Abruf von irgendwelchen anderen Medien, entsteht eine Architektur, die alles kann.
Und wenn man konsequent ist, muss man dann auch alles regulieren. Das System kann all das auch tatsächlich schon. Es kann erweitert werden auf alle Attribute.
Ich habe bei solchen Dingern ja auch, also es gibt ja, okay, einmal das Missbrauchspotenzial, so prinzipiell, ja. Aber man muss ja auch immer mal gucken, wo liegen die Daten denn? Wie ist das Ganze abgesichert, ja? Gibt es da nicht vielleicht irgendwelche Schwachstellen, wie du darauf zugreifen kannst?
Und ich habe wenig Vertrauen da in die Skills der Leute, die das betreiben, dass das alles so sicher ist.
...die wir uns vorstellen. Ob über 18 oder unter 30 oder geboren in Bielefeld, das wäre möglich.
Und der Schritt von einer freiwilligen Wallet hin zu einem Internet, das nur noch gegen Vorlage einer staatlichen Legitimation betreten werden kann, ist sehr, sehr klein.
Und der CCC warnt bereits davor, dass eine zentrale Freigabeinstanz für Internetnutzung der dezentralen Architektur des Netzes widerspricht und im schlimmsten Fall Internet-Shutdowns staatlich ermöglicht.
Im Grunde ist Anonymität im Netz das Prinzip, das unsere ganze moderne Demokratie stützt.
Ein Diskurs funktioniert nicht, wenn man Angst haben muss, dass man ausgesperrt wird, nur weil man eine Meinung vertritt.
Da gebe ich ihm komplett recht.
Ja, ich würde das sogar noch ein bisschen erweitern. Das ist wichtig, dass Leute eben sich frei äußern können und nicht Angst haben müssen, dass demnächst einer bei ihrem Arbeitgeber anruft und sagt, ey, der hat da Zeug im Internet gepostet, schmeiß den mal raus. Da gebe ich ihm komplett recht. Dass du dich anonym äußern kannst im Internet ist ganz zentral und eines der wichtigsten Sachen überhaupt.
... einem Messenger seine Identität geben muss, damit man einen Journalisten kontaktieren darf.
Und das ist leider auch keine Theorie. Auch da gibt es schon ein Experiment sozusagen.
Südkorea hat von 2007 bis 2012 eine Klarnamenpflicht im Internet getestet.
Und das Ergebnis war, naja, die Zahl der Beleidigungen...
Stimmt, ja, Südkorea. Das war, was ich vorhin meinte. Da habe ich ein bisschen Durcheinander gebracht.
Aber, ähm, wir haben das schon mal ausprobiert.
ist kaum zurückgegangen. Dafür wurden die Identitäts-Datenbanken gehackt und Millionen
echter Namen und Adressen lagen plötzlich im Netz. Südkorea hat das ganze Experiment abgebrochen,
weil sie gelernt haben. Aber selbst nach all dem bleibt danach noch eine Frage, die zeigt,
wie weit man eigentlich gehen muss. Was ist eigentlich Social Media? Die Gesetze sprechen
von Social Media Plattformen ab 14. Aber mir hat diese Frage noch niemand beantworten können,
was das eigentlich ist. Instagram, klar, okay.
TikTok, ja, natürlich. Aber schon YouTube.
YouTube hat Kommentare, Abos,
Community-Posts. Ist es Social Media?
In Australien wurde YouTube unter das
Verbot gepackt, aber... Stimmt.
Stimmt, wenn ich mir das mal so recht überlege.
Wo fängt Social Media
an und wo hört es auf?
Ist schwierig zu sagen.
Man kann YouTube-Videos ohne
Login schauen. Was machen wir da? Was bringt
dann ein Verbot? Discord fällt
in Australien explizit nicht
unter das Verbot. WhatsApp auch nicht.
Und Telegram auch nicht.
Auch Roblox nicht.
Aber all die Dinge, vor denen man Kinder schützen will,
passieren genau auf diesen Plattformen auch.
Cybergrooming passiert nachweislich
auf Roblox. Sogar vermutlich
Was? YouTube hat eine PM-Funktion?
Wirklich? Die gab's vor
Jahrzehnten gab's die mal
auf YouTube. Die haben's dann
abgeschafft.
Man kann
Private Messages mittlerweile verschicken auf YouTube.
Schlimmer als irgendwo anders. Fake News verbreiten sich über WhatsApp und Telegram.
Deepfakes laufen über Messenger. Extremismus rekrutiert über Foren, die kein Mensch als Social Media definieren würde.
Nichts davon wird von diesen Gesetzen erfasst. Noch nicht.
Und da haben wir noch nicht mal von Mastodon oder anderen dezentralen Diensten angefangen.
Ich will hier auch mal noch eine andere persönliche Geschichte teilen.
Ich war vor ein paar Jahren auf einer Messe. Damals habe ich noch reine IT-Tutorials gemacht, also Programmieren, Hacking, Cyber Security und das Ganze.
und da kamen zwei Jungs zu mir, 9 und 11 Jahre alt.
Die hatten mit meinen Videos programmieren gelernt und konnten auf Hack the Box
nicht die leichten, sondern auch die schweren Maschinen lösen.
Die waren verdammt gut in dem, was sie gemacht haben.
Das war 2022, noch bevor KI-Tools einen den Code geschrieben haben.
Und die haben das alles selbst gelernt, über YouTube, über Online-Plattformen und über Communities.
Unter dem geplanten Verbot hätten die beiden keinen Zugang gehabt zu diesen Ressourcen,
die sie zu dem gemacht haben, was sie waren.
Und das gilt wirklich für viele Lerninhalte, für viele Schüler war und ist eine der wichtigsten Bildungsmöglichkeiten Social Media.
Das stimmt. Ja, da ist was dran. Das stimmt wohl.
Und generell muss ich sagen, also Großteil von aktuellen Infos habe ich von Reddit, von Twitter, ich nenne es immer noch Twitter.
ihr wisst ja
xformallyknown as twitter
ähm
und sonstige Sachen
wenn das jetzt nicht mehr so einfach möglich ist
und das ist ja auch für jüngere
wichtige Infos
auch größte Quelle für Fehlinformationen
wird überall Mist gepostet
Man muss halt gucken, dass man das halbwegs gescheit einschätzen kann.
Das gehört halt dabei.
Das ist wie bei allem.
Du musst den Kram ordentlich benutzen können.
Genauso wie ich euch mittlerweile schon nach zwei Sätzen sagen kann,
ob das ein AI-Slop-Artikel ist oder nicht.
Man kann auch alles verbieten, dann hat man das Problem nicht.
Hat aber auch nicht die Vorteile davon.
Eine weitere Sache, die nicht bedacht wird.
Ich selbst bin auf dem Autismus-Spektrum.
Als Jugendlicher kannst du das nicht einschätzen. Ich glaube mal, die Jugendlichen können das in der Regel deutlich besser einschätzen als irgendwelche Boomer-Leute in meinem Alter oder älter.
Und ich habe das auf dem Kanal auch schon offen thematisiert. Für Leute wie mich sind digitale Räume keine nette Ergänzung zum echten Leben. Auch schon als Teenager übrigens. Die sind oft der einzige Ort, an dem soziale Interaktion funktioniert.
Das stimmt wohl.
komplett verausgaben muss in australien wo er das gerade sagt eigentlich müsste ich auch mal
so ein test machen ich bin ja auch das typische antisoziale keller kind müsste auch mal irgendein
autismus test machen da liege ich bestimmt auch knapp drauf waren und behindertenverbände wie
advocacy for inclusion und cyda schon jetzt das pauschale social media verbote jugendliche mit
Einschränkungen isolieren und ihnen wichtige
Zugänge nehmen könnten.
Ja, aus dem Gesichtspunkt
habe ich das noch gar nicht gesehen.
Boomer sind
mittlerweile kompetenter als Jugendliche.
In was?
In technischen Sachen. Ich meine,
ihr kennt ja meine Meinung dazu.
Ich bin eh der Meinung, so wirklich gut
auskennen, tut sich eigentlich nur meine Generation,
vielleicht die Generation davor und danach.
Die Neuen, die Alten
kommen damit überhaupt nicht klar, weil für die ist das
komplett Neuland. Und die Jungen nehmen es
einfach zu sehr als gegeben hin, dass Technik
eben das macht, was sie macht, wenn sie
auf den Button drücken. Aber dass
gerade was Internet und
Social Media Kompetenz
angeht, dass da irgendwelche Omas
mehr Kompetenz
haben als 14,
15, 16, 17, 18-Jährige.
Das glaube ich nicht.
Die Omas fallen immer noch auf Enkeltricks rein.
Q-Plus-Jugendliche in konservativen
Umfeldern sind Online-Communities
manchmal der einzige sichere Raum
überhaupt. Das fällt komplett
weg. Wenn Medienkompetenz
das Problem ist, dann müssen wir aber
auch mal über Leute reden, die eigentlich
wirklich anfällig sind. Und das sind
bei Gott nicht die Teenager. Eine Studie von
Gesnegler und Tucker
von der Princeton
hat gezeigt,
dass Erwachsene über 65 fast
siebenmal so viele Fake-News-Artikel
teilen wie die jüngste
Altersgruppe. Eine PwC-Umfrage
kommt zu dem Ergebnis, dass nur
20% der über 60-Jährigen
überhaupt glauben, jemals Fake-News gelesen
zu haben. Bei den 18-29-Jährigen
sind es 55%.
Die sagen, sie waren schon mal mit Fake-News
konfrontiert. Die Jüngeren sind also deutlich...
Also was ich gerne gucke, ich
konfrontiere mich gerne mit Fake News.
Ähm,
und zwar,
ich gucke gerne so
Verschwörungstheorien-Debunked-Videos.
Weil ich mir da immer
an den Kopf greifen muss, was die Leute teilweise
für einen Scheiß erzählen.
So, am liebsten gucke ich irgendwelche
ähm,
Flat Earth-Debunked-Videos
oder, wisst ihr,
was der Mandela-Effekt ist,
das ist auch so ein Verschwörungsding.
Da drehen
sie auch komplett am Rad.
Scientology ist ja
bei uns in Frankfurt um die Ecke.
Mandela-Effekt
ist,
also es gibt
Leute, die behaupten,
dass die
Geschichte
oder dass sich permanent
das alles ändert.
Also zum Beispiel,
das ist immer so mein Lieblingsbeispiel dazu,
viele denken ja,
dass Darth Vader sagt,
Luke, ich bin dein Vater.
Wenn man sich das mal anguckt,
dann sagt er das gar nicht.
Und dann gibt es die Leute, die sagen,
okay, da habe ich das wohl falsch im Kopf
oder haben das halt viele Leute irgendwie falsch im Kopf.
Und es gibt aber Leute,
die sagen, nein,
das, was im Kopf ist, ist richtig,
in Wirklichkeit
hat sich die Geschichte verändert.
Das ist so diese
Mandela-Effekt-Verschwörungstheorie.
Und es
gibt auch Leute, die behaupten,
permanent, dass,
die behaupten, dass sich permanent
die Kontinente,
die Kontinente
der Erde
bewegen. Also, okay, das ist
keine Verschwörungstheorie, das ist so.
Die Kontinente bewegen sich, aber die
behaupten, die Kontinente bewegen sich ganz
schnell. Und da habe ich
letztens ein Video geguckt von einem,
der hat sich die Karte angeguckt
und ist dann irgendwie runtergescrollt zu
Australien, ich glaube, das habe ich schon mal erzählt.
Der ist dann irgendwie runtergescrollt zu Australien
und war irgendwie der Meinung,
er hat im Kopf, dass das,
keine Ahnung, Neuseeland und Australien
und so, dass die viel weiter
weg sind voneinander. Und
da hat er in seinem Video gesagt,
das ist überhaupt nicht so.
Australia has moved.
I repeat, Australia has moved.
Und er war voll davon überzeugt,
dass das, was er in seinem Kopf
hat, vor der Position
von Neuseeland und Australien das Richtige ist,
aber das, was du auf
Google Earth siehst, das ist falsch.
Also die
Geschichte hat sich geändert, nicht das, was
er im Kopf hat.
So Videos gucke ich mir immer gerne an, weil
da kann ich mich so
heftig drüber weg, KekW,
was die Leute teilweise für ein Blödsinn
erzählen.
Das ist
Hartz IV TV für Pseudo-Intellektuelle.
Ja, ja, irgendwo schon.
Aber ich gucke das gerne.
Ich gucke das gerne.
Da greife ich mir immer so an den Kopf.
Wie bescheuert kann man sein?
...problembewusster.
Das ist so absurd, ich will das noch ein bisschen absurder machen
und zitiere hier Bayerns Digitalminister Mehring einmal ganz kurz.
Das beste Argument gegen pauschale Digitalverbote für junge Menschen
ist das Nutzerverhalten der Babyboomer-Generation.
Aber die Babyboomer werden nicht reguliert.
Die werden nicht vermeintlich geschützt,
weil Senioren erziehen ist politisch einfach nicht so verkaufbar
und naja, Kinderschützen funktioniert ja auf jedem Wahlplakat.
Also fassen wir mal zusammen.
Meta schreibt Gesetze, um nicht haften zu müssen.
Die Politik kopiert sie, weil Kinderschützer...
Motorlearner, exakt das wäre so ein Fall, ja.
Max FPS hat auf YouTube immer Cloud Passwort Manager empfohlen, hast du im Kopf.
Aber die Geschichte hat sich geändert.
Das heißt, du musst jetzt sagen, du hast recht und das hat sich nachträglich geändert.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie man auf so Ideen kommen kann, aber da gibt es wirklich Leute, die glauben da fest dran.
Oder was ich auch toll finde, sind die Leute, die...
Das ist top, das lese ich auch öfters.
Das ist kein Rage-Bait, die meinen das ernst.
Was ich auch immer geil finde, ist, die Leute, die angeblich irgendwelche Beweise finden bei Raketenstarts von SpaceX oder so,
wo die sagen, guck, das ist der Moment, wo die Rakete gegen den Dome,
wo die Rakete den Dome gehittert hat.
Weil da gehen ja manche von aus, dass das quasi eine unsichtbare,
was auch immer, was auch immer, was für ein Material das Ganze sein soll,
Kuppel über der Erde ist.
Und die Raketen, die prallen immer von der Kuppel ab
und deswegen fliegen die dann immer so schräg weiter.
Und die meinen das wirklich ernst?
Ja.
... noch immer zieht, die Technik scheitert flächendeckend und die Verbote werden ganz einfach umgangen.
Und die, die am härtesten getroffen werden, sind nicht die, die der Algorithmus radikalisiert,
sondern die, die auf digitale Räume angewiesen sind.
Und was, wenn das eigentliche Problem gar nicht die Altersverifikation ist?
Was, wenn es ein Gesetz gäbe, das eigentlich schon genau die Probleme löst,
sondern niemand setzt es halt einfach durch?
Das, was laut Studien und Experten...
Hast du schon jemals im Real Life getroffen, der sowas glaubt?
Also, das jetzt explizit nicht mit dem Dome.
Ich glaube auch, dass diese Flat Earth Geschichte eher was in Richtung USA ist.
Aber ich habe schon Leute getroffen, die an Chemtrails und sowas glauben.
Es gibt ganz merkwürdige Sachen.
Mein Nachbar, ja, mein Nachbar ist auch der Meinung gewesen, Corona ist eine Strafe Gottes.
Das ist kein Spaß, ja.
Also es gibt schon sehr viel abgedrehte Sachen, die man so permanent um sich drum herum hat.
Und ich habe auch eine Frage, die ich mir auch immer wieder stellen würde.
So, jetzt kommen wir mal aufs Video fertig.
... nachweislich tatsächlich schadet, wird von keinem einzigen dieser neuen Ideen adressiert.
Und das sind ganz einfach die Algorithmen, Infinite Scro-
Wie die Flat Earthers Satelliten erklären, das ist klar.
Flat Earthers erklären alle Sachen, die nicht reinpassen, mit Perspektive oder mit CGI.
3. Autoplay und algorithmisch personalisierte Feeds, die auf maximales Engagement optimiert sind und dadurch natürlich süchtig machend werden und auch bewiesenermaßen Extremismus fördern.
Und naja, das ist es, was in den Gerichtsverfahren in den USA zunehmend als suchtbildend auch für Kinder angegriffen wird.
New York arbeitet gerade konkret an Regeln, wie Plattformen solche Mechaniken bei Minderjährigen begrenzen müssen.
Und eigentlich hat sogar die SPD das in ihrem eigenen Impulspapier sogar geschrieben.
Algorithmen sollen per Default deaktiviert sein.
Das klingt erstmal gut.
Aber die Umsetzung ist ein bisschen fraghaft.
Denn über den DSA, den Digital Services Act, läuft genau das schon auf EU-Ebene.
Auch die nicht profilbasierten Empfehlungen stehen da schon drin.
Das Gesetz existiert seit 2024.
Es ist ein Kraftgefühl.
Juckt aber keinen.
Es zielt eigentlich genau auf das richtige Problem.
Nicht den Zugang, sondern den Algorithmus.
Aber es wird halt nicht durchgesetzt.
Warum nicht? Weil, naja, Algorithmen sind halt das Geschäftsmodell.
Meta wird niemals freiwillig den Algorithmus reformieren, der das Unternehmen profitabel macht.
Nö.
Die investieren sehr viel lieber natürlich Millionen in Lobbying, um eine Alterskontrolle an der Eingangstür durchzudrücken,
die sie selbst eben auch nicht durchführen müssen.
Was hinter der Tür passiert, sollte natürlich nicht angetastet werden, wenn es nach innen geht.
Und genau das ist das eigentliche Problem.
Die Politik bekommt halt ihren Symbolsieg wieder, aber Meta behält sein Geschäftsmodell.
Das Schädliche ist, Apple und Google übernehmen die Haftung und wir, also alle von uns, bekommen eine neue Identitätsstruktur, die erstmal nur das Alter testet, aber logisch gedacht auch sehr schnell sehr viel weiter geht.
Heute für Kinder, morgen für Pornografie, wie beispielsweise in UK, übermorgen für das gesamte Internet.
Ja, und danach für irgendwelche Beleidigungen von Politiker oder für irgendwelche anderen unwichtigen Dinger.
Wenn die Infrastruktur erstmal da ist, wird sie benutzt.
... eigentlich alles für den Austausch da ist online.
Und dann ist die Klarnahmenpflicht auch nicht mehr weit und das VPN-Verbot.
Die Infrastruktur, die gerade weltweit aufgebaut wird, die Eudi-Wallets, die App Store Signals und die biometrischen Datenbanken,
die sind nicht nur für Kinderschutz benutzbar.
Die sind leider auch sehr viel ausweitbarer.
Und wenn sie einmal steht, dann wird sie auch für alles benutzt werden.
Das zeigt die Erfahrung.
Und deswegen ist das, was hier passiert, kein Jugendschutz, sondern eher Brot und Spiele.
Es ist ein Symbolgesetz, das niemandem hilft, aber allen schadet, die auf ein freies, offenes Internet angewiesen sind.
Und deswegen müssen wir das auch so benennen.
Aber, und das ist wichtig, das Framing ist nicht unbesiegbar.
Die Discord-Community hat die globale Altersverifikation innerhalb von Wochen gekippt.
In Australien klagen Teenager vor dem High Court.
Der Widerstand funktioniert schon, wenn genug Leute ihn sichtbar machen.
Wenn ihr also nach diesem Video eine Sache tun wollt, dann schickt es von mir aus gerne jemanden,
der tatsächlich glaubt, dass Social Media Verbote wirklich nur Kinder oder Eltern oder Großeltern betreffen.
Und wenn ihr mehr tun wollt, der CCC und Digital Courage arbeiten an Stellungnahmen zur Eudi-Wallet und zur Altersverifikation.
Mehr News gibt es natürlich auch immer über meinen Morphia, da kriegt ihr mal das Schnellste mit, wenn ihr da mal reingucken wollt.
Ich habe am Anfang gesagt, ich nutze Linux, weil mir niemand reinredet, wie ich mein System einrichte.
Und das will ich auch noch bitte in zehn Jahren so sagen können.
Bis zum nächsten Mal im Cyberspace.
Ciao.
Da waren viele Sachen drin, von denen ich noch keine Ahnung hatte.
Excellent.
Nee, das will ich mir nicht geben.
Das ist mir zu Realitätsbezug.
Und es ist krass, wie schlimm Online-Glücksspiele geworden sind.
Ey, ähm, mittlerweile,
das hat nicht direkt mit Glücksspielen zu tun,
aber mittlerweile sind ja die meisten,
zumindest im Counter-Strike-Umfeld,
E-Sport-Turniere, die es so gibt,
Das sind ja von irgendwelchen Skin-Trading-Seiten.
Also, gefühlt gibt es ja da kaum noch was anderes.
Aber Leute, ich habe Hunger.
Ich muss jetzt unbedingt was futtern.
Ich habe jetzt auch die Nudeln hier schon stehen.
Ich habe hier Spaghetti, Tomatensauce drüber,
Hackfleisch drin, Parmesan-Käs.
White-Pepo-Happy-Time.
Nein, nicht White-Pepo-Happy.
Äh, Pepo-Fett.
Selbstgekocht, nö.
Alles klar.
Dann sehen wir uns im nächsten Stream, Leute.
Wem es gefallen hat, kann mir gerne ein Follow da lassen.
Ich freue mich immer, wenn ihr am Start seid.
Bis dann, macht's gut. Wir sehen uns.
CU.